foreign
are you always on social media scrolling
through your feed for us if you enjoy
spending time on social media then you
might want to consider a career in
social media marketing
social media marketing has become an
essential part of modern day marketing
strategies with the increasing
competition in the online space
businesses need to leverage social media
platforms to build brand awareness
engage with their target audience and
drive conversions this has led to a
surge in demand for social media
marketing professionals job in the field
of social media marketing are diverse
ranging from social media manager to
social media strategist social media
analyst and social media advertising
specialist each role requires different
skills and experience but they all offer
exciting opportunities to work with
social media platforms and get engaging
content some of the top hiring companies
for social media marketer include
Accenture Amazon Dell and freelancer.com
salaries in the field of social media
marketing are promising with the average
salary of a social media manager being
fifty thousand dollars per year social
media advertising specialist at fifty
thousand dollars per year and social
media Analyst at sixty thousand per year
and social media strategist at sixty
five thousand dollars per year if you
have excellent communication skills
enjoy working on social media platforms
and are passionate about marketing then
a career in social media marketing could
be the perfect fit for you so why not
turn your love for social media into a
fulfilling and rewarding for you now let
me tell you about simply lens
postgraduate program in digital
marketing that is created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide we will explore SEO
SCM content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start to learn more about the course
you can check the link in the
description box below now let's check
out what we have installed for you for
this content marketing full course I'll
start this video with a 5 minute segment
introducing you to social media
marketing then we'll discuss exactly
what social media marketing is post that
we'll explore digital marketing through
Facebook later on we'll check out
Facebook ads and how to create them then
we will dive into a discussion on how to
increase Instagram followers and how to
create Instagram ads after that we'll
check out some strategies and tips to
Instagram marketing following that we'll
learn how to create and grow YouTube
channel following that we'll learn to
execute SEO operations on YouTube then
we'll go in depth on how to work with
YouTube ads finally we'll wrap up this
social media marketing full course with
some tips and tricks on social media
marketing imagine it's the year 2004.
this is Phil Phil's looking to release a
book and set up a Blog he's sure that
it'd be successful but he's only worried
about one thing he doesn't know how to
ensure that his book reaches the right
target audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads Billboards
radio Direct Mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
Phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing
the form of marketing that's a lot more
lucrative inexpensive and configurable
marketing that would enable marketers to
advertise Their audience digitally using
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails Etc among
these types social media marketing
cotfield's eye social media marketing
would give Phil the opportunity to take
advantage of social media platforms to
advertise this content to a highly
targeted audience it would help more
people learn about this book increase
the interaction with his audience It's
relatively inexpensive unless he goes
into advertising and will help him get
Marketplace insights that might help in
understanding his audience preferences
better Phil started by taking up a
certification to learn about social
media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media some of the most common
forms of content that Phil could post
would be images text posts polls and
videos
but over time Phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content Phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text the they also have a call to
action that encourages user interaction
Phil could use images from his book
advertise websites that sell his book
and more then there are text and post
ads these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from Phil's blogger as book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
you could also use video ads Phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertise his books Phil could also use
lead ads through which he could collect
information from users who are
interested in a Weekly Newsletter or
regular updates from his blog but that
wasn't the only thing Phil could do with
social media platforms he could create a
brand for himself and drive audience
interest to it engage with them create
an identity engage with content finding
content that works for him social media
platforms also allowed him the
opportunity to Target audiences based on
demographics like their age location
gender and much more and in time Phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page and by extension his blog he also
saw an increase in the number of people
who bought his book greatly increasing
his audience here are some things he
learned one to set goals that were
quantitative smart and follow a constant
deadline two to understand his audience
by engaging and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
4. using tools like buzzsumo IFTTT
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos welcome to
Simply learned YouTube channel and in
today's video we're going to talk about
social media marketing for those people
that are not really familiar with what
social media can do for you and for your
business this is the course that you
want to want to watch so we're going to
talk about what it is what you need to
know where is social media going how do
you felt do how do you develop your own
social media strategy and we will also
do a quick rundown of the most important
social media channels but before we
start let me introduce myself I am Mark
campman I am your digital navigator for
this video and if you like today's video
why don't you like the video by clicking
below and also if you want to subscribe
to our Channel click on the Subscribe
button below we would love you to be
part of our community so let's get
started are you ready for this let's
check out the topics that we will be
discussing in a bit more detail
yeah we're going to be starting with
discussing the trends in social media
what is happening where is it going what
are the most social media networking
platforms and what do we see happening
in the future we will also look at a
definition of social media marketing it
is important that you understand what
social media marketing is and what it
can do for you yeah and we look at what
I see the importance for your business
and you will also learn why you
basically can't go without social media
marketing these days yep so that's what
we will be looking out and next we will
be looking at how to develop your social
media marketing strategy yeah we're
going to look at a very simple five-step
process that you can follow to develop
your social media marketing strategy for
your business or for your personal brand
next we will be looking at a different
social media marketing platforms we will
be looking at Facebook at Twitter at
Instagram LinkedIn Pinterest
Etc and we're going to look at where are
they where are they what people are
using the platforms and I'll maybe cover
some of the cool features of the various
social media platforms that you can use
as a business
we will close this with looking at the
pros and the cons of social media
marketing there's lots of benefits you
can get from it but hey of course there
are some negatives to it as well and
then I will close with giving you some
answers to questions that I get asked a
lot when I run this social media
marketing introduction so that will give
you a full overview of what social media
marketing is and how you can benefit
from it for your own business or when
you are a um a freelancer for your
clients business or for yourself as a
social media expert or any expert that
you um that you are positioning yourself
as so that's the introduction let's get
going into the action so let me start
with a simple question
out of these four social networking apps
which one do you think the old one out
yeah when you look at Facebook Instagram
YouTube and WhatsApp which one is the
odd one out from a social media
networking app perspective
yep and the right answer of course is
WhatsApp because WhatsApp is a messaging
platform yeah and what is a messaging
platform do in between social media
platforms like Facebook Instagram and
YouTube well very simple the answer is
that WhatsApp and messenger Facebook
Messenger for instance nowadays are
considered social media apps as well
yeah so in WhatsApp you can communicate
and engage with your friends and with
groups you can promote your business in
there so they are fully blown social
media networks yeah just a little trivia
to get the the juices going so there we
have it so what I always do when I talk
about social media marketing yeah I've
um I'm talking about Trends from a from
a quite a generic perspective
I've been in digital marketing social
media from the very early days yeah I
was one of the first to demo the
internet when I worked in Silicon Valley
in 1995. yeah we call when the web was
launched in 1995 we talked about a
presentational web yeah you created a
website for your business to present
your business and that was what the web
was it was very much like one way you
could go on the web and you could find
any information that you like
yep and that you need it now in the
early 2000s we saw rep 2.0 emerging
which is the conversational web
it happened in the conversational web we
saw social media coming the episode was
Facebook was Twitter there were some
um some other social media networks that
no longer exists but it was all about
getting into conversations with your
clients or with
um with other people that share similar
interests so that was the conversational
web and that led to the growth the
phenomenal growth of social media
and then nowadays today we're talking
about web 3.0
yep and web 3.0 is what we call the
virtual reality web
Facebook bets heavily on the virtual
reality web through the metaverse it's
that important for Facebook that they
even change their name as a company they
are now called meta as a company so the
meta first is Mark Zuckerberg's Vision
to actually meet people in a virtual
world and you can see each other in this
virtual world currently probably still
with virtual reality glasses or a
virtual reality headset but where will
the future go yeah so instead of typing
text or sharing photos in your news feed
you're stepping into a virtual world
where you can meet your friends anytime
anywhere
so really exciting still a long way to
go but consider that web 3.3.0
and social being interaction engagement
is a core part for that yeah social
media although social media website
social media platforms may come and go
the basic concepts of social media they
are here to stay
yeah social media has led to a
fundamental change in the Way businesses
engage with their clients yeah and how
they interact with their clients
and we'll get deeper into that when we
go into the definition of social media
marketing for now let's look at where we
are today with the social media networks
and I always use this slide for that it
is the most popular social media
networks worldwide by monthly active
users
and I want to emphasize the monthly
active users because that is what is of
Interest
I'm not interested in how many people
have subscribed to a network there may
be robots that have subscribed to it
yeah what I am interested in is that how
many people are actually using it on a
monthly basis
and you can very clearly see yeah
Facebook of course is the biggest social
media Network platform but if I look at
this slide I see three major trends
the first Trend I see is the sheer size
of Facebook
yeah because Facebook is not just number
one when it comes to social media
networks worldwide but there is also
WhatsApp on number three there is
Instagram on number four and there is
Messenger
um as well yes so you see the sheer size
of Facebook is enormous and they are
driving the changes in social media lens
although some of the Innovation may come
from other social media Networks
yeah the
um the big Drive is
from Facebook
the second Trend that I see here is if I
look at number two which is YouTube
yeah to me that says video is one of the
most important types of content being
used in social media these days if I
combine that with the importance that
Facebook gives to video yeah there's no
doubt that video is the preferred type
of communication on social media
networks and let's look at ourselves
yeah we prefer to watch a video then
read a lengthy article yep with about a
particular topic so if you are not on a
video in your social media marketing
strategy you're really missing out on a
tremendous opportunity
yep so that's Trend number two the
importance of video and the third Trend
I see is the importance of messaging AUC
number three is Messenger you see number
five is
um there is Facebook Messenger there's
also WeChat from China yeah so it is
very important these days to understand
that messenger is considered a key
social media platform and that
businesses use messenger in their
communication and the power of using
messaging in your marketing Outreach is
that it allows you to have one-on-one
conversations with your customers you
can reach an audience yeah you can reach
a big audience through Messenger but
once they respond you get into
personalized conversations
and that is how Facebook is seeing
messenger yeah as where in messenger you
have your one-to-one communication with
your best sort of friends where on
Facebook platform itself you more have
like Community title style conversations
okay so another few things that you see
in this slide is to do of course the
emergence of the tick tock yeah you see
the presence of
um Snapchat of Twitter of Pinterest but
the main thing that I miss here actually
is where is LinkedIn on this chart
and if I look at the original graphic of
this charge you see that LinkedIn is in
there and remember LinkedIn May probably
have more than 300 million subscribers
but not all subscribers are actively
engaging and using the platform on a
monthly basis so from a monthly active
users perspective LinkedIn does not
feature on this chart and that is one of
the biggest challenges that LinkedIn has
yeah to get people to engage with the
platform
welcome back to all these social media
networks later where I'm going to give
you a quick overview of what it what it
is and what it does
okay so let's have a look at what social
media marketing actually means what is
it yeah and we got to put this in the
context of the definition of marketing
yeah I studied Marketing in the very
early days in the 80s and um my main
sort of Guru in marketing was Philip
kotler and over the years marketing has
sort of developed from traditional
marketing to online marketing but to
basic concept has not changed if you
look at the definition of marketing it's
the activity of creating
communicating
delivering and exchanging offerings
that have value for customers
yeah so you supply you deliver you
exchange products or services that have
a value for your customers
so two very important aspects here there
is value and there is customer and that
is what we capture in the marketing
concept you put the customer at the core
of what you do
yeah because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the customer
yep so take social media marketing in
that context
then the second part of the social media
marketing
sort of term is the word social media
what is social media when I explain
social media I'm using the three C's the
three C's of social media marketing and
they are content they're community and
campaigns
content is the fuel of your social media
content is the
um the currency of social media if you
have really good content that you can
share on the internet
you're using various multiple multiple
social media channels like Facebook like
YouTube or like video or like Instagram
or blogging you name it yeah people will
engage with your content
and then when people start engaging with
your content they may come back for more
content that you supply and they will
then become part of your community so
Community is a very important aspect of
your social media definition
with really good content you can create
communities
and then you can push that process by
running campaigns
yeah and a campaign makes it relevant
for businesses
because when you run a campaign you have
a goal for your campaign you have an
objective you have a star date you have
an end date
yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns
to develop your communities with really
exciting content
and then you put it into the marketing
context you do that if it's a customer
at in the core of what you do
yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media marketing
is
very basic it says the use of social
media to develop a company's brand
increase website traffic and boost sales
that is what we call social media
marketing
yeah the most important aspect here is
that you need to have an outcome you
need to have a result which is customer
related
and that is where the sales element
comes in you do this to get the customer
to do something and in the end that is
buying your product or your service
yeah so social media marketing is not
the technical
combination of your social media
networks yeah to
um to reach as many people there needs
to be a goal to it and when we talk
about marketing it comes down to selling
your product or service with a value
yeah so that HD
um kind of the call to action as it were
that comes out of your social media
marketing so keep that in mind
everything you do with your social media
marketing in the end comes down to
reaching your goals or achieving your
objectives of developing your company's
brand increasing website traffic or
growing your sales
now a big benefit that you're getting
these days in digital marketing and
social media marketing is data
is intelligence
is knowledge
in the early days of marketing the
biggest problem has always been how to
measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and they write about me
in the newspaper how do I measure the
effectiveness of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I ran
so in the early pre-internet days yeah
we the only way to measure
customer engagement as it were were
through Loyalty cards or credit cards
yeah with a loyalty card you had some
basic customer data through credit cards
you could track transactions but it's
very difficult to relate it to your
marketing then the internet emerged and
all of a sudden I could track traffic to
my website
yeah I could see how many people visit
my website are these people that visit
my website for the first time are they
returning visitors what are the most
popular pages that they see how long do
they stay on my website and are they
actually buying my products
yeah so that was a major advancement of
marketing in the early 2000s and then
when social media emerged it all of a
sudden became possible to measure
engagement
how many people are having conversations
with us I could even measure sentiments
are people positive about my brand are
they negative about my Brands I could
track the effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns
I could measure the effectiveness of my
advertising campaigns that I ran online
so today's reality is that we can
measure everything
we can measure clicks we can measure
transactions we can measure engagements
we can measure return on investments
yeah and we can now even take that a
step further through artificial
intelligence that we can actually start
making predictions how people may
respond to campaigns that we're going to
be running
so it's a very important aspect of your
digital uh your social media marketing
so as I mentioned earlier social media
is a completely new way for businesses
to engage with their customers
yeah you can no longer go without it
it's a new channel to Market it is a new
channel for engagement with your
customers it is a new channel to learn
it's a new channel to listen to find out
what's happening in the market so it's
now it's it's it's there in every aspect
of your business
and not only for the marketing
departments it's there for the sales
department it's there for Logistics it's
there for the customer service
department it's there for the HR
departments using social media for your
recruitment is a very important element
of social media marketing
yes so keep that in mind that social
media marketing is no not a fad it is
there and it's there to stay and it
touches every aspect of your business
now to summarize this there are three
areas where social media has changed
The Way businesses operate
first of all there is the connection
social media is a new way to connect
with your stakeholders
yeah and stakeholders in this case can
be customers they can be prospects
influencers your own employees using
social media for internal
and not only on a local scale this
happens nowadays on the global scale the
internet allows you to sell locally to a
global audience if you want to yeah so
you can you can
cover the world you can Target specific
audiences wherever they are so the
connection aspects the targeting aspects
yeah the markets where you want to sell
your product is opened up through social
media and that is a big benefit for
business
the second area where social media has
changed businesses fundamentally it's in
the interaction site
it's not just about connecting with your
stakeholders you can also interact with
them and they can interact with you on
their terms on their preferred platform
and remember in social media land the
customer is in the driving seat if
you're not interacting with them on
their terms you're going to miss the
train
it's not about you don't liking Facebook
or LinkedIn
yeah as long as your customers are on
Facebook you better be on Facebook
otherwise you're going to miss the vote
yeah because if you don't interact with
them they will move on to your
competitors who are very likely engaging
with them
yep so it's the connection aspect it's
the interaction aspect and then the
third part is the customer data aspect
all of this we have what we talked about
can be done and you can track every
aspect of your social media marketing at
a customer level
and it gives you the key performance
indicators like conversion ratios sales
ratios customer satisfaction ratios and
ultimately return on investment
and there are tools nowaday that let you
manage and track all these areas in one
conglomerated system
your HubSpot is for instance a tool that
you can use for that and they integrate
all your marketing and customer data and
campaigns in one system that you can use
for that
so now Having learned about these sort
of fundamentals of social media
marketing let's now have a look at how
do you put together your social media
marketing strategy how do you set it up
how do you develop it now with my over
40 years of experience in marketing
digital marketing and social media I
developed a simple five-step methodology
to set your business or to set up
yourself for social media and it's
called flirt
yeah and flirt is an acronym
flirt the first letter the f is for
focus
yeah and in the focus phase what you do
you look at various things the first
thing you do in developing your social
media marketing strategy is look at what
is your niche
what Market are you targeting
and the more you focus in your Market
your targeting your Niche the easier it
will be to reach them
yes so it's very important that you
focus on a very particular niche
once you've identified that Niche you
look at your positioning
why should they buy from you what is
your unique value proposition remember
the definition of marketing yeah the
value for your customer is key in this
and you put it in what we call a
positioning statement
you also look at your customers you
create customer personas
where you look at your customers and you
kind of map their interests their pain
points the typical questions that they
would ask so you get a good
understanding of your your customers
yes or you look at your Niche you look
at your positioning you look at your
focus I'm sorry you look at your
customers
yep and then you're going to ask
yourself why am I going to use social
media
yeah am I going to use it to build
awareness am I going to use it to drive
traffic to my website
am I going to use it to generate sales
am I going to use it to improve customer
service
am I going to use it to recruit new
staff am I going to use it to
communicate with my
um my employees
yeah so lots of reasons why you could
use social media and it's your challenge
to identify one or two objectives for
your social media
and then a very important aspect of your
social media marketing strategy even
your overall digital marketing strategy
what are the keywords that you will be
focusing on
in other words what are the key words
that you want to be recognized
recognized for Google wants to know
Facebook wants to know LinkedIn wants to
know and it's all about repetition the
more often you use those keywords the
more those social media platforms and
Google will associate you with those
keywords when people search for them
they will then show you how you're up in
the search results we call this search
engine optimization or search engine
marketing
yeah so keywords is like a whole course
in itself
but it's very important part of your
social media marketing strategy in the
focus phase
so that is the F for Focus think about
your Niche your positioning who is your
customers why are you on social media
and what are your main keywords
the next is the L for listen
listen is so important
yeah we tend to
talk too much
yeah where social media
can give you fantastic listening
opportunities
and when I say listen I mean read
articles online
listen on Facebook and on Twitter on
LinkedIn listen on Google
yeah watch videos listen to podcasts
there's dozens of ways that you can
listen online because when you listen
you learn
and when you learn you get better and
you develop
so what does that mean from you some
practical tips when it comes to
listening first you need to listen to
where your customers hang out
are your customers on Facebook are they
on Twitter are they on LinkedIn and
later in this session when we go through
the various social media platforms I'll
give you an overview of what type of
people are on the various social media
platforms
the next thing that you want to know
when you listen is who are your top 10
bloggers or influencers in your Niche do
you know your top 10 bloggers do you
know your top Instagram influences
because you want to learn from them but
you may also want to build relation with
them
to use them in your marketing Outreach
you also want to look at the trends in
your Niche Google Trends is a really
useful tool that you can check to find
out what are the trends in your niche
and you're looking at your competitors
and your customers what are they doing
what are they talking about
yes so a very important stage and if
you're doing it properly you would
actually set up a social media listening
dashboard where you bring all your
listening channels together in one
dashboard
and then instead of having to go to all
those social media networks or websites
you let them come to you Inno reader is
a very good dashboard online dashboard a
free dashboard that you can use for this
we're then looking at the eye for
integration yeah so you know your
strategy you know where your customers
are you know which social media Networks
you're going to focus on then you're
going to integrate them you're going to
set up your social media Networks you're
going to make sure the branding and the
profiles are consistent you're using
your keywords you're going to create
your content calendar
and you're going to set up your blog
blogging is very important in social
media marketing because it is the
easiest way to start creating content on
your website
and to start sharing that content
through your social media channels that
will then drive people back to your
website
yes so that is part of the integration
stage and then once you've got that all
set up you're then going to reach out
it's very important that you reach out
because if you're not reaching out then
people won't find you people won't see
you
yeah the whole essence of social media
marketing is that you create as many
touch points as possible on the internet
for people to find you
you know where they start engaging with
your content going back to your website
want to know more about you want to know
more about your content and you start
building a relationship that may then
turn into a sale
so reaching out you're going to start
sharing your content you're going to
repurpose your content so turn your blog
post into a video or into a carousel or
turn your video into a podcast or what
have you
yeah you're going to share other
people's content there's nothing wrong
with sharing content from other people
and you're going to run
campaigns
campaigns to push your content in the
channels
yeah and campaigns nowadays are no
longer sort of just posts on social
media it is a combination of organic
posts yeah where you just share your
posts on social media could be paid like
pay-per-click advertising or it could be
influencer marketing style
reaching out yeah so very important is
the reaching out stage and then of
course tracking is the icing on the cake
as it were when you track you measure
your online reputation you measure your
conversions you measure your social
media activity and engagement you're
meshing your Roi and you plan for your
next quarter
okay time to talk about the social media
marketing platforms let's have a look at
some of the most relevant ones out there
now but before that let's make sure that
you understand the essence of the social
media marketing platforms how do they
work very simple they all work according
the same concept what you do you create
an account on the social platform like
Facebook for instance you fill in your
profile
on Facebook you put in a lot of data
about yourself on Twitter a little yeah
so you fill in your profile and once
your profile is ready you're going to
connect with friends or follow and be
followed
there are some platforms when you send
somebody a connection request or a
friend request request when they accept
your mutually connected like Facebook
and like LinkedIn other platforms like
Twitter and like Instagram when you
follow somebody doesn't mean that that
person follows you
yeah so we're talking about followers
and following as it were
yep and then when you've got that you're
going to start sharing updates
and you're going to check your news feed
where you will see the updates from your
friends
now as a business every platform enables
you to create a Facebook page or to
create a page
yeah and what you want to do you create
your page you put in your company
information you brand it to your company
branding guidelines and then you get
people to follow or like your Facebook
page
or your LinkedIn page yep and then you
start sharing updates and people that
liked your page they may see your
company updates in their feeds
and this is what we call organic reach
so you do a post as a business and then
the people that follow you will see your
posts on their personal news feed
now in the early days of social media
this organic reach could be 40 to 50
percent
which means that if you have ten
thousand
followers on Facebook so 10 000 people
liked your Facebook page five thousand
of those people would see your update on
their personal news feed which is
fantastic
and that was in the early days for
social media many Brands they spent lots
of marketing building huge communities
because it was a fantastic free way of
reaching out to your Market
nowadays things have changed
Facebook has been driving this yeah
Facebook wants you to advertise on
Facebook all these social media and
platforms they have to make money so
they have advertising sort of on their
platform and they want you to use
advertising so over the years Facebook
has lowered organic reach to less than
three percent
so again if you have 10 000 people that
like your Facebook page fewer than 300
people may see your updates in their
feed
and Facebook says hey that's the way it
is we offer you a fantastic marketing
environment and we need to make money as
well so hey yeah start advertise on
Facebook to reach your entire audience
and businesses Now understand that they
now know that social media is pay to
play
to reach your audience it's no longer
relying on organic reach you have to pay
to use pay-per-click advertising or PPC
but we're going to talk about that in
the next videos
all right so it's very important that
you understand this concept of how
social media marketing platforms work
so let's start with the first one the
biggest one Facebook with 1.9 billion
active users worldwide
is that over the years the younger
generation has left Facebook
yeah why have they left Facebook because
it's not cool anymore
yeah and their parents are on it
yes if you want to reach the young teens
early 18s early 20s don't go to Facebook
you want to be on social networks like
Snapchat or Tick Tock if that's
available in your markets now there's
still markets where Facebook is enormous
yes so they are the leading social media
Network in your Market if that is the
case then of course you have to be on
Facebook but in general we can say that
the audience for Facebook is now a
slightly older audience Generation X or
Millennials it's still a really good
Network to reach these people
particularly when you talk about
consumer type products now what does
Facebook offer you as a business to use
Facebook has the Facebook page that you
can create to reach your audience
nowadays Facebook really would like you
to use Facebook groups
Facebook groups is a fantastic area in
Facebook where you can get really good
engagements
and as a business you can offer a group
to your customers as a VIP area or a
product knowledge area or a pre-launch
area or just for your customers yeah
lots of reasons lots of areas where you
can use a group to reach your customers
then there's Facebook Messenger of
course that you can use for your
business where you can set a Bots yeah
so you can have sort of automated
conversations with your customers on
Facebook messenger and there is Facebook
live
don't ignore Facebook live Facebook
loves you to use Facebook live
the beauty about using the Facebook live
it gives you sort of Buzz and engagement
before the event during the event and
after the event
yeah we call this tent poll marketing
you can build up excitement leading up
to the event and after the event as well
and then finally of course Facebook is
betting heavily on the metaphors yes so
it's Mark Zuckerberg's Vision that
instead of engaging with your friends in
the news feed you engage with them in a
virtual world now the verdict is out if
this is going to work but fact is that
although we've been talking about
virtual and augmented reality for years
it is here now yeah there's more and
more apps becoming available on your
mobile on your desktop that use
augmented reality
and virtual reality I can now download
Ikea place I think it's called where you
just open up the app you pick a product
from the catalog like a table and then
you can just position the table in your
living room
yeah and then you can move it change the
color of it or whatever you're using
augmented reality through your um your
camera
okay so that is Facebook
let's look at the next one Instagram I
love Instagram yeah a lot of users from
Facebook have gone to Instagram
why because it is a visual social media
platform and it has
inherently higher engagement than
Facebook it's easier to reach the
audience not just your friends
yeah so lots of cool features in
Instagram one of the coolest features is
the Instagram stories
yep and people now spend more time on
the stories than on the the timeline
where they see the posts so Instagram
started as a photo sharing app very
simple yeah you made a photo you put a
filter on top of it which almost felt
like you're a photographer and then you
share it with hashtags and you saw
immediately the likes coming in and
people loved it for its simplicity
and now it has grown to a fully featured
social media Network that businesses can
use to make their brand come to life via
photos and Via stories
the audience is slightly younger than
the Facebook audience but a more and
more mature audience is coming on there
as well and it's it initially it had
very much a business to Consumer Focus
but nowadays it's not just photos that
you can share you can share visuals I
can turn a blog post into a carousel of
five visuals
yep and
um in that way share really good content
so very powerful and very useful for
businesses to reach the audience that
hangs out on on Instagram
all right so that is Instagram let's
look at the next one and that is YouTube
now YouTube of course is not just for
watching video YouTube is a fantastic
social media platform to build an
audience of followers
yeah it's a great platform to monetize
your video as well by enabling
advertising to be shown before or during
your videos a lot of video creators they
do that yeah and your YouTube has a
program for that if you qualify by a
number of views that you have on your
video and number of uh and then the size
of your audience you can participate in
this program and it is a really good way
to make money on you for many content
creators now check out our earlier check
out our earlier video on how to create a
YouTube channel to find out how you can
set up a YouTube channel and how you can
use YouTube as a social media platform
YouTube is great for brand awareness and
since it's owned by Google it's also
really helpful for your search rankings
both on YouTube and on Google Google
and there's lots of different videos of
course that you can make you have videos
that do well are typical videos like
how-to videos unpacking videos
Vlogs video blogs we call them review
videos live videos lots and lots of ways
to reach the video your audience yeah on
with video on YouTube so the typical
audience that uses YouTube are basically
everybody from young to old but very
important to understand with YouTube
that people are there for a reason they
search for something they may search for
entertainment they may also search for
answers to their questions
which is different than the videos you
would have on Facebook for instance yeah
so Facebook is very good for brand
awareness where YouTube videos are very
good for
um for lead generation for instance and
for building relationship with your your
audience
good and very interesting social media
platform that emerged around 10 years
ago is Snapchat
they have around 300 plus million daily
active users
and let me tell you a bit about the
history of Snapchat Snapchat was a
response to Facebook's problems about 10
years ago in privacy
and not being cool anymore and
particularly the Privacy issue where in
those days a lot of people said who is
owning my photos on on Facebook yeah
um is it Facebook or is it myself so a
lot of people and that there's always
been a gray area
yeah combined with Facebook not being
cool anymore and you know how important
being cool is for the younger generation
yep so fata so two guys who came up with
the idea of doing something radically
different and they came up with a social
media platform Snapchat where posts
would delete themselves within 24 hours
they built a a user interface around
this which was fairly difficult to use
yeah but that was for a reason
gets they love to explain to each other
how it works and if it's complicated
enough then their parents won't be able
to get on it
yeah so kids love that idea it's too
complicated to use for my parents so I
really have my own social media worlds
yeah in Snapchat that nobody else has
access to so particularly the teens the
generations that was very uh keen and
they were very hot on the uh on Snapchat
so it was that new place for Facebook
users to go to and they grew ever since
steadily not huge but they are there and
they are a very powerful social network
particularly when you want to Target the
younger generation
now there are two major features that
they sort of drove into social media
lens which was the stories
and second the vertical videos
so you all know the concept of the story
itself deletes in 24 hours but it turned
um social media instead of sort of
scrolling through your news feed you
swipe from story to story much more
visual much more fun much more engaging
yep and you would swipe those stories
vertically and that automatically led to
using vertical video
and vertical video is a major Trend in
social media content yeah which is
picked up by
um by Tech talk as the main format for
uh for videos on Tick Tock YouTube have
short so all social media now networks
they now have stories and they have
vertical video as a key element yeah so
vertical video particularly for short 10
12 second videos which we call snackable
content is very important why would you
tilt your phone to watch a video why not
just use it vertical which is also a
quite an interesting
um sort of form factor to get a good
engagement on your videos
finally Snapchat has very Innovative
advertising features
yeah they have lenses they have stories
they have filters you can put a filter
over your face BMW had a really good
campaign to launch a new car where you
could place the car through a lens
anywhere that you liked in augmented
reality and you could actually put a
filter where you gave yourself a golden
face yeah so very powerful advertising I
think the the WhatsApp advertising
platforms is one of the best advertising
platforms out there it's also probably
one of the most expensive
advertising platforms of all social
media Networks
right so let's look at Twitter
I call Twitter SMS on steroids yeah it
was one of the first besides Facebook
one of the first social media platforms
that came out and it was a very exciting
platform when it launched
and Twitter relied heavily on celeb
celebrities using it to drive acceptance
on a global scale yeah but many music
stars rock stars actors they started
using Twitter and that drove the global
adoption of the uh the platform now what
makes Twitter so powerful there are
three aspects on Twitter first of all
you can retweet a tweet
yeah so when you send a tweet and I
follow you I receive your Tweet if I
just click on retweet it'll go to all my
followers yeah if somebody in my
follower base retweets that tweet your
Tweet can go viral without uh in in in
in minutes
yep and there's various examples of
tweets that went viral within minutes
yeah like the um which was it a selfie
tweet during the Oscar ceremony a few
years ago
yes so it is sort of retweeting is very
powerful
it also makes it instant yeah because of
this retweeting aspect news goes on in
on Twitter instantly and it shares to a
global audience instantly so that makes
it very very
powerful for news agencies as well and
for businesses a very powerful feature
of Twitter is the Twitter search
each tweet is indexed and you can search
in all the tweets you can search for the
very first tweet that was ever sent
yeah so that makes it a very powerful
for Brands to find content so Twitter is
really good for finding jobs for
instance because lots of businesses they
tweet about I'm looking for a marketing
manager or a web developer so if I
search for web developer hashtag jobs
that tweet will show up in my search
results
[Music]
had is that they did not keep up with
the developments in social media
platform functionality yeah so most
celebrities went to Instagram because
Instagram was much more visual much
better place for celebrities to engage
with their their fans so Twitter lagged
behind and in the last few years it
clearly repositioned itself
so it now is seen as a great way for
businesses to use as a communication and
service Channel with their customers and
for media companies to share the latest
news
so if you want to find out what is
happening in the world now or what
businesses are doing now or if you have
a problem with a product from a business
Twitter is the best place to be
and for you individual as I always say
you don't need to be on Twitter to tweet
but you must be on Twitter to find great
content to search
whether you want to search for jobs or
whether you're searching for
opportunities if you're a photographer
yeah and you should in London for
instance and you go to Twitter and you
search for looking for wedding
photographer London
you get a list of tweets of people who
are tweeting I'm looking for a wedding
photographer does anybody know anybody
yeah so extremely powerful to uh to use
for lead generation
right so what about Pinterest
Pinterest is a visual bookmarking
platform
it's very cool the concept is simple you
see a photo on the website that you like
yeah but you can then do you can pin
that photo on Pinterest in a board
yeah and you're not copying the photo
you're just copying the link in your
board so by doing that you can build
fantastic collections of visuals that
you like and want to organize
so I bought a house in Marrakesh a
number of years ago in Morocco and we
needed to design the interior so we had
a board with Morocco design we had a
board with Morocco riyads we had a board
with
um a tiling and what have you and we
just build up a whole collection of
ideas that we liked and then we got the
people that helped us in making the
things that we wanted and we could just
share them the links on Pinterest of the
ideas that we had worked really well
now because you can save those Boards of
course you can then share them as well
yeah so everybody can access your boards
which means that it becomes a great tool
for getting ideas and Inspirations from
boards from other people
so if you want ideas for home design or
your wedding or fashion Pinterest is a
fantastic place to get inspiration
another major benefit for businesses is
that you can put your product catalog on
Pinterest as visuals organized in boards
yep and then when people
find those products on in on Pinterest
and they click on them it will take them
to the catalog of your website where
they can buy your product so it's a
great way to drive additional traffic to
your website if you want to see a good
example for that go to the IKEA UK
Pinterest page and look at their boards
you see boards for small living room
ideas back to school Christmas holiday
celebrations and then you get lots of
ideas with um for instance for small
living rooms and then you click on some
of the products that you see and that
takes you to the
page on the Ikea catalog website where
you can buy the product
now Pinterest is very popular amongst
women amongst Millennials and it also
has very powerful advertising features
and then LinkedIn LinkedIn is serious
yeah I call LinkedIn Facebook with a tie
where Facebook is fun LinkedIn is
serious in Facebook you can get away
with a funny profile photo in LinkedIn
your photo needs to be professional
now if you go to linkedin.com
forward slash sales forward slash SSI
you get your Social selling index
and that is a score between 1 and 100 of
how good you are on LinkedIn
and you will see in the score in the
summary that our four components that
contribute to your SSI score or four
components that contribute to how well
you do on LinkedIn
so those four are your profile
here your activity level in connecting
with people
how much content you share and your
activity a level in building
relationships with people
yes so the better you do in those four
areas the higher your score your profile
of course is very important make sure
that your LinkedIn profile is as
complete as possible
now linkedin's biggest challenge as I
mentioned earlier is to get people to
engage and share content
so how does LinkedIn make money very
simple there are four areas where they
make money first of all they allow
people to upgrade their LinkedIn account
to a premium account where they get more
features
there is a whole section in LinkedIn
specifically for recruiters
yeah so a recruiting version of LinkedIn
there is a whole area for sales we call
this sales Navigator
yeah if you run a sales team that you
use LinkedIn of course you want to keep
the customer data so you're getting a
sort of customer relationship management
system within LinkedIn when you sign up
for sales Navigator and then there is
LinkedIn advertising
LinkedIn of course is best for business
to business and it's really good for
developing your personal online profile
as long as you share content through
publishing articles and sharing uh
sharing posts
so I've been operational on LinkedIn
from the very beginning and I shared
lots and lots of content and articles on
LinkedIn and I got lots of business
coming in through Linkedin
yeah we're talking about serious amounts
of business that I did by being on
LinkedIn so you've got to be on LinkedIn
if you are in business
right now one thing that I will not talk
about here is a stick talk yeah we
haven't got a slide for that but bear in
mind Tick Tock although it's not
available in India
um Tick Tock is a very important social
media Network these days which derives a
whole new format of uh of engaging and
communication but more about that that
later
right so let's look at the pros and cons
of social media what is good and what is
bad about it the biggest the biggest
advantage of social media marketing is
that it can lead you to new audiences
yeah wherever they are in the world
whatever type of business you are you
can reach them through organic paid or
influencer Outreach
yeah influencer Outreach has become a
very powerful element of your social
media marketing strategy it is about
collaborating with for instance
Instagram users with many followers to
Market your products or services
so there's the pros out there and they
are far better than the than the cons
but there are cons it's not all positive
you need to be aware that when you are
on social media you are opening yourself
up as a business people can see what you
do they can see how you do it and they
can also see when you're doing things
wrongly yeah when you're doing things
not the way it should be done it's okay
when things go well but it can be
disastrous when things go bad as we say
it takes years to build a brand
but on social media you can ruin it
overnight
yeah there's lots of examples of that
um a really
big example was that you remember the
Chinese passenger that was dragged off
of a United Airlines plane
YouTube and Twitter were bombarded with
negative and cynical posts towards
United Airlines how they dealt with that
situation
but hey those are the cons and there's
in any marketing channel that you use
there are cons but the pros far outweigh
the cons that are there it is there it
is a fantastic channel to reach new
audiences yeah and it is only going to
get bigger
right so to close here are a few answers
to questions that I get often asked in
my social media classes
so let me start with giving you a list
of the questions and then we'll do
um the answer so what is viral marketing
All About Now marketing is considered
viral when it reaches the point where
it's being shared by the public at large
rather than just its target audience
yeah so when the
um you reach more people than you intend
to reach
yeah that could be through word of mouth
or through social sharing it means your
content has gone viral
yeah and particularly on YouTube you see
when you are running a campaign for a
particular Market but then the video is
so good that it goes well beyond your
target audience
yeah that is what we call viral
marketing what is earned media earned
media refers to positive reviews or
mentions in Industry Media or user
generated content and guest posts on
third-party websites
so it is basically when other people
talk about you
other people share your content
that is what we call earned media
what are some examples of social media
marketing strategies there is one famous
one which I can highly recommend you
have a look at it is from a company
called Blendtec yeah Blendtec sells
professional blenders if you go to
Starbucks and you order a frappuccino
they blend the ice cubes with Blendtec
blenders they are industrial grade
blenders they need to be very powerful
now nobody talks about blenders online
so they came up with a um an Innovative
campaign called will it blend
yep so where they created a series of
videos where they blend everything you
want them to blend like an iPhone
comparing that with a Samsung which one
Blends the fastest
they had a Facebook page with it a
website with it campaigns with it
through that campaign they managed to
grow their revenue with over 500 percent
a very powerful campaign the Dollar
Shave Club is another good example how a
small company an online company started
to challenge the big shaving companies
yeah who charge lots and lots of money
for shaving blades
they challenged it hey come to us and
you'll buy shaving blades for one dollar
so really Innovative campaign how they
did that so how do you get started in
social media marketing
remember my flirt methodology
yeah Focus that is where you start think
about your Niche what makes you unique
think about your customers think about
your targeting
yeah so focus focus focus that is the
most important part when you get started
on your social media
then what is icky marketing sticky
marketing is a term for attractive
content that engages customers
and then influences them not only to
purchase the product but also to share
the content
yeah so it's people they like the
content so much that they it helps them
going through the buying cycle but also
they start sharing it with their friends
yeah which gives you additional traffic
to your website which may lead to
additional leads to your website for
your business now let me tell you about
simply lens postgraduate program in
digital marketing that is created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide we will explore SEO
SCM content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you'll have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start greetings everyone this is Rob
Sanders with simply learn and welcome to
today's edition today we're going to
talk about digital marketing through
Facebook
so there's lots to cover so sit back
enjoy take some notes and feel free to
comment in the comment section
so let's start out with
Facebook itself
okay so Facebook obviously social
networking platform it's been around for
a few years but it's come a long way I
mean today on Facebook you can host 360
degree videos
uh you could sell products via chatbot
you could
basically be a News Network on Facebook
I mean we've all seen the results of
that over the past few years
internationally that's where people go
to get their news so it's really come a
long way in fact you know Facebook
basically has about 1.5 billion daily
active users that's a lot of people
engaging in the network
according to HubSpot the average user
spends about 60 minutes per day on
Facebook is an hour of 24
spent just on the social media platform
now a lot of people gravitate towards
Facebook a lot of different ages
demographics countries use Facebook for
again for various reasons but despite
all its use despite all this hotspot is
reporting that only 48 percent of
marketers
think that their Facebook efforts are
effective
only 48 percent is less than half of
marketers in other words are frustrated
with Facebook you know there's a lot you
can do with Facebook and so that's what
we're going to focus today's session on
all the things that you should be doing
on Facebook to better engage with your
users okay so first thing we're going to
talk about
is really setting up the perfect
Facebook page okay so that's I think
where a lot of companies go wrong I
think people are just quick to jump onto
Facebook as a network just because their
competitors are on there somebody told
them they had to be on Facebook and then
what happens
they get a you know 50 effort
output on the Facebook page with no
updated post no information no best
practice is applied so
basically the old saying is garbage in
garbage out that's what you get when you
don't follow best practices or apply all
the best features Facebook says to offer
so really when it comes to setting up a
Facebook page you want to start with the
basics you want to have a good profile
picture first of all I mean if it's you
yes you want a picture of you but if
you're representing a company
organization you really got to give
second thought about what that profile
picture is going to be
you know obviously relevancy comes to
mind but you know is it in Good Taste is
it an updated is it fit the brand
guidelines of the organization okay then
you wanna you know you can also
accompany that profile picture with a
cover photo so again
you ask yourself you know is the cover
photo outdated is it recent is it in
good taste
and I think this is where a lot of
people go wrong
and that's really adding a good
description not a dissertation by any
means but you know a short description
that just explains what the organization
or company is all about
you know just you know common sense but
you would think that uh adding a
description wouldn't be a big deal but
you know it is a big deal because you
want people to know what you're all
about
and you want to create a good username
for your page because that's a that's a
username people are going to hopefully
remember so you want to pick wisely
there you don't want something long
something that people aren't going to
remember or misspell when they try and
type it in
you could certainly add your page to
shortcuts and when you actually set up
your page you have several roles that
you can assign to people so my advice is
if you're going to operate a Facebook
page for your organization or company
add multiple people to the page to help
out you're not going to be able to do
everything on Facebook by yourself
unless that's your sole job 24 hours a
day because there's lots and lots and
lots of things you could be doing on
Facebook
so set up a role you can play the role
of admin but you have other roles that
you can assign to other people within
the organization you can assign editors
moderators
people to handle just the advertising or
you can hire just or assign an analyst
role to people who can go in and just
look at the results of your post
so you have various page roles that you
can assign on Facebook now the other
important feature when you're working
with a Facebook page is to customize the
notifications
okay you want to be notified when
somebody responds likes engages you want
to set up notifications for your ads if
you're running Facebook ads so there's
lots of notifications so make sure you
customize those so that you're in the
know on a daily basis okay and one other
best practice that I don't necessarily
see all that often on a Facebook page
and that's adding a CTA or call to
action
so don't be afraid
to move people from the ecosystem of
Facebook to your website where likely
there's more information so add a good
call to action on the Facebook page you
can keep people within the environment
and ecosystem of Facebook or you can
move them to your website or blog or you
know somewhere else just add a CTA let
people do something when they're on your
page that's really the point of the CTA
so those are just some of the best
practices
for really setting up a Facebook page I
mean again there's lots of things you
can do we're going to talk about more of
those as we move forward but just doing
those basic things just making sure you
know you keep those photos and those
pictures up to date uh you know change
the description every once in a while
play around with the CTA you know just
continue to you know keep the page
vibrant it's like watering a plan if you
if you don't keep it updated it's gonna
die and people are going to recognize
that so you have your Facebook page you
do have an option
and if you want to reach more people on
Facebook you have the option of
advertising on Facebook
and so you have something called just
basically classic ads on Facebook so the
whole idea of advertising on Facebook is
again
if your goal is to generate more you
know likes on your page or maybe it's to
drive people directly to your website
that's basically what you can do that's
that's you have to pick what your
strategy is okay or your objective so
Facebook's going to guide you through
that process if you're interested in
advertising now the great thing I like
about Facebook advertising unlike say
paid search ads on Google is that you
can really hone in on your audience
you know it could be a specific
demographic or some a group of people
who have the same interests that you're
trying to promote
so the benefits of running advertising
on Facebook is you can really hone in on
who your audience is
you can also decide where to run your ad
I mean Facebook has an advertising
network if you will that includes
Facebook Messenger Instagram obviously
news feed uh email so there's a lot of
things that you can choose from with
Facebook so you want to be able to pick
and choose where you want to run those
ads
and Facebook advertising has multiple
types of AD formats anything from
yeah videos to to images
so you could pick your format test your
format you know the thing I also like
about Facebook advertising because
anybody who's seen my videos in the past
knows that I'm a big proponent of a b
testing So within Facebook ads manager
there are components to set up a b
testing on call to actions and so to me
that's a great feature of advertising
you always want to test what people
react to and so that's built into ads
manager
and of course when you're advertising on
Facebook you can control it all with a
budget so Facebook's going to let you
know you know basically based on who
your audience is where you're
advertising what your objective is
this is how many people you're going to
reach this is what they recommend on the
budget so you can go with a recommended
budget or you can just choose your own
budget the whole idea though Beyond
advertising on Facebook
is to really hone in on a strategy okay
why are we going to spend money on
Facebook
you know is it to generate leads again
is it just to generate more engagement
on our Facebook page so you really want
to give it some thought before you dive
in and start spending money when you do
make that dive and you do start
advertising again there's a lot of
things that you can take advantage of
with Facebook advertising
um
there's there's lead ads
you know basically allowing people to
submit a form right then and there
and there's video ads as I mentioned
video ads to me are probably going to be
the most effective and impactful of all
the forms of advertising because
that's what people want they want video
nowadays they want to be able to read
and listen and engage
you can run engagement ads you can
remarket on Facebook meaning Target
people who've already been to your
Facebook page or been to your website
you can do interest targeting meaning if
you have a group of people who have the
same interest as your organization maybe
that could be you know picking up
plastic from the ocean okay there are
probably a large amount of people on
Facebook who share that same interest I
know I do I have that interest so
there's always an interest out there to
be had and targeted
of course you have with Facebook you
have demographic targeting based on age
and gender and you have behavioral
targeting now behavioral targeting to me
is the Hidden Gem of Facebook so
for instance you could Target ads to
people who say purchased a piece of
clothing for you okay so if they
purchase you can retarget them based on
a previous behavior of purchasing a
piece of clothing I mean if you're
selling uh Health Products or beauty
products or pet products it doesn't
matter you know the behavior is all
going to be the same you can pick and
choose based on that behavior
so behavioral targeting to me is a a
good feature to take advantage of if
you're going to run Facebook ads
now another thing I like about Facebook
advertising is uh basically the use of
Carousel ads so Carousel ads are
basically multiple images or or videos
so instead of just running one video out
or one image ad you can put them
together and you can have I believe up
to 10. So within the same ad unit so you
can have a rotating
imagery if you will or Carousel of
images and so basically the what great
thing about this is It's interactive it
allows you to put more of your message
and more of your brand more of your
focus out front Okay and I found through
my experience at Carousel ads 10 along
with video ads tend to work really well
Okay so
just keep that in mind if you're going
to do Facebook advertising you know keep
some of these features in mind in terms
of Behavioral targeting demographic
targeting you know running lead ads or
Carousel ads
the other thing that you should know
about Facebook advertising is the use of
a Facebook pixel so what is that
Facebook pixel mean well it means that
if you want to drive traffic from your
advertising to your website you want to
be able to track that behavior and
that's what the Facebook pixel does it
allows you to basically track website
behavior when somebody comes from your
Facebook ad
so if you insert the Facebook pixel
directly on your website then Facebook
will be able to tell you in its own
reporting console what people have done
did they engage once they went to your
website did they convert meaning
download something fill out a form
submission purchase something okay so
keep that Facebook pixel in mind so if
you're going to run advertising on
Facebook
that's what you want to do you want to
be able to leverage that Facebook pixel
now let's switch over to some of the
other things that you can do on Facebook
and so if you have a large number of
followers a few are a popular brand or
even if you're trying to generate more
likes and more followers on your
Facebook page then you know a contest is
probably not a bad idea I mean who
doesn't like a contest so to me
you can run a Facebook contest right on
Facebook you know very simple idea but
you know if you apply some of the best
practices it could really pay off for
you so let me just run through some of
the best practices and setting up a
Facebook contest
first things first you have to choose a
price so in my opinion
I think a gift card tends to work best
as a prize
um it could be for a specific store in
the United States you know targeted in
Walmart are always good or apple if you
want to really go higher end or just
something very generic uh maybe a 25 50
gift card to Amazon where you can allow
the winner to choose what they want
regardless of the specifics gift cards
are always flexible to use okay so it
ensures that entrance
of the contest have an interest in your
products okay which you know if they
have an interest then they're going to
be easier to convert into a sale so you
want to offer something that's going to
be of interest okay
the next thing you need to do is decide
what the users have to do to enter so in
my opinion you want to make it as simple
as possible but get what you need to get
so
do they need to submit a photo you know
I've run Facebook contests in the past
for some of my clients you know photos
always tend to work because that's what
people tend to do on Facebook anyway
they submit photos
okay so a little bit more behind the
photo is you want to capture something
along with that photo so to me an email
address you know tends to work that way
you have something of value along with
that photo that way you can leverage
that email later on down the road
whether you do email marketing or
Facebook lookalike or something of that
nature
okay so you have to decide what it is
you're going to ask users to do so keep
it easy but get something of value in
return so once you've made those
preliminary decisions build your
Facebook fills your Facebook contest
page so make the contest page simple but
exciting okay so that's the whole point
you want people to enter so you want to
have a tension grabbing titles you want
to use high quality images you want to
obviously enter in the prize information
and the contest information the this the
important dates when it starts when it
ends okay you want to have that
all-important submission form again that
goes back to what are you capturing or
your caption just name and email address
or you capture a name email address City
other information like interest are you
adding questions so just be careful on
the submission form
and then you want to be able to you know
have share buttons and allow Facebook
comments as well okay so
when you build your contest page then
you obviously want to promote your
contest I'd like to think that goes
without saying that you can use other
social platforms like Twitter LinkedIn
Instagram
Tick Tock to promote the contest on
Facebook you want to get people there
and participate yeah
another option could be running the
Facebook ads for the contest that's
probably not a bad idea so remember you
can use Carousel ads or or lead ads or
you know behavioral targeting or
interest targeting
you can use all those ad features I
mentioned a couple minutes ago to help
Drive traffic to that contest page and
get contestants so obviously you run the
contest you monitor the contest Facebook
has something called Facebook insights
built in right into Facebook's platform
so you'll be able to measure the results
of the contest
and then when the contest is all said
and done
well what do you want to do well you
want to profile the winner okay so you
wanna
let everybody know hey contest is over
so and so on and you want to share those
results on Facebook and other social
networks
I mean you can even create a video
showing the winner
to generate a little bit more excitement
you can send follow-up in fact I would
even recommend you send follow-up emails
to all the people who entered into the
contest okay thank them hey that gets
you closer to getting more sales okay
and then you could tease people with a
future contest
so
at the end of the day contests are
always a good idea
to generate more excitement more brand
more Buzz
um
now moving on from the contest another
thing that you could do on Facebook is
promote your post so if you're not doing
any paid advertising however you're
posting a lot on Facebook you have the
option to promote your post and so what
does that mean so basically it's a form
of advertising using some of your
organic posts and it just allows you to
allow that post to get more visibility
okay it allows you to Market it in the
news feed so more people can see it okay
so you choose your post you set a budget
and then the post is shared to a set
number of Facebook members okay and so
you could turn it on and off that
promoted post anytime you want okay now
from my experience
promoter posts are really good uh it's a
really inexpensive way to highlight a
specific post that you feel needs
attention so if you're posting a lot and
you feel that post is going to get
buried and doesn't get the visibility
that it deserves then consider promoting
it uh it's really in my opinion cost
effective now I know that's all relevant
but promoting a post definitely
generates a lot more awareness so if you
have really something important to say
and show then consider promoting it it's
it's really that simple it's just right
there with an opposed Facebook allows
you the option to go ahead and just
promote it with said budget the other
thing you can do on Facebook it's
sponsored stories
so really sponsor stories are just short
user photo and video collections that
can be viewed a few times and they
disappear after 24 hours it's it's
really similar to
users who operate on Snapchat
that's basically the concept behind it
it's just focused around Facebook's
in-app camera okay which you can overlay
with filters and lenses just like you
can on Snapchat
and you can add some visual effects and
tags and and also you can have fun with
it basically so a sponsor story is just
you know as allows you to manipulate
videos and photos to tell a more
complete story in a more fun way
basically so have fun with sponsored
stories on Facebook
another
thing that you could take advantage of
and this is something I would recommend
is using Facebook's open graph
so what is Facebook open graph so for
those that aren't familiar it's been
around a while I think we're in 2021 so
2010 that's how long Facebook open graph
has been around it's just simply a
protocol
and what that protocol does it extracts
certain elements from your page so title
images URL and other meta information
from your website okay and what Facebook
does is pull that information and that's
what they're going to display
and social post so it allows basically
your website to communicate with
Facebook and allow you to control what
information gets said and seen in
Facebook okay or which elements of your
page you really want somebody to share
regarding your website so that's
basically what a Facebook offering graph
is okay so that's something you
implement on your own website so
moving on from Facebook open graph you
have Facebook exchange also known as fbx
okay so that's been around a few years
as well I think 2012 is uh when it
launched and it's just a platform for
advertising Services two desktop users
okay so that's the key it's it's really
for desktop users it's not available on
the Facebook mobile app okay and it just
allows you to do real-time bid purchases
it allows online advertisers really to
place ads onto Facebook sidebar or
directly onto users timeline as they
scroll down
okay so it just allows you an Advertiser
to get your product out there a little
bit more
okay so you have sponsor stories you
have open graph you have Facebook
exchange you have Facebook advertising
promoted posts you have all sorts of
options available on Facebook
I think the key thing though to remember
when you're on Facebook
is to always provide value so what do I
mean by providing value so think of it
as value-added content and so
value-added content because that's
basically what you're doing you're
promoting or pushing content on their
platform you want it to be unique and
original
uh you want it to be exclusive content
or information that your audience really
can't get anywhere else
okay so that's the whole idea behind
value-added content
you know you can repost and rehash what
other people have written but to me the
whole idea behind Facebook is to write
something really unique that really
resonates with your audience okay and if
you can do that you're probably going to
naturally gain more followers and
generate more likes and engagement on
your Facebook page
okay the other thing you want to do
along with that value-added content is
really
in my opinion I've talked about this on
other
webinar sessions with simply learn and
that's really generating or leveraging
any social media platform like a sprout
social
um or HootSuite and why do you want to
leverage those is because it allows you
to really just create a Content counter
think about the content the value-added
content you're going to publish ahead of
time and it allows you to consistently
publish at a good time and day and so
you're consistent with your publishing
and your schedule
that's the whole point Beyond using a
social media platform
if you don't not a big deal you can go
right into Facebook
just like clockwork and and publish when
you feel it's the right time to publish
I mean everybody's publishing schedule
is going to be different
everybody lives in different time zones
everybody every company's audience is
different
um and let's let's just face it that the
you know there's going to be
differentiation so there's not a set
schedule it's just what you're
comfortable with that's going to be
right for you and your audience
the key is consistency so and that's
where the social media platforms like
The Hoot Suites and the Sprout socials
come into play now a couple other things
you want to do
to take advantage of Facebook engage
with your fans meaning if somebody
comments
positively or negatively
go ahead and engage with them in a
positive manner okay you know put some
focus on relevancy when it comes to your
fans
okay so you always want to attract
people who have like-minded interest
always keep that in mind
okay now if you're trying to build more
fans and followers you could certainly
use
Graph Search and basically all graph
searches is typing something in to the
feed bar and Facebook a keyword
basically and if you type in say coffee
shops or something of that nature you
know basically Facebook's going to allow
you to see you know pages that your
friends have liked uh friends who you
know live near excuse me coffee shops
who live nearby
um so it's going to give you some
feedback and other suggestions based on
that keyword or interest
so take advantage of the graph search on
Facebook to generate like-minded
or similar Pages it allows you to find
people that you can connect with on
Facebook
now the last thing we're going to talk
about
with Facebook is metrics always my
favorite subject for those that have
listened to me for a while know that I
am big not only on just a b testing but
on measuring data
and so of course just like you know
Google analytics or any other social
networking platform Facebook has its own
set of metrics and so I'm just going to
run through some of those metrics that
you should be aware of
and so we're going to start out with
engagement
so engagement is in my opinion probably
the number one metric you want to
measure within Facebook's ecosystem not
necessarily the most important however
it is at the top of the list okay
obviously conversions are always going
to Trump everything but engagement is a
form of conversion people are engaging
with your post or with your contest or
with a video and so that's really all
engagement is it's just a number of
times somebody took action on your post
okay whether they they liked it whether
they shared it whether they left a
comment those are all forms of
Engagement so to me engagement allows
you to really see over a period of time
over a period of post how well you're
performing
and you want to leverage engagement to
make adjustments to your post I mean if
you've posted say 20 posts on Facebook
and you've got no engagement then you
probably want to Circle back and think
about
what kind of post you're writing
are you adding value-added content to
your relevant audience that's really the
key with engagement
okay reach is another metric reach is
just the number of times people have
seen your content on Facebook that's all
that's all it is
okay then excuse me reaches the number
of people your content is seen by on
Facebook so
so that's all reach is okay so reach is
a number that takes into account both
organic and paid okay so how many people
is your post really reaching whether
that be paid or organic okay and so
obviously that number you want as big as
possible so you're gonna probably start
out small but you want that to grow
because that's where the engagement part
goes in the more your post engage the
more people are going to like the more
people are going to connect with you and
the bigger your reach is going to be so
the other metric is Impressions and so
Impressions is basically the
divisibility okay of your post okay how
many people saw your post that's
impression
Okay so
you know if you're reaching 100 people
of those hundred people how many people
saw it how many Impressions did you have
now it's a hundred you obviously want a
hundred if it's ten thousand you want
ten thousand Impressions so you want as
many people possible to see that post
and if they haven't and it's an
important post then remember you have
the option to remote that post and so
that's going to give you the Boost you
need to go ahead and and get more
visibility for that specific post so you
can increase the impression counts okay
okay now the other thing you want to
measure with Facebook is referral
traffic so if you're running a contest
and sending people back to your site
where you're running Facebook ads and
sending people back to your website you
want to leverage Google analytics or
similar tool to measure how much
referral traffic Facebook actually drove
okay so that to me is key if you're
driving traffic back to your website so
always keep that in mind okay how much
traffic is Facebook really driving and
more importantly of the traffic that's
going to my website how much of that is
converting so that's something you want
to look at
of course if you're running a Facebook
page and you're not doing any Facebook
advertising page likes or something you
want to keep a tab on okay how many
people liked or followed you directly on
your page okay obviously you want that
number to grow over time
and again it goes hand in hand with the
the amount of content and the
value-added content that you're posting
on Facebook okay so obviously with
Facebook ads or organic post on Facebook
you have the option of videos and so if
you're going to post videos then you
want to be able to see retention meaning
what percentage of your videos were
watched okay and so to me that's
important because if I post a good video
and it's a 30 seconds
and I didn't get that many people to
watch it then what does that say about
the quality of the video or if vice
versa if I have a two minute video and I
have a large percentage of the people
who only saw say 25 to 30 seconds what
does that tell you you need to kind of
compress that video down so retention to
me is an important metric on Facebook
related to videos and then obviously
engagement
remember I said earlier that most people
like to engage with videos on Facebook
and so you want to be able to measure
the amount of likes shares or comments
that that video received so retention
engagement are both available for videos
on Facebook
and then rounding out the metrics when
you're doing Facebook ads
you're going to have some key metrics
that you're going to want to measure
okay aside from cost you want to really
measure click-through rate and click the
rate basically is just the percentage of
people that saw your ad and then clicked
on your ad that's all click-through rate
is okay so you want a very high click
the rate obviously if 100 people sell
your ad you obviously want 100 people to
click on that
okay the thing about Facebook
advertising is the cost model could be
cost per impression or cost per click so
if it's cost per click obviously you
want that number to be as low as
possible that's the whole idea so if you
get
100 people clicking on your ad
then
obviously if that cost per click is low
then you're not spending as much so to
me it's better to pay say 500 for 1500
clicks then say paying 500 for 250
clicks obviously the 1500 is a means
your CPC is a lot lower than the two
dollars you're spending for 250 clicks
at a cost of 500.
so that's the whole key here is to try
and run ads and keep that cost per click
low
okay so the other metric you want to
measure with Facebook ads is cost per
acquisition or CPA okay and basically
that just measures the cost based on a
specific action so if you're asking
somebody to fill out a form submission
okay how much did it actually cost you
an advertising dollars to get a person
to do just that fill out a form
submission okay if it was a hundred
dollars then you gotta ask yourself wow
is that high obviously cost per
acquisition numbers always need to be
low okay so if you're selling T-shirts
at the at a cost of say ten dollars if
your cost per acquisition is ten dollars
okay you're in trouble you want to keep
that cost for acquisition number as low
as possible so that's a key metric to
always keep in mind
for Facebook advertising
and then another metric to kind of look
at or keep an eye on is AD frequency so
how many times did people see my ad okay
so you want to be able to show your ad
probably at most two to three times I
mean if somebody's seen your
advertisement
five six seven times they're just going
to ignore it and so to me those are just
wasted Impressions and so you want to be
able to control your ad frequency the
number of times you want somebody to see
your ad it could be one time it could be
two times but you obviously don't want
somebody to see you around five six
seven times
otherwise you're just not going to get
probably much out of that
so those are all the different types of
metrics available in Facebook you know
heed my advice pay close attention to
the metrics that's going to tell you a
lot about how your Facebook page is
performing now let me tell you about
simply lens postgraduate program in
digital marketing that is created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide we will explore SEO
SCM content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you'll have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start and in today's video we are
going to be talking about Facebook
advertising
we're going to talk about how businesses
use face we get fertility how the what
are the benefits they can get from it
we're going to show you with a demo on
how to set up your Facebook advertising
and we will close today's session with a
few do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising but before we go into that
make sure that if you like today's video
or if you like to Simply learned Channel
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
below and if you like the video feel
free to like it and share it with your
friends so let's get started
today's world has changed dramatically
when it comes to reaching your audiences
fact is that everybody is trying to get
the attention of the million of
prospects out there in the market
everybody is screaming try my product
try my product or try my product but
most businesses they now have to realize
that today's customer has changed yeah
today's customer is looking for instant
gratification they want a product now
wherever they are whatever their device
that they're using yeah and they can
prop they can Source their products from
everywhere in the world yeah but it is
your challenge to make sure that when
they are in the buying mode that you are
there to help them it's a new economy
out there it's a service driven economy
look at products like Uber or an Airbnb
where a whole new ecosystem has
developed of people offering their
products their services to a global
audience in marketing terms we're using
a term called solomo standing for social
local and mobile
yeah when you bring those three elements
together of social media local marketing
and mobile marketing you stand a really
good chance to connect with your
customers at the right time
Google has summarized this in what we
call Google moments on average people
have a couple of hundred moments during
a day where they grab their mobile phone
to do a search on their mobile phone
they maybe want to buy something they
want to book something they want to
share something they want to learn
something all those little moments or
opportunities for you to connect with
your customer or your prospect and
that's your opportunity but that's also
your challenge to make sure that you are
there
when your customers are having those
moments when they scream I want your
products and there are plenty of
channels that you can use to reach those
customers yeah we know about social
media we know about your website there's
things like influencer marketing there's
email marketing and there's more and
more competition out there that are
trying to use those channels to reach
your audience but fact is there is one
channel that really stands out of all
these channels and that is pay-per-click
advertising
pay-per-click advertising is a well
established part of what we call the
digital marketing Trifecta and this
Trifecta consists the word triceps of
three components owned paid and earned
yes so the old is your own website or
your own social media profiles and your
social media pages
but owned is no longer enough you need
to supplement your own media with paid
media and this is what we call
pay-per-click advertising
and then the third element of the
digital marketing Trifecta is what we
call earned media and earned media is
where you can still use that powerful
um effects of public relations in an
online world or where you can work with
influencers to help you develop your
online presence and connect with your
audiences
but one of the best ways to start
getting to your audiences is to use
advertising
yep and there are various platforms for
advertising there is
um Google yeah there is Google search
advertising Google display advertising
and there is Facebook advertising now to
put these two in the context Google did
about 210 billion dollars of Revenue in
advertising in 2021 Facebook is about
half of that 115 billion dollars in 2021
and the most powerful models for
advertising are search ads and display
ads yeah so with search ads is in the
Google search which is what Google the
offers the display ads and video ads are
offered by Google and by Facebook
and we call this pay per click
advertising which means you're not
paying for showing your ad but you're
paying when people click on your ads
okay so let's have a look between uh to
this advertising in a bit more detail
you have Facebook advertising was
introduced on around 2007.
yeah so
um in 2007 it was launched by Facebook
yep so but it has grown drastically
since then in 2011 ads were being shown
in the news feed yeah Google a Facebook
called it sponsored stories in 2012 ads
came on the mobile yeah mobile ads are
now considered the most powerful
um forms of pay-per-click advertising in
2014 a Facebook introduced a three-level
advertising structure which was very
much introduced by Google as well where
you have campaigns you have ad sets and
you have your ads and when you go in
setup and you'll see that later your
your ads in Facebook you will have to go
through these three ad elements
campaigns ad sets and ads to set up your
advertising on Facebook
in 2016 in 26 sorry in 2016 Facebook
introduced chat Bots and ads in
messenger which became a whole new area
for advertising for Facebook yeah
connecting with
um customers on Facebook messenger and
offering that for advertising as well
and in 2018 there was a whole range of
AD formats available on Facebook from
videos stories messenger Carousel
slideshows collections so a whole range
of ads to choose from when you start
your face setting up your Facebook ads
now what is the future yeah what does
the future hold for Facebook advertising
as you may have read
um that both Facebook and Google are
having a lower Revenue in their
advertising given the whole world
economic uh situation we're slowly
moving towards a a recession even yeah
Facebook and Google and Microsoft all
the big Tech players are feeling the
impact in that yes so that is one
Element now one of the other reasons why
Facebook's Revenue has gone down in
advertising HD tracking capabilities and
a lot of businesses they track people
when they visit their website and then
you can Target them with ads we call
this retargeting in marketing terms now
Apple has announced
um earlier this year that on iOS people
can say which is on the iPhone people
can decide to not being tracked yep so
that has put a whole sort of kind of a
um a a
um a a different set of Dynamics in
Facebook advertising on the iPhone and
it is not as effective as it was before
that announcement from um from Apple
so the future of advertising is all
about security it's about privacy and of
course in the end it all comes down to
how good are your ads how what is the
quality of the content in your ads are
you able to stand out from the crowd
yeah so those are the big challenges in
Facebook advertising now you have to be
aware that Facebook advertising is
completely different than Google search
advertising
you have to put it into a context Google
search advertising is what we call
intent based
yeah so when I have a question or I'm
looking for something or I need a
plumber I go to Google Search yeah and I
search for plumber near me and Google
will give me some ads with plumbers near
me
that is not the way Facebook advertising
Works Facebook advertising yeah is not
intent based it is basically it is your
challenge when you advertise on Facebook
is to stop the user from browsing and
click on your ads so it's more
interruptive you need to make sure that
they stop what they're doing which is
much more difficult
yeah so you'll see that Facebook is
therefore slightly more challenging to
actually generate leads
yeah to get new customers
Google advertising is much better for
that but Facebook advertising is much
better to reach a global audience very
targeted yeah and work on awareness
developing your proposition helping your
prospects to go through the buying cycle
yeah so Facebook ads they help spread
product and brand awareness in a news
feed or on Instagram or on messenger to
a very specific targeted audience
now another element which is important
to understand when it comes to Facebook
advertising is to do with Organic reach
when I have a Facebook post and I do oh
sorry when I have a Facebook page and I
do a post on my page the people that
will like my that have liked my page
will see my post on their news feed
that's how the theory
is yeah of course not everybody will see
those posts because that wouldn't work
because then you would get way too much
advertising in your feed yeah so
Facebook is very selective in the number
of posts from advertising from
businesses or sorry from businesses that
will show on your news feed
yeah and in fact that a percentage of
people that will see your posts your
business posts on their personal news
feed is less than three percent so again
if you have a Facebook page let's say
with 10 000 followers and you do a post
on your Facebook page less than 300
people will see your post
now businesses are not happy with that
yeah they said hey Facebook why are you
doing that I want to reach my entire
audience and Facebook says well hey you
still can yeah but it's going to cost
you some money and Facebook says you
have to go and advertise on Facebook to
reach your audiences so businesses Now
understand that Facebook is what we call
pay to play
you to reach your audiences you have to
supplement your organic reach with
advertising
and the beauty about Facebook
advertising is that it is a fantastic
way to reach your target audience
and that is the biggest benefit that
Facebook advertising can give you it's
all about the targeting there is so many
targeting options in Facebook and I'll
show you when we go into the short demo
on how to set up your ads so what are
the reasons why businesses go into
Facebook yeah what are the reasons what
are the benefits that they will get from
it and the first big benefit that they
get is that they get access to an
audience which is out there
yeah and it is not just a small audience
we're talking about Facebook at as of
today as close to 3 billion active
monthly users that is a massive numbers
and most of these people they check
their profiles at least once daily so it
is a huge audience to reach and there is
no better social media Network to reach
a global audience than on Facebook
yeah so that is one of the reasons why
you want to start advertising on
Facebook the second reason why you want
to start advertising on Facebook is that
Facebook gives you a fantastic platform
to advertise your products to People
based on their demographics based on
their interests based on their location
based on their
um their history of browsing based on so
many different segmentation factors
which means that you can make sure that
your ads reach the Right audience
which is a really good benefit that you
will get from Facebook advertising
the next benefit that you get from
Facebook advertising is that it is very
cost effective
yeah you can just start with a small
budget you can slowly increase your
budget you can relate your budget to the
returns that you're getting from it so
it helps you spend less and achieve more
it is one of the advertising platforms
with the highest return on investment of
your on your money so very cost
effective to advertise on Facebook
here are some other reasons why
businesses use advertising on Facebook
it really helps them with increasing
brand awareness as I said earlier the
difference with Google search
advertising Facebook is not intent based
people are not searching in Facebook
looking for Content which could include
your ads they are actually browsing on
Facebook and it is your challenge yeah
to
um to be creative enough to make them
stop browsing and pay attention to your
ads so it really helps in increasing
brand awareness it's let it's an
opportunity for you to Showcase your
brand and to help them add value to
their lives so by doing that you
establish trust you establish
credibility yeah and you provide recall
value for your brand
so it is all about taking the customer
by the hand and helping them
in going through the buying cycle
yes so when the buying cycle is about
awareness is about building interest
yeah then building that trust that they
then will turn into buying your product
the second big benefit that you're
getting from Facebook is to Target
people that have already expressed an
interest in your service we call this
retargeting you may also have heard
about pixel targeting or pixel marketing
it basically means that if somebody
visits your website
yeah you can then retarget those people
within ads
from a technical element as a
perspective it means that you need to
put Facebook will give you a piece of
code that you need to put on your
website
and then as soon as somebody visits that
website that triggers that code it
automatically connects with Facebook and
then Facebook will capture that user
data that you can then use to Target
them with a specific ads
so a big opportunity there for the
retargeting but things will be changing
here in the near future yeah Google has
announced that by 2023 24 it will stop
enabling third parties to leave cookies
on the um on on websites yeah to Target
people so that whole retargeting area
will go and will undergo some big
changes in the near future and then of
course Facebook advertising can really
help you increase Revenue as I said
earlier it is a fantastic way to to
connect with people and take them by the
hand through the buying cycle you can
educate your audiences about what your
product has to offer yeah and the more
people know about your products the more
likely they are prepared to make a
purchase and to share their experiences
so lots of benefits that you get now
let's dive a bit deeper into this and
let's look at the different type of ads
that Facebook has available so first
there is the single image ad
these are single ads single image ads
that have an option uh optional text on
the top and a link description that
links to your website and a call to
action that is very important to have a
good call to action in your ads the ad
images they need to be 1200 by 628
pixels
so that's where you have an opportunity
in the visual to stand out in the news
feed and make people stop and then click
on the link as you see here for instance
sign up
the next ads are the multi-product ads
they are usually carousels so it enables
you allow consumers to see all the
products or the services that you have
available they're very efficient they're
very Visual and they have lots of
creative options
um in them so they're very popular and
they're blocks being being used Lots by
by businesses so that's your
multi-product ads usually via a carousel
then of course you have your video ads
Now video ads are 30 seconds to two
minute ads and they are amongst
Facebook's most engaging most popular
ads they get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other ads and not only views
also engagement why because people love
to engage with video when you engage
with video you have the opportunity to
touch emotions of people which is much
stronger in building trust building
relationships with your audience
a particularly video on mobile yeah
works really well so it's a high growth
area of video advertising and one area
that you definitely need to look at if
you want to be successful with Facebook
advertising
then you have the lead ads lead ads they
offer slightly different way to
advertise your products they let you get
usernames emails phone numbers actually
without leaving Facebook
yeah and that's what makes them really
powerful within Facebook advertising you
can actually create a sign up form or
you could even drive them through
Messenger and have a communication with
them to get their details through a
chatbot
so people don't leave Facebook you do
the whole process of lead generation and
lead capture within Facebook and it can
be easily synchronized with your
existing CRM system
then you have collection ads collection
ads blend video and product catalog
photos so they are really good if you
want to advertise multiple products at
once yeah if you want to do this so
collection ads work really well
okay so that's a short introduction of
Facebook advertising the benefits that
you get why people would use them why
businesses would use them and the
different type of ads so in the next
section let's go and have a look at how
do you create an ad what are the steps
to create a Facebook ads
so here you see I am on a Facebook page
and this is the page for Riyadh for
Russia which is a hotel in Marrakech and
I am the admin for this page
and what I'm going to show you on this
page is how to access the advertising
platform and how to set up your ads
yes so let me first before I do this
show you what Facebook is trying to do
everywhere whether it's your desktop or
your mobile to make sure that you go
into advertise creation mode yeah so
you'll see it everywhere promote
ad Center create ads create automated
ads boost post wherever you are you will
come to sections like boost post or go
please create an ad on the mobile it's
even more obvious yeah here is the same
page but then on the mobile device and
if I scroll down you see on the first
post immediately boost the post so
you'll see that Facebook is trying
everything to get you to advertise
yeah and I think it is a bit annoying
yeah but it's also you need to be aware
that all the various places that
Facebook will try to to hook you into
advertising they lead to various
subsections of the advertising platform
yeah so if I click here on booster post
it will take me to a what I call a quick
and dirty boost advertising module yeah
so I say I'm gonna good morning from our
rooftop I'm going to turn that post into
an ad yeah it I can immediately suicide
what goal do I want for my ad do I want
to add a button what is the URL yeah do
I want to edit the image who is my
audience yeah and then what is the
budget what is the duration where am I
going to show these ads and how am I
going to pay Bang Bang
boost post now
yeah so it's looks very interesting and
very effective to do this but what you
see here is you will only get a
subsection of what Facebook advertising
can do for you
yeah and if you think hey if that's okay
with you that's fine but you're missing
90 of the other features to make your
ads as effective as possible
in other words my advice to you would be
don't click on the boost a post button
on your mobile or your desktop because
again it leads you to a limited
functionality of the advertising module
and the advertising capabilities that
Facebook can offer you
so back to the desktop the same applies
here if I click here on Boost post
yeah there's nothing wrong with
advertising for a post you can take one
of your most successful posts or for a
video and you can create additional
reach for that post through advertising
but don't do it through the limited
advertising functionality again this is
a quick and dirty module everything on
one page and it will you can click boost
post now and it's an easy way to start
spending your money yes so that is
if you click the Boost post the same
applies if you go to the
create ads or create automated ads yeah
so let me show you the create automated
ads it takes you through a very
automated process of creating ads which
is great when you're a beginner
but again it'll only give you limited
functionality of what Facebook
advertising has to offer you so my
advice would be don't go to the
automated ads click on create ads that
again gives you limited functionality
gives it all in one page again you don't
want to do that
yep and then you click on the ad Center
that gives you again a summary of the
advertising slightly more tools
yeah but it's all to lure you into spend
money in a very quick way
so then where do I go for my advertising
the place where you go ish to the
Facebook or how do you know called meta
The Meta business Suite The Meta
business Suite gives you everything you
need for your advertising it allows you
to manage multiple advertising accounts
yep and it gives you access to the full
functionality of what Facebook has to
offer you so let's go there The Meta
business Suite hmm
so here you see
everything you need for your advertising
yeah so here you see it's your read for
Russia and it's not only for your
advertising you can manage your posts
here you can schedule your posts manage
your inbox your notification manage your
content manage your shop plan your post
now we'll cover all these areas in
future videos but for now we want to
focus on the advertising again even here
they have ads as a quick and dirty
method to create your ads again where I
want you to go click here on all tools
and now finally this is where you want
to go it gives you access to the full
advertising functionality to create your
ads to manage your ads to manage your
audiences to set up events when you want
to connect get data from your website
and where you can create your forms
this is where you want to go yeah so if
I click here on the ads manager
that takes me to the full advertising
platform
now here you see by the way turn off ad
blocker yeah which is important because
in your creation of your ads Facebook
will obviously
[Music]
simulate your your ads yeah but if you
have your ad blocker on the ads will not
show in the preview so it is important
that you switch off the ad blocker so
you create your browser environment
exactly as users will have in when they
they see your ads so let me go into
switching that off
which is more tools extensions and you
see here my ad blocker is on so I'm
going to switch that off
yeah let me do a review
yes so here you have your account
overview you have your uh your desk as
your sort of your dashboard now you see
I haven't run any campaigns yeah so I'm
not gonna so there's not much to see
here in this and this this tool so let's
go here under my campaigns yeah and this
gives me the basic sort of structure of
your advertising on Facebook
yeah and remember we talked about
campaigns ad sets and ads
yeah those are the three elements of
your
advertising campaign on Facebook you
create a campaign and I'll show you what
you need to set up in the campaigns then
within a campaign you can have multiple
ad sets and those ad sets within a
campaign inherit the settings of the
campaign
and then within ad sets you have ads
yep and Those ads they inherit the
settings of the ad sets and the settings
of the campaign
all right so you see here we have three
or two campaigns or three campaigns
there is a new leads campaign there is a
page likes and there is a traffic
campaign so now I'm not going to show
you these campaigns I'm actually going
to show you how to create a campaign
so let's go into that here is create
if you have experience with advertising
in pay-per-click advertising you will
recognize this approach Google ads has
it as well it is what we call guided
campaign creation
yeah so when you start your Facebook ads
and when you start your Google ads you
can select do you want an awareness
campaign
do you want a traffic engagement leads
promote your apps or a sales campaign
yeah and basically once the campaign
objective that you select will
set a number of the settings yeah sort
of specifically for that campaign
objective so it makes it easier to align
it with your business goals and the
whole setup will be done easier
yeah so here you see an awareness
objective so that is too good for reach
for brand awareness for video views yeah
so it's showing the ad to the month to
as many people as possible who are
likely to remember them
traffic is to send people to a
destination like your website this is
really good to get link clicks to get
views from a landing page or get people
get into conversations with people on
Messenger or Whatsapp engagement ads is
get more messages videos views post
engagements it's good for Instagram
first messaging apps good for video
views engagement on posts
lead ads are collect leads for your
business or brand they're good for
instant forms on messenger good for
conversions and to get calls here is to
promote your apps like in app installs
app events and here is sales that is for
your catalog sales for instance
yeah we're going to do a simple one I'm
going to set up a traffic I want to
drive people to a landing page
yeah so here I'm going to click on
traffic yeah and I'm going to click
continue
so now I'm going into the campaign
settings so here you see the three
structures again the new traffic
campaign new traffic ad set new traffic
ads that I'm going to use
okay so here is my traffic campaign I'm
going to create a name which is I'm
going to stick with new traffic campaign
am I going to use any ads are there any
AD categories yeah so is it about
elections is it about politics is it
about employment about social issues
yeah I remember a few years ago there
was this Scandal when there was brexit
and the Trump elections or the in 2018 I
believe it was there was a lot of data
being sold by this Cambridge analytica
that they data they took from Facebook
and they sold it to the campaign teams
of the U.S election and of the brexit
yeah that had a big impact on privacy on
Facebook and on
um advertising for for elections and
politics so and now Facebook has set
some extra sort of security guidelines
for specific uh categories
now what are the campaign details
here you see by default it is set as an
auction
pay-per-click works on an auction base
and this is not a pay-per-click course
but basically it means you will do a bit
on your ad how much you're prepared to
pay for a click yeah and that will then
go into an auction and that will
determine the position of your ads we
want to get more traffic
do you want to do a b testing yes and we
want Facebook to do that yeah or you
switch that off and what is your budget
do you want to create a distribute your
butt set across ad sets yeah if you want
to do that you can switch that on and
then you have your campaign budget so
we're going to set a daily budget of 20
pounds yes so go back to the
phone setting yeah and then what is your
campaign bit strategy I just want the
highest volume and there's more options
you can schedule your ads so you can set
it at specific times my advice is to run
the ads all the time yeah particularly
in the learning phase when Facebook
launches your campaign it goes into
learning mode and then Facebook will see
by itself when your audience will
[Music]
will will respond and they will adjust
the ad scheduling accordingly so there
is your traffic campaign
details then we're going to your traffic
ad set where do you want to drive your
traffic to your website to an app to
messenger we want to drive it to the
website
now Dynamic creative is an important one
yeah do you want to want Facebook to
create your ads or do you want to do it
yourself when you want Facebook to do it
you provide creative elements like
images and headlines and then Facebook
will automatically generate the best ads
for you yeah so I kind of like that yeah
so I always switch that on on here you
see the schedule when do you want to
start
yeah so do you want to send an end as
well so that would be then let's say
November the 22nd and then here is some
more options you can set ad spend limits
and here is where the real meaty
sort of stuff happens in Facebook
advertising this is where you can select
your audience
you can save specific audiences
in the audience manager yeah so you can
have a number of audience if you have an
office in one country or another country
you can just hear select select the
audience for that particular country or
you can just create a new audience
okay so you can exclude audiences you
can set a location you can set the age
location let's look at that if I click
here on edit people living in or
recently in this location
people living people recently people
traveling in this location so this is
really powerful if you want to Target
people who are visiting a uh an event
like a football match or what have you
and you can include and this is where
you can search location you can in
search by City let's say London
yes or London England or I can say let's
do prisons reading in England
yeah and I can even say uh give me
yeah so I can search location give me uh
rg7 I can do my postcode yeah so I can
actually people doing in the reading
area by postcode and I really like this
so if I say for instance
rg76 yeah so here you can see how you
can Target a specific area yeah and this
is particularly for your local marketing
is very important
yep so that is the uh the local
targeting is really good so you can and
then by the way here you see your
estimated audience size and when your
audience get bigger you see estimated
daily results as well
and then you can do more you can search
by
um where was this you can search by
detailed targeting by demographics by
interests and behaviors yes if I want to
people who like reading
Football Club
yeah so here is the reading FC soccer
team yeah so here are I can now sent an
ad targeting specifically people in that
particular area who lie and we have the
UK as well
yeah so uh in reading and that
particular area who like football who
like Reading Football Club yeah or I can
um other at other areas as well there's
also the suggestions if people like
reading they may also like these type of
things Neymar soccer or maybe they like
Manchester United yeah so this is just a
tip of the iceberg the whole
segmentation in Facebook advertising and
the targeting is extremely powerful
okay here are your placements for your
Facebook ads best is to let Facebook
decide where to place your ads but to
show you where your ads can be shown on
Facebook if you click on the manual
placements you see here they can show on
Facebook they can show on Instagram on
messenger and on the Audience Network
now what is the Audience Network Google
has said as well yeah in the display ads
which are ads that show on millions of
websites that Facebook has an agree or
that Google or in this case Facebook has
an agreement with so it shows your
Facebook ads outside Facebook
or millions of websites okay so that's
the Audience Network then if you look at
it here is the feeds where you're at can
she can show
your ads can show in stories and reels
your ad can show in-stream videos
overlay and post Loop ads on reels on
Facebook search on messaging in article
apps inside so there is tons of places
where your ads can show but the best
thing is to let Facebook decide where
your ads are going to show
okay so these are your ad set settings
so let's now look at the ads
so here you see the Facebook page and in
our case it is the Riyadh for Russia
page
there you go yeah we'll make it you can
opt in for Branded content tools you can
look at the ad setup we can do manual
upload you can get data from your
product catalog and here you specify
what type of AD you want to show is it a
single image or a video or is it a
carousel
yep and then here you have your ad
creative
and your media and the select images
select videos and then here you have
your primary text headline description
your website URL this is where you can
do your url parameters when you want to
track your campaigns
yeah here you see the ad previewed at
preview is off and now it's on yeah but
of course I need to select media
so let's see
find images so here we're going to say
go to my website
and create an image for me approve
yeah so now it will actually show me
some images
select images yeah so here you see
images from my reacts
yeah that it picks up from my react or
from my website here's the website yes
so let's take uh
let's take this image and we'll say
continue
yeah so
so selected destination link for your
ads
let me see where we're going to put that
one
there you go yes from now because I put
in the destination link you will see how
the ad start building up but this is the
photo that I selected yeah now I'm not
going to show you the details of and I'm
not going to use as an example here I
just want you to show you the fields
where you can play and create your ads
yeah and then you see here in the ad
preview whether you see it in the feeds
there is a mobile preview as well
yep so you see here the feeds you see
here the stories and the reels how they
would look on Instagram the in stream
app and here in the search in article
and on apps
yes so there you have it that is your
traffic ads so we've now done our
campaign we've done our ad set we've
done our traffic ads and then basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to publish your ads
now when you're going to publish
yeah you can then go back to view the
details
and then you see that the ad is
um done and it is actually in review by
Facebook so if I now go back to my
campaigns
yeah let's close this one
you see here is the new traffic ads yeah
and you see here it's processing and
then here you see immediately the
details that you can get from your
campaign yeah so you see the processing
you see the ad set name the bit strategy
The Buckshot you see attribution setting
so basically attribution is how you
track the results of your ads
and then you see here the results in
number of Link clicks how many people
reached how many Impressions what is the
cost per result what is the quality
ranking the engagement ranking the
conversion ranking the higher these
rankings the better Facebook considers
your ads and the more and the better the
positions for your ads here you see your
amount spent and here you see the end
date of the campaign
yes so that is how you set up your
Facebook ads as a kind of introduction
to the Facebook advertising
yeah so if I now go back to all my
campaigns
campaigns yeah so you see here let me
see if I have some now you see there's
no none of these ads actually run or did
run in the past yes so I can't show you
the the results but we'll go into more
details at a later
um the later session on on Facebook
advertising for now this is I think the
best overview I can give you yeah and if
you want to get more than details then
we'll go in a more in-depth session of
the Facebook advertising
okay now that is all clear let's look at
the do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising
what should you do and what shouldn't
you do with your ads
so there are various dues to first of
all make sure you continuously test your
ads
and the good thing is that Facebook will
do this for you
yeah you can tell Facebook please test
my ads you can give Facebook a
collection of creative materials a
collection of headlines yeah and it will
actually mix and match those headlines
and it will use the ones that will give
the best
um the best conversions so it's very
important that you continuously look at
your performance and see if minor
changes to your ads will lead to a
better performance
second make sure that your images and
that your videos are engaging remember
there is no intent in Facebook
advertising you have to be very creative
to stand out from the crowd and you can
only do that by making your ads
engagement or them by making your ads
engaging
in images and videos
so the not only the images or the videos
but it's also the messaging that you use
use a message that will stay with your
audience
yeah so it's the combination of the
visuals and the key message of your ad
that will make people stop
if by looking in a split second at your
ad yeah they get it
then they will stop and they will
click on the call to action so make sure
you use a message that is
powerful and effective
also keep it simple or we say kiss keep
it simple and stupid make sure that
people easily understand
the message that you're trying to convey
with your ads don't make it too
complicated don't use complicated
visuals don't use complicated messages
keep it simple
and make sure that you reach the Right
audience
yeah Facebook's biggest benefit is the
targeting you can Target micro or micro
level targeting people in very specific
areas
yeah so that is the deuce and of course
there are don'ts as well so the first
thing is be sensible with your budget
don't spend your whole Budget on one
single campaign
yeah so start small and basically grow
your budget based on the results that
you're getting
yeah if you have to use visuals and
messages that are appealing then of
course don't make sure that you put too
much information in the ads again keep
your ads simple don't clutter them with
too much text and too many visuals
make sure that you proofread your ads
don't have typos in your ads there's not
a lot of text in your ad so please make
sure that you double check the quality
of the ads when it comes to the language
and the um the Cramer yeah so don't
forget to proofread your ads
be sensible in the activity level that
you have on your Facebook page yeah up
until a few years ago it was
it was actually promoted by Facebook to
do as many posts as you think are
relevant for your business people did
four or five posts a day nowadays it is
not about the quantity it is about the
quality so don't do too many posts on
your Facebook page be sensible think
from a customer perspective also when it
comes to your ads yeah so too many ads
or showing the same ads to the same
people all the time yeah may have an
adverse result
and then finally make sure that your
image relates to your product so don't
put up an image that doesn't relate to
the advertised product the people who
choose to keep up with your content on
the Instagram they don't like your own
personal cheerleaders following you
through every post story and update you
share do you want to boost your
popularity on the platform you need
those followers they are the key to
building your audience increasing your
reach and showing the word what you are
all about whether you are a business
influencer or just an average user
getting more followers is the name of
the game on Instagram from clever
hashtags to paid promotions these are
plenty of tactics you can use to grow
your following and become the Talk of
the Town so get out there and start
building your insta fanbase everyone I'm
vaiba khandival and I welcome you all to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
will be learning on how to increase
Instagram followers so first let me ask
you a question
that the Instagram get launched is it a
6 October 2010 or B 6 October 2011 or C
6 OCT November 2010 a d 6th August 2009.
you can comment on your answers in the
comment section below now let's get on
with our session but before we get into
nitty-gritty of things let me take you
through simply learns professional
certificate program in digital marketing
or better known as postgraduate program
in digital marketing it is the
post-graduate program course by simply
learn in collaboration with Purdue
University and meta blueprint in digital
marketing this comprehensive program is
designed to equip you with skills you
need to excel in the fast-paced world of
digital marketing with this program you
will learn everything from fundamentals
of digital marketing to the latest
trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide you will explore
topics such as SEO sem content marketing
social media marketing email marketing
and much more
this program is led by Industries
experts who bring their real world
experience to the classroom giving you
an Insider perspective on what it takes
to succeed in the digital marketing
world
and with Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program
individual marketing is the perfect
place to start to learn more about the
course you can click on the link in the
description box below now without any
further Ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
we will start off the discussion with
various steps to increase Instagram
followers moving forward we will also
discuss best practices to increase
followers
finally we will wrap this session with
the best tools to help get more such
followers so let's get started with a
few steps to help increase Instagram
followers first up you need to lay the
groundwork you need to identify your
ideal Instagram customers and create a
plan you can include keywords in the in
your profile and bio next you need to
create some interesting and engaging
content we have to craft a stunning
Instagram feed we can use lengthy
captions that are both engaging and
informative
then we have to make ourselves
discoverable
you can tag your location and other
relevant individuals in posts and use
hashtags to expand your audience
afterwards you have to be able to engage
with your community and build relations
you can start by collaborating with
similar companies and influential people
also you can interact with your
community and build trust and loyalty
finally you need to keep learning you
don't have to be afraid to use different
Instagram features and keep up with the
trends to stand out from others best way
to learn is to keep trying and keep
learning now let's check out some of the
best practices to keep in mind
in your Endeavor to increase followers
first up use relevant hashtags in your
posts and stories to reach a wider
audience next
you need to post high quality visually
appealing content that resonates with
your target audience
then we have to engage with your
followers by responding to comments and
asking questions
then we can also collaborate with other
users particularly those who have large
or engaged following
then we have to use Instagram features
such as deals and Instagram live to
share more personal and interactive
content next we have to utilize
Instagram speed promotion options to
reach a larger or targeted audience then
you can also consider using Instagram's
explore feature to discover and engage
with user who are interested in similar
content as to yours
afterwards we can also use Instagram
stories to share behind the scene
content and give your followers a more
personal look at your life or business
then you have to also post consistently
but you need to be careful not to flood
your followers feel
at last you have you can use Instagram's
analytics tools to track the success of
your posts and adjust your strategy
accordingly finally let's close this
session with the best tools to help get
more followers the First Tool in your
agenda is plan a pie
this tool allows you to schedule and
publish your post as well as analyze
their performance
the next tool we have is hoodsuit
this tool offers a variety of features
including the ability to schedule and
publish posts engage with followers and
track Analytics
then we have a tool called later this
tool is specifically designed for
Instagram and allow you to schedule post
track analytics and find relevant
hashtags
after that we have boostgram
this tool can help you to get more
Instagram followers by providing a
targeted followers through paid
promotions
following that we have social B this
tool offers the ability to schedule and
publish posts engage with followers and
track analytics finally we have social
drift this tool helps you get more
Instagram followers by using artificial
intelligence to engage with users who
are likely to follow you now let me tell
you about simply lens postgraduate
program in digital marketing that is
created in collaboration with Purdue
University and meta blueprint with this
program you will learn everything from
the fundamentals of digital marketing to
the latest trends and techniques used by
top marketers worldwide we will explore
SEO SCM content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start in today's video we are going
to be talking about Instagram
advertising and Instagram reels what is
it what do you need to know about um
what ads are available on Instagram how
can you optimize these ads for maximum
performance and how can you use
Instagram reels to grow your following
even further now I am Mark campman I'm
your digital Navigator for this video
but before we start like if you like
this video click the like button and if
you want to join our learner community
on YouTube subscribe to our Channel by
clicking on the link below so are you
ready let me start with giving you some
interesting Instagram stats that will
show you that Instagram has to be part
of your digital marketing strategy now
Instagram is only 12 year olds it is now
the seventh most visited website in the
world yes listen to this it's the
seventh most visited website in the
world and it is the um fourth most used
social media platform by monthly active
users
1.22 billion
users every month their nines Instagram
is ninth on the Google's most Search
terms list it's the second most
downloaded app in the world on the uh
the app stores and Instagram is most
popular amongst gen Z population
generation Zed Generation X males are
the fastest growing demographic yep and
that takes Instagram into a B2B into a
business world as well India has the
most number of Instagram users in the
world and people spend more time on the
Instagram stories than in the Instagram
news feed telling you a lot about the
importance of stories these days and
Instagram stories ads they generate
about 25 of Instagram's advertising
Revenue now do you need any more facts
to convince you that Instagram is one of
the most popular social media networks
and that it has to be part of your
digital marketing strategy so let's dive
a bit deeper into the Instagram
advertising opportunities and the reels
that you can use in Instagram so in this
session we are going to be talking about
Instagram ads in digital marketing why
is it so important what are the benefits
that you can get from Instagram ads
we're then going to look at the
different types of Instagram ads that to
you that you have available I'm going to
show you some Instagram ad Types on
Instagram and I'm also going to show you
where on Facebook you can go to create
to create the Instagram ads we're then
going to dig into the Instagram reels
yeah it's a new feature about two years
ago it is kind of the um the the
follow-up from igtv it is Instagram's
response to tick tock success they have
an Instagram reels are short vertical
videos that are very powerful in the um
and used by many people these days so
we're going to dive into these we're
going to see the benefits that you can
get as a business for them and I'm going
to show you quickly where to go on
Instagram to set up these these
Instagram reels I'm then going to give
you a few tips on the Instagram reels
and then we're going to close off
today's session with some frequently
asked questions that I'm getting a lot
in the when it comes to Instagram
advertising and Instagram reels so are
you ready for this let's get started
let's look at Instagram ads in digital
marketing so let's talk about Instagram
ads and branding first why is it so
important important to use Instagram
advertising for your branding well more
than 25 billion businesses use Instagram
to promote their services and products
yeah so when they are all working on
developing their brand through Instagram
so 90 of the Instagram accounts they
follow at least one business on
Instagram and 62 percent of users say
that they are more interested in a brand
after seeing them in an Instagram story
so it's a very important platform for
Brands to connect with their users yeah
when many Instagram users they actually
use Instagram to research new products
and services and most Instagram users
almost more than 80 percent they say
they take an action after seeing a
product on Instagram
yes so no surprise that many brands are
active on Instagram yeah and on average
you can say that the brands do about one
and a half times posting every day yeah
so there's no doubt that Instagram
should be part of your business yeah it
is an effective tool for advertisers to
boost brand awareness and increase
engagement with their followers and
their customers and it's not only a
platform to Showcase your brand but also
a channel through which you can interact
with your followers and build customer
loyalty and then I'm not even talking
yet about the e-commerce opportunities
you have on Instagram by opening up a
shop by promoting your products on
Instagram so a platform where you
definitely have to be
so it can act as a new channel for your
business which can extend your online
presence
and when you are on Instagram you can
promote you can sell you can increase
sales of your business and you can gain
many many benefits from being on
Instagram and here are just a few of
them so you can keep up with what's
happening in the world so if many people
if everyone yeah billions of people are
on Instagram why aren't you so there is
the new Instagram shop feature that can
help you and your brand to get more
sales so you can open up a shop on
Facebook you can then connect that shop
with your Instagram and you can promote
your products you can tag your products
in your Instagram posts and that will
lead
two sales through your um your Facebook
and your e-commerce shop it's fantastic
for competitor analysis what are your
competitors doing on Instagram what are
they promoting what are they advertising
you can learn a lot about what works and
what doesn't work in the the market
Instagram is also a place where you can
connect with your customers where you
can deliver customer service yeah so
it's not just offline or not just on
Twitter but you can use that on
Instagram as well
so
Instagram these days is a very normal a
very basic platforms and it's almost
like you're having your website
customers expect you to be on Instagram
as well these days so if you do that
properly it can help you in getting more
customers growing your online customer
base on Instagram and it can help you in
developing your brand to generate more
sales and to grow your online reputation
by setting the tone and the style of
your posts you can immediately develop
and present an online sort of identity
that you can then transfer into your
online reputation
another powerful aspect of that you have
with Instagram is that you can work with
influencers yeah there's many
influencers many Instagram
users with large followings they offer
their services to Brands to help them in
promoting their products and services so
that is not enough for you finally yeah
the virality on Instagram is very very
strong so if you have good content good
posts good stories Good reels you can go
very high and wide and far through the
uh the Instagram
um the Instagram world and many people
will view your videos and share your
videos so it's a platform you can no
longer ignore and you definitely want to
be there
so in 2020 a new style of post was
created which was called the Instagram
reels which is kind of the follow-up of
the igtv which was a kind of a vertical
video kind of YouTube channel that you
could get on on Instagram now it is sort
of in the response of Instagram to the
growth of of tick tock and creators on
Instagram like Justin Bieber lizzo
Stanley Tucci they really helped to
transform this
um feature from a almost like a tick
tock wannabe to a full-blown competitor
of tiktok they are full screen vertical
videos that can be up to 90 seconds long
yeah they come with many unique editing
tools and an extensive library of audio
tracks as well so it's very easy to make
these short videos and to start sharing
them and you will see that the fuse and
the engagement that you get with these
reels in Instagram is extremely high on
top of the sound real can include
multiple video clips filters captures
and in an interactive backgrounds so you
can add stickers all the tools that you
expect in that you see in stories that
you see in Tick Tock you see that in the
Instagram reels as well now they're
clearly different from Instagram stories
yeah Instagram story they did disappear
in 24 hours once you post a real it is
available on Instagram until you delete
it so they are also favored by the
Instagram algorithm yeah which is more
likely to recommend them to people who
don't follow you yes so it is a very
good tool to grow your following but
we'll talk about reels a little later
when we go into the after we've gone
into the advertising on Instagram
so let's look into
um advertising on Instagram here are
some interesting facts about Instagram
advertising each month there are two
million advertisers active on Instagram
yeah so that is a big number of people
the estimated advertising reach for
Instagram users is
1.32 billion users
yes so there and that is an important
one the Instagram advertising reach has
outpaced Facebook advertising reach in
the last year so and did you know you
can reach 22 of the global population
age 13 or older in Instagram so a
platform an advertising platform that
you cannot ignore yeah and through
Instagram reels you can reach another
potential audience of close to a billion
people
so and interesting fact you know is that
the split in female and male is about 45
and 55 on the advertising audience for
the Instagram reels
so how do you create Instagram ads
through the Facebook advertising manager
yep and we've done a um a short or a
video about Facebook advertising in the
um in in an earlier video of this series
but um I'm sure I'm not going to go into
this but I do want to show you a new
feature in the Facebook and Instagram
advertising advertising setup but before
we go into this let's have a quick look
at Instagram and see if we can find some
ads so if I go out of here and I go to
Instagram
yeah so here you see my mobile let's log
in and we're going to Instagram
yeah so by just by browsing through your
news feed you will already come across
ads
yeah so let's see where we see an ad
popping up
so here you see one yes so Sahara
Services official and because it's an ad
you see it's a sponsored ad and here you
see the type of ad that we see here is a
photo ad just one photo that they have
with a call to action in this case visit
the Instagram profile
so here you see an ad yeah which is
again is sponsored but here you see I
can flick through the photo so this is
what we call a carousel ad
yeah so there are multiple photos or in
this case videos so you could also see
this as kind of a video ad but this is a
combination of a video ad and a carousel
ads where you can flick through multiple
photos so what I've done I've saved a
few
um a few ads yeah that is easier so I
don't have to browse so if I click here
on the saved and here you see some ads
yeah so here you see an example of a
photo ad but multiple photos and that's
why we also call this a carousel ads
okay here you see an example of us
another Carousel ads yeah so you can see
that it's an ad because it's a sponsored
again multiple photos and a call to
action yeah here you have a photo ad
where it's just one photo and here you
see another Carousel ad with two photos
and here you see a video ads
yeah so these are the ads that you see
on uh in the news feed
besides that there are ads in the
stories and here at the top you see the
stories so let's go here browse through
the stories
so here you see and we immediately see
here a sponsored ad from Barcelona Tanja
yeah and this is a video ad
yeah what I like about the ads on the
stories and that's why they are so
powerful they have a very sort of
natural blend with the stories before
and after them they don't really look
like ads and particularly if you're
making them full screen vertical ads
yeah they blend in very well with the
the with the news feed yeah of the story
feeds yep so here you see another ad
yeah with uh as a story
so you can the call to action are you
looking for the click on the more yeah
and then you can have different more
information in the ad as well so very
powerful
yeah here you see another ad
okay so those are your ads on uh on the
stories and then here you see the reels
yeah now
um
yep that will come back to the reels
later and here in the reels you will be
will be able to see and to Showcase your
ads as well
okay so that is the those are the ads on
um on Instagram yeah so if I summarize
this
yeah if we look at the uh the Instagram
ads
so the first ads that we saw were the
photo or the image ads yeah so
particularly for campaigns where there
is a very strong visual aspect yes
strong visual information that you can
summarize in one single image they are
the best
um for creating image ads these pictures
can be produced using your own
photographers or designs or
illustrations or you can even take an
existing post that you can promote or
that you can boost as an image ad as
well so very straightforward very simple
but the image ads are the simplest way
of creating Instagram ads here you have
a story ads so a story ad multiple
visuals that go in a story engagement is
typically greater with story ads yeah
because it sort of gets the entire
Mobile screen and it's much more
engaging than at in the in the news feed
yep so we see here there is not really
video in there but it is moving kind of
images moving text yeah and audio in
this ad from from Spotify so story ads
are extremely powerful one of the most
popular types of ads in Instagram and
again very easy to create
you then have the video ads so if you
want to give the viewers a more in-depth
look of your brand your products your
services then run a video ad on
Instagram
so make them short you can make them
Square you can make them full full sort
of vertical full screen but the
important thing is try to make the
content engaging
yep and that is where video ads are so
powerful and they can bring a message
across in a very powerful way video ads
on Instagram they are probably the ads
with the highest conversions yeah for um
for people that view the ad and if you
want them to take an action so yep so
those are the video ads and then you
have the reels ads so intermitted with
reels you can have 30 second long ads
that are sort of comparable to story
advertising so they're full screen
vertical videos and again they properly
merge with the organic reels yep and
they have featured they have sound they
feature Sound and Music
so very powerful ads where you can get
very good call to actions learn more
learn more buy now yeah this sort of
call to actions that can really lead
people either to drive them to your
website or drive them to your shop where
they can buy your product
yep and then we have the carousel ads
and the carousel ads is what I showed
you where you have a collection of
photos or videos that people can swipe
through yep so they can particularly
they work really well in your Instagram
feed and they are really good for
showcasing multiple products in your ads
what you also see is that people use
Carousel ads where they have one large
sort of horizontal photo that they split
up in three sections so it is almost
like browsing through the photo from
left to right so very powerful ads that
you can get on on Google on Facebook and
on Instagram advertising
okay now before we go into the reels
let's go to Facebook ads and show you
some new feature on on the advertising
for the um for Instagram advertising so
here you see the Facebook business
manager yes so it is the meta business
Suite which is sort of a new integrated
platform
um which brings together a number of
functions it used to be the Facebook
business manager but they now have
brought it all under the meta business
Suite so if I go there for my Riyadh for
Russia page it takes you to everything
you need to do and to plan and to manage
and to track of your Facebook or your
Instagram account yeah you see here Iron
Man can manage the Facebook page and I
can manage the Instagram page now we're
not going to go into the whole of the
meta business suit I just want to show
you the advertising and a new feature
here in advertising if I click on all
tools and then I click here on ADD
yeah so this is kind of a quick creation
of ads I can automate my ads I can
choose a goal for my ads or I can boost
existing content and I just want to show
you how easy it is these days to make an
ad for your Instagram so if I want to
boost the post
yeah or I can get more leads or whatever
I want to do yeah boost an Instagram
post or real let's go into that
yeah so content type I'm just going to
do a post for this sake yeah so we're
going to boost this post
yep and then here you will see how the
ad will look like in your Instagram feed
in this case yep and that's where you
can change the text of your ad so it's a
really good feature to quickly launch an
ad of an existing pouch post make sure
you've got your ads blocker Switched Off
to get access to this yeah you can have
other previews as well
let's see what that will give us
yeah so here you see the feed in
Instagram Explorer here with the
Instagram feed
he able to do how it looks in Instagram
stories
here is how it would look in Instagram
reels
yes so really useful tool to quickly see
how your ad will show on Instagram yeah
for an existing post and then of course
you can have the same facilities if you
want to create a new post
okay so that's all I'm going to share
with you on Facebook and Instagram
advertising and how to create your
Instagram ads through the meta business
Suite right so let's go back to the
presentation and let's look at the
Instagram reels so
yeah so where are the reels in Instagram
if I click here on Instagram and then
here is my home
yeah if I click at the bottom on the
little icon here I can then go to reels
and this is exactly like Tick Tock I can
just flick up and that takes me to the
next post
okay so very useful and very simple way
of um of creating and sharing content
and very popular way and a lot of people
spend time on the reels to find really
cool content okay so here I can go to
the search and I can search for items so
I can search for instance look at
marketing how to yeah and here you see
books to master marketing which is in a
real format so this is how I can then
access posts in relation to marketing
yeah and and other elements yeah books
to read
yeah so lots of stuff here on the reels
that you can use to find content in
every topic that you're interested in
yep so here is more reels on Morocco
yeah so very useful tool now how do you
create a reel you click on the plus icon
and you basically select here at the
bottom post story real or live you click
real and then you see the four up five
options that you have here for the audio
the length of the video the speeds yeah
the grids that you want to change the
scale and there's even a timer so
there's lots of functionality that you
can use here in your
um in developing your video Then by
pressing the center button you can start
recording the video yeah and there is
also opportunities to get
um take for instance do little
characters dancing on your desk yeah or
on your keyboard you can make them
slightly bigger
yeah we lost the character where was he
and now we're recording we've lost so
here's our character I can blow him up a
bit yep and we then see him dancing on
our screen
yeah happy with that stop it do next
yeah I'm gonna not not add a sticker
here is the video that we've just
created yeah I can edit a clip if I want
to I click next and then I can share it
to Reels I can write a caption I can add
stickers and all the standard stuff that
you can do on your uh on the reels yeah
so very cool very like Tick Tock and the
the the best thing about it it is so
simple to make it's very intuitive
okay so that is a quick introduction of
the reels
so how do you fit reels into your
digital marketing strategy let's have a
look at that in a bit more um in a bit
more detail yes so it is a really good
way to give your audience a behind the
scenes
overview yes so which works well to get
engagement and to get Trust on your
brand yes so look at the culture in the
company how you make your product how
hard people work look at the the
customer services how they work it's a
really good way to give people a behind
the scenes look of the company and again
to build this brand trust people really
appreciate that yeah so that is one of
the things that you can do with
Instagram reels another very powerful
aspect of Instagram reels is that you
can use it to generate what we call user
generated content why not ask your
customers or your users to create reels
around a topic that you work on yeah and
share it with with a hashtag yes so it's
a great way for people to getting to
know the company getting to know the
products start using influencers yeah
get competitions going where you do
photo contests or maybe video contests
and you can turn those into reels with
the pictures or make them actually let
the user share the the reels they
created themselves yes so sharing user
generated content is a second big
benefit that you can get from using
Instagram reels now Instagram reels
because they're short people have short
attention span they're also really good
to educate your customers yeah or
educate your audience they're a great
way to develop yourself as an expert in
your field by giving their audience
value yeah on how to use your products
how to
um
to to answer questions about your
products yeah on how to do specific
things in in using your products so get
people to learn around your product and
if you make that a recurring type of
real people will come back for them
because they want to learn more about
your products it's also good to see your
products in actions so combined with
user generated content why not ask your
audience yeah your customers to make
sure it reels on how they use your
products
yes so but if you want to do it yourself
you can really try to highlight what
sets your product apart from your
competition
so yeah you use that to your advantage
in using Instagram reels to highlight
your products and to see your products
in action
and of course it goes without saying if
you make it fun if you make it more
personalized yeah that is a fantastic
way to connect with your audience yep
and that is where children work really
well where pets cats dogs worked really
well try to get casual try to interact
with your followers through very sort of
emotional casual content
so and often what you will see that
these type of reels will have very high
number of views because people just love
to browse through that type of content
yeah create your own challenge or create
your own Trends encourage your fans to
participate and use a special hashtag to
share the content they create yeah for
you
so that's the big benefits that you can
get from the reels yeah so use that to
your advantage
good so let's look at some tips and
tricks on Instagram advertising now
remember
most people watch
content on their mobile Instagram is a
mobile app so make sure that you design
your ads with Mobile in mind make sure
that you optimize your ads for mobile
there's nothing worse than seeing a an
Instagram story ads with a horizontal
video and then black above and below yes
so optimize it for the mobile and mobile
is vertical so use that vertical format
because the immersion is better but also
it's much easier to crop a vertical
video to a four by five aspect ready a
ratio or a square ratio than a landscape
video
yes so make sure you design your ads for
mobile first
tip two let a visual speak for
themselves
yeah make your ads less wordy and use
Font sizes that are optimized use color
and make the use capitals make sure that
it is optimized for mobile devices use
big phones that stand out use colors
that stand out and that's a visuals
speak for themselves
tip three yeah use animations use Motion
Graphics it is not just video that you
need to have but animated text animated
things happening on the screen they are
videos as well so let the screen come to
life either through video or through
animation and Motion Graphics
and of course very important Keep The
Branding keep the messaging that you
have keep it at the front yeah the first
three seconds people will decide if they
want to watch the entire ad or continue
to scroll yeah so make sure that in the
first three seconds you capture people's
attention and you've put your branding
and your message across
and then of course you sound yeah you
sound in your ads so although a lot of
the people they may want to watch it
without audio Yeah make it accessible by
people with muted volume use trendy
soundtracks to engage those who choose
to listen to your videos
yeah consider using captions as well or
text overlays that's very important if
you have somebody speaking in your ads
yeah always use captions or overlay of
text to make sure that if people have
the sound off that they can still
understand what the ad is all about
right so that is all on the Instagram
ads and the Instagram reels so let's
look at some of the questions that I'm
getting yeah from people when we talk
about Instagram reels and Instagram
advertising so one question I'm getting
a lot is if I do my reels yeah
I didn't get much engagement what should
I do to improve yes so now first of all
in general Instagram reels have a very
high engagement yes so they're probably
the part of Instagram with the highest
engagement that you will see and I will
show you yep so if I go to my Instagram
here on the of my my Riyadh for Russia
let me close this here
yeah so
save the draft close yeah so I'm going
to my Instagram so this is my profile
and here you see my reels now if I post
a video a normal video I used to get
maybe I could I get some views but
nothing like thousands or thousands of
views yes so since we've been using
Instagram reels
yeah we've now get views and plays on
our videos here
1244 here is a view eleven thousand
views of the video
yeah here you see six thousand views of
the video these were numbers we would
never get yeah on the Instagram news
feed or the Instagram stories so here
you see you do get the engagement of
your um of the reels on Instagram yeah
and it's one of the big reasons is that
Instagram favors the Instagram algorithm
favors reels in your um yeah in sharing
your content okay so make sure that your
video content is up to scratch maybe the
music could be improved a really good
way is to look at what your competitors
are doing
yeah and maybe they do things that
you're not doing so try to learn from
that
okay question two how do I choose to
write soundtrack for my Instagram reels
good question yeah it's very important
that you get the right sound for your
Instagram reels now Instagram has a
whole library of sounds that you can
choose from in creating your uh your
reels Facebook has a huge library of
thousands and thousands of songs that
you can download royalty free and use in
your in your posts in your ads yes so
very important first of all is that you
look at what's trending in the world
where when it comes to picking a
soundtrack yes so learn from that what
are the hits at the moment what are the
most popular sound music videos on
YouTube what's the most popular music on
the on Instagram learn from that yep and
then make your decision on what music
you want to use in your video
okay will reels get me organic audience
or do I need to promote them as well
so the beauty about digital marketing is
a duty site what you want to do
yeah whether you just want organic or
whether you want to advertise yeah so
just to be clear for everybody when I
say organic audience it means that if I
do a post without any advertising how
many people will see my post how many
people will see my video my reel and how
many people may like it or share it
yeah and we know and as I said earlier
the reels have a high
fairly High organic reach from the three
areas in Instagram posts stories and
reels reels gives you the highest
organic reach at the moment but we also
know these days and if you look at some
of my other videos that I posted on
YouTube on digital marketing that social
media is no longer a free right social
media these days is pay to play yeah so
if you really want to use Instagram and
Instagram reels to grow your business to
find leads then you need to combine
organic marketing with paid marketing
yes so start looking into what we call
the pay-per-click advertising and see
how much wider and how much bigger the
audience is that you can Target yep and
then try to invest some money in the
pay-per-click advertising and see what
results you get
so always good to look into that have
your options open but the good thing
about digital marketing you decide what
you want to do Instagram is a social
media platform that needs no
introduction with nearly 1 billion
monthly active users and 500 million
daily active users Instagram is a
platform drive with marketing potential
more than 7 billion dollars Revenue has
been generated from Instagram mobile and
it's home to more than 2 million
advertisers
not only that marketing on Instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one-third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to Instagram's
parent company Facebook Instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by Facebook ads with
this you can advertise to People based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on Instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a URL to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your Brand's website or a page for a
particular product make sure to track
this link as well to see how much
traffic it brings
here's an example of how Samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services Samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number two we have create a
Content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
Content calendar
a Content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts it'll help you plan
ahead and automate the process of
publishing your posts when your audience
is most active a calendar helps you
decide what content caption hashtags
videos goes live on what day date or
time a consistent post schedule will
enable you to make the most out of
Instagram it'll also keep your audience
engaged and also give you access to
historical posts if you want to repost
your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
Facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more
you also have a variety of AD formats to
choose from like story ads image ads
video ads collection ads and more
moreover they can also be set up from
Facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from body
shop in which they are using a single
image ad the advertising works because
of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link let's go to number
four have a visually consistent feed
Instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
two authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your Brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted Earthly tones
with a low key editing style your
content must feel down to earth and your
brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images and
are somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can Captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them this makes it more likely that
they feel closer to your brand and buy
your products your captions can tell
stories that can help your brand appear
more human and build deeper connections
with your audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
Patagonia talks about forests in America
each of their posts tell stories about a
different tissue that affects nature
their brand on Instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues that's
the kind of stories you should tell with
your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your post showing up
on the Explorer tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in the sea of
content
your hashtag shouldn't be too generic
like hash New Year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and Industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven take
advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc ALS by them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to convert followers into
Advocates of your brand
here's an example of how Starbucks uses
user generated content and takes
advantages of Their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed and products stalled at
Starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads most
instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising we do
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to Instagram ads
single video ads that can create 60
second ads carousels are a combination
of images and videos and Instagram
stories that enable you to combine
images and videos to create visually
attractive ads
here's an example of the brand Pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well shot videos and captions now
for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and Authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how Ralph Lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products the influencer
showing off the latest Ralph Lauren has
to offer this encourages his interested
followers to check out the page and buy
something for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways contests enable your audience
to engage with your brand with 3.5 times
more likes and 64 times the comments you
can give away a product or a service
which enables you to boost engagement
and brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned Brands need to be partnered with
Contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important you would
need to track your contest performance
and promote the results on other social
media platforms as well here's an
example of a contest run by Domino's
Pizza which encourages people to
contribute their own short stories and
connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic
adding links to the Instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to The Savvy
marketer igtv provides you a unique
mobile-friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews another new
tool they have introduced is Instagram
reels Instagram's answer to tick tock
Instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's a Rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
Styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
Instagram engagement now let's get
started
first off let's have a look at an
introduction to Facebook
was first launched in February 2004 and
was initially known as the Facebook
in 2005 it removed thee from its name
and it has now become the Facebook we
all know today
it is now the world's most popular
social media and social networking
service
next let's have a look at Instagram
it was launched in 2010 for iOS and then
in 2012 for Android by Kevin Systrom and
Mike Krieger
Instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
Platforms in the world
in April 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by Facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash in stock
now let's compare some stats between
Facebook and Instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats first off Facebook like I
mentioned earlier Facebook is the
largest social media platform in the
world reaching almost 60.6 percent of
the internet it has 2.5 billion monthly
active users and approximately 1.6
billion active users in fact as of Jan
2020 the US has approximately 190
million and India is approximately 280
million Facebook users an indication of
a market that's still ripe for the
picking
now let's have a look at Instagram
although having released significantly
later earns its title of the fastest
growing social media platform with 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily users
in the United States there are
approximately 120 million and India has
close to 88 million Instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic age group of the user base
first off Facebook
although there's a general opinion among
the younger population that Facebook
isn't hip or is induced all that much
anymore this statistic has something
different to say
turns out more than 65 percent of
Facebook users are between the ages of
25 and 34.
for Instagram it's no surprise that 71
percent of the user base are under the
age of 35.
next let's compare the usage time of
both these platforms
let's take Facebook first
in the United States users spend
approximately one hour on Facebook every
day in India users spend an average of
three hours a day on Facebook
shockingly High numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead isn't it
on the other hand in the United States
users spend 23 minutes on average on
Instagram in India users spend
approximately 45 minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for Facebook 86 percent of marketers use
it for advertising
Instagram is used by 71 percent of
businesses for their marketing
requirements
now let's have a look at some industries
that will work well on both these
platforms
if you do belong to any of these
industries if you're not taking
advantage of these platforms you're
missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on Facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media e-commerce automobile
and packaged Goods
next time you're on Facebook take a
closer look at your feed there's a good
chance you'll see most of these
industries is post on it
next up Instagram we have Industries
like fashion Ecclesia Cosmetics
Automobiles and food and beverages
I can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find all these
industries advertising on Instagram
now let's take a closer look at how
Facebook can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at Facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an online presence for
your organization for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch a webinar a live broadcast a new
store opening anything whatever it is it
can go on your Facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page you get
greater visibility letting people know
about the products and services that you
offer you can offer customer service as
well in fact according to American
Express 90 of users use customer service
as a deciding factor for whether or not
they continue to do business with an
organization so customer service is
pretty important like I mentioned
earlier your business page provides a
place where you can offer your followers
offers and other advantages
and finally the page lets you build a
community
a highly targeted community that has a
higher possibility of buying your
products and services
next we have Facebook groups with
Facebook groups you can build a
community of like individuals
some of the advantages that come with us
are it provides a highly targeted
audience I mentioned earlier that
business Pages provide you with a highly
targeted audience groups take that to
the next level it enables everyone to
learn from one another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members know things
that others don't
your group will enable them to
communicate with each other and learn
these new things
you also get honest feedback your
customers who are also likely part of
the group will be able to give their
feedback on how they like your product
and perhaps even give you tips on how to
improve now since your group is filled
with a community that's highly
interested in your brand you can also
increase engagement in an organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next Facebook has events with Facebook
events your organization will be able to
mobilize your brand and enable online
consumer marketing basically meaning
that you have a platform for letting
people know about important
announcements not to mention there's
also the opportunity to get some free
advertising done events also help you
increase brand awareness most people get
to know about your brand by attending
the event or just seeing the promotion
for it now let's have a look at Facebook
Stories for groups and Pages a feature
that is available for both groups and
Pages it provides you the ability to
appropriately represent your brand or
business directly from your mobile
device or desktop
now some of its advantages
other it helps you engage with your
audience with stuff other than the
usuals like articles videos and other
similar posts this way you can also vary
the kind of content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers stories help your brand show
that you're generally interested in your
audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency next
Facebook has Facebook Messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience at a
personal level
in the last few years messenger has
proved itself to be a great marketing
tool it helps acquire more customers now
people are more loyal to a brand that
generally cares about them and by
directly interacting with them through
Messenger their loyalty towards you is
certainly set to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get a greater number of
transaction and even if a customer
doesn't give you a transaction at least
you're increasing your brand awareness
then we have Facebook live
Facebook live gives you a platform to
interact with your audience in real time
it can be used to diversify your content
providing your audience with something
different from what they've received
from your brand initially live can also
be used to show what happens behind the
scenes in your organization further
helping humanize your brand
and finally you can also provide instant
questions and answers to your audience
increasing engagement with them
next we have the Facebook shop
the Facebook shop is a business page tab
application that enables your customers
to purchase your products directly from
your store it also has the following
advantages firstly you can use the shop
to drive new sales you can give the
customers who are on the fence about
your product a small Push by engaging
them and how can you do that with deals
and promotions you can also reward
Advocates of your brand with special
benefits to be availed from your store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition now let's have
a look at Facebook ads
Facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific targeted audience on Facebook
now some of the advantages of Facebook
ads are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience
and it provides you with greater reach
while making you spend lesser amounts of
money it also helps you re-advertise or
retarget your products to an existing
audience and finally it helps increase
Revenue sales and leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about Facebook ads you can check out our
Facebook ads video I'll add it in the
live chat so you can check it out if
you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature Facebook offers to help you with
marketing
Facebook insights I'm sure all of you
have heard about Google analytics let's
just say this is Facebook's version of
that with insights you get information
that can help you refine your brand
strategy by tracking and measuring
results
it can help you determine reach and
engagement actions people who are
viewing your posts when your fans are
online the type of posts that are
working for you and much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
Facebook helps you with marketing now
let's move on to Instagram
first off we have Instagram business
accounts Instagram business accounts
enable Brands to be recognized as
businesses
now it also has the following benefits
to offer it's only with a business
account that you can get Instagram
insights we'll talk about insights in a
little more detail in a little bit you
can also add a contact button on your
profile enabling users to connect with
you directly
you can also specify what kind of
service you offer by adding what
industry you belong to in your bio and
finally you also have the ability to add
links to your Instagram stories now I'm
sure you've all seen the see more option
in your stories so now you know how that
shows up
now if you guys are interested in
finding out how you can increase
followers on Instagram you can check out
our video on the same topic of the same
name I'll add the link in the live chat
next let's talk about Instagram stories
with Instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement build brand
awareness and to drive sales you can
also use stories to provide recent
updates about your brand
now some of the advantages of Instagram
stories are that they help businesses
grow Their audience and can enable them
to engage with their audience regularly
with stories you can also Drive traffic
to other websites like your company's
website it can also help diversify your
content setting it apart from the usual
videos and photos next up let's talk
about Instagram DMS or direct messages
DMS help you grow your business by
interacting with customers at a personal
level it can also help build connections
with your users by building a personal
connection with your followers their
loyalty towards your brand is improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry and
as an extension of the last few points
this leads to easier lead generation and
increased sales
next up we have igtv
now igtv is a platform that's gotten
really famous recently it enables your
brand to get closer to its audience and
enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include greater
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience
improve engagement and greater chances
of conversions finally it also helps
build a community of a highly targeted
audience
next we have Instagram live
Instagram live enables you to
communicate with your audience in real
time further improving your
discoverability and strengthening your
connection with the audience
moreover it provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on live stream
and finally it helps you interact with
your audience in real time
this helps further humanize your brand
next we have Instagram ads
Instagram ads provides you with control
over advertisements you decide how they
appear and who sees them like Facebook
Instagram has a number of different ad
types to offer
they are photo ads video ads Carousel
ads slideshow ads and stories ads
next up Instagram offers an Instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your Instagram
profile
at some points even enabling users to
access the shop directly from an image
showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
Instagram shop is that it provides easy
product discoverability and since it
provides visual marketing it also leads
to more sales
and finally Instagram insights
Instagram's answer to Facebook insights
and Google Analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data on follower demographics
their actions and your brand content
it helps determine engagement
Impressions and reach best and worse
performing content profile visits
website clicks and much more
and there you go that's everywhere
Facebook and Instagram can help you with
marketing
now we've laid out the facts for you
keep in mind your requirements and make
a wise choice now let me tell you about
simply lens postgraduate program in
digital marketing that is created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide we will explore SEO
SCM content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start welcome to today's training
where we will be talking about YouTube
channels we're going to be talking about
what are YouTube channels how do you set
them up how do you optimize them and how
do you subscribe to them but before we
start let me quickly introduce myself
IMR kempman I will be your digital
navigator for this video and if you
liked the video please click the like
button or if you want to join our
YouTube Community why don't you hit the
Subscribe button
so what's all this about in YouTube why
is YouTube so popular what makes it so
special and why do you need a YouTube
channel well the numbers they speak for
themselves over two and a half billion
people open YouTube at least once a
month that is one third of the world's
population
YouTube generates around 30 billion
dollars of Revenue in 2021 that is 78
million dollars a day these are
extraordinary amounts and this is
primarily advertising Revenue
now 25 of global mobile usage is for
YouTube it's one of the most popular
mobile apps and YouTube is the main
source of video for 78 of its users look
at the younger generation they don't
watch terrestrial TV they watch TV on
YouTube so on the back of this a whole
community of video creators have emerged
people who go on YouTube to present to
share to discuss to debate to invent to
compare and become famous with posting
their videos we call them YouTubers and
I don't have to mention people like
Gangnam Style Justin Bieber Shawn Mendes
Ariana Grande Dua Lipa and what about
brands that made it big on YouTube the
Dollar Shave Club Blendtec with blend
will it blend and it's the YouTube
channel they use as the social platform
for their videos a YouTube channel
serves as the homepage for a user's
account anyone can view YouTube without
having an account however you need to
create a YouTube channel if you plan to
upload videos add comments or make
playlists but more about how to do this
later businesses can also have a YouTube
channel these channels are different
from the personal channels because they
can have more than one owner of manager
so how do businesses benefit from
YouTube
well posting on YouTube will help people
find you on Google remember Google owns
YouTube by consistently utilizing
YouTube for your business you can
increase your chances of showing up in
the search results and improving your
own rankings
YouTube will also expose you to a huge
Global audience
YouTube is available in over 80
languages and it receives more than 30
million visitors a day who watch nearly
5 billion videos
it's the second biggest search engine
coming only after Google itself and the
YouTube app again as I said earlier is
one of the most popular apps in the
store
YouTube gives you qualified traffic
people on YouTube often have a question
they search for and if your video can
answer the question they have you will
get a qualified lead it's much like
Google search but then it's visual
also video content is 12 times more
likelier to be watched than text to read
video can evoke emotion they can make
you think they can make you feel and if
they make you think and feel you're not
likely to forget those videos and that's
much more that can be said for most
other types of online marketing
video also helped to humanize your brand
they bring it to life taking your
messages from flat and static to Dynamic
and engaging
videos help your brand build trust and
loyalty in a unique way
you can also use YouTube ads to reach an
even bigger audience YouTube advertising
runs on through the Google ads platform
and has some very powerful features and
more about these ads on YouTube later
videos can also be repurposed across
many other channels so they can help you
drive additional traffic to your website
you can share them on your social media
channels you can embed them on your own
website or you can include them in your
email marketing
to summarize video marketing is a must
for your business and if you're not on
the video train you will miss the next
stop
publishing regular videos is key and
YouTube offers you a YouTube channel as
your YouTube homepage for all your
videos so here's a bit more background
information about a YouTube ecosystem
it's important to know that there are
three players in the YouTube ecosystem
there's you the viewer there's the
content creator or the people that
upload their videos and there are Brands
Brands who want to reach you to sell
their products
and it's YouTube's challenge to keep
everybody happy in this ecosystem
to keep you happy to show you the best
videos keep content creators Happy by
enabling them to make some money and to
keep Brands Happy by connecting them
with the biggest audience possible
so how do Brands connect with you very
simple through advertising showing your
short video ads before or during the
videos you watch in fact 84 of YouTube
food viewers both from Brands after
watching videos or ads they see on
YouTube
and then how do content creators make
money very simple YouTube enables them
to earn ad revenue from ads that run
before or during their videos every time
an ad shows in front of the or during
the video they get a percentage of the
ad revenue and I'm sure you've seen
those ads while you were watching
YouTube videos
but not every YouTube content creator
qualifies for this you need to have at
least 1 000 subscribers to your channel
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your Channel
in other words
advertising in YouTube is the oil of the
YouTube ecosystem it keeps everybody
happy
and there are a variety of ads
marketeers can choose from many of them
find pre-roll skippable ads the most
effective you know those ads that you
can skip after a few seconds
just a little side note Here YouTube ads
or mobile are the most effective for the
simple reasons but many people watch
videos on their mobile but also many
peoples have ad blockers on their
desktop so your ads will not be seen on
their desktop
YouTube has recognized the power of
mobile video and mobile ads and has
announced that it will share 45 of AD
revenue on YouTube shorts
now what are YouTube Shorts YouTube
shorts are short vertical videos and
they are YouTube's response to the
phenomenal growth of tick tock and
vertical videos are key these days if
you want to boost engagement consider
using vertical videos
and here's why it has a 90 percent
higher completion rate compared to
Vertical videos
about 80 percent of consumers claim that
the format is more engaging and 65
percent of people find Brands using
vertical videos for their advertising to
be more innovative
so enough of the theory let's look at
the YouTube channels and look at what
you need and how to set up a unit your
YouTube channel
first of all you need a kit to make
videos whether it's your computer your
webcam a camera a smartphone and of
course you need a video editing software
and very important you need an indoor or
outdoor environment to make your videos
and then of course you need to make the
video this will be a topic for another
simply learned video in its own right
but here are a few tips
what make people watch videos
people watch videos when they are
educational
informational
entertaining funny controversial or
shocking
lots of examples in these categories of
videos in YouTube now what type of
videos do people like to watch there's a
whole range of different types of videos
but if you want to look at the most
popular ones you talk about unpacking
videos review videos Challenge videos
whole videos parodies covers live videos
how-to videos is a whole range of styles
of video of topics or video that you can
create whether it's for Consumer videos
or for business videos
now what type of videos can you make
there's a whole range of different types
there's standard format video which is
horizontal there's the vertical video
which I talked about a little earlier
there are stop-motion videos
yeah there are time lapse videos you
could do 360 videos and the big growth
these days is in art is in augmented
reality and virtual reality
yep and then what do you need to think
about when you shoot your video there
are three very important aspects of
making your video think about light
think about sound and think about having
a stable camera position
yeah light is very important there's no
better light than outdoor light and if
you haven't got our if you don't shoot
outdoor but indoor make sure you have a
good lighting setup
sound can be very deceiving if you're
interviewing somebody on the video
outside you think there is no wind but
then when you hear the video back on
your computer you hear the wind it's
it's quite an interesting phenomenon but
it's a fact so best is to have a high
quality microphone that you use when you
interview or when you record your videos
and think about a tripod as well make
sure your camera is in a stable position
so that's the theory behind all this
let's now look at some YouTube channels
and show you how to make a YouTube
channel and here is the simply learn
YouTube channel
a very clear Channel with lots of
content for people to learn about all
topics in um in technology so here you
see the banner yeah with some good
messaging in there you have your logo
here you see the number of subscribers
yep so you see it's a verified account
by YouTube and here is the Subscribe
button yep and when you are subscribed
to a video or to a channel the you get
um sort of personalized notifications or
you can switch off the notifications but
the beauty about people subscribing to
your channel is that they will receive a
notification when you publish a new
video
then here you have a menu of things that
people can go to there's the home page
for all your videos there is a list of
all your videos you can organize your
videos in playlists you can look at the
comments that you're getting in the
community section you can set up
different channels and you can group
those channels under your account and
here is the about page where you have
about information about the company yep
and this is you can optimize this with
keywords so Google will Index this for
the for the search as well so let's look
at this home page again and the um The
Branding yeah so here you see a feature
video
and there are two elements in this area
that are important here first of all you
saw just when I got on the page before I
subscribed you saw a different video yep
and then when you come back to the page
you can see another video so basically
you have a video that you can put here
for first-time visitors where you can
promote your company or your channel and
then you can have another video set up
for returning visitors
and then here you have all your videos
and you can organize them in playlists
and in a minute I'm going to show you
how to set this all up and how to create
your own channel
okay so this is simply learn another
example would be one of my favorites on
social media is social media Examiner
here is the social media examiner
YouTube channel
yes so here you see the the featured
video here you see The Branding very
good branding with strong messages on
there an industry report that people can
download you see here you can put a few
links to your social media or your
website or where people can download for
instance the industry report here you
see The Branding the logo yeah again I
can subscribe to it and then here you
have the descriptions of the video and
the different channels the different
um playlists
okay so then here you have to group the
different channels that they have under
their um their their main channel the
social media Examiner
okay so you see coming back and I see
another video here so finally the other
one I want to show you is GoPro GoPro
they are very active on YouTube very
active on on having videos having videos
from their users from their subscribers
having very clear playlists
yeah so
um and this could be a different
playlists from users the different
products features and what what have you
what you also see here is access to the
store
yeah where they sell products and if I
click on this I can then go to the GoPro
website where I can buy this this
product
so this is an overview of the YouTube
channel on the desktop but as we all
know most people and particularly the
younger generation they watch YouTube
videos on their mobile device so
whatever you do and in The Branding as
well on setting it up you need to make
sure that it looks well and it looks
good on the mobile as well so let's look
at these channels on the mobile device
yeah so here you see the mobile you see
exactly the same elements of it you see
your banner you see your uh your your
logo number of subscribers and your
feature video and then you have your
other videos
yeah so it's a lot easier to navigate
through one thing that you need to be
careful of is that the width of the
banner is not as white as the width on
the on the desktop yeah so in your
design you need to take that into
consideration otherwise half of this
text will be chopped off
yep so this is simply learn if we're
going to social media Examiner
yep so here is the social media examiner
page yeah their Channel again the the
banner and you have subscribed
yep and then here you see a different
color yeah with simply learn it was
brownish here it was greenish you cannot
change this color that is something that
YouTube will decide based on the overall
color it can pick it will pick up on
your um on your desktop on your uh on
your YouTube channel
okay so and again remember the banner
how white you go and then the other one
was the GoPro
yep here is the GoPro Channel
same look and feel here it is grayish
yeah with the banner the logo and then
the um the feature video
right
time to have a look at how I create a
YouTube channel and how I optimize it so
I can grow my number of subscribers to
my channel
here you see the overall YouTube
interface and it's very important that
you get into YouTube and that you sign
in with your Google account
and once you have your Google account
set up and you're logged into your
Google account you can create a YouTube
channel
so how do you create a YouTube channel
here you see a your user yeah and here
you see your user icon and for me it's
just why I haven't put any visual there
yet yep and if you haven't done anything
on YouTube yet then this is the screen
that you will see yeah here you see the
videos that you can all access the
subscriptions how you can explore and
you can use YouTube without having
uploaded any video yourself or without
having created a channel
if you want to upload a video on YouTube
you click here on the plus
of course everything I'll show you you
can do on the mobile as well but my
experience if you are in admin mode and
you want to add text you want to add
your about you want to make different
selections then it's much easier to work
on the desktop so for demo purposes I'll
be showing it on the desktop okay so if
I click here on my user icon I get to
the menu of things I can do in my
account my Google account and my YouTube
account here you see create a channel
I can also go to YouTube studio and in
YouTube Studio I can edit all my videos
and optimize them I can check with
another I can switch to another account
I can look at my membership my date I
can look at the device theme I'm using
the language the restricted mode whether
you want a certain videos not to have
presented to you your location keyboard
shortcuts
Etc but what we're going to be looking
at is the create a channel
so I'll just click on create a channel
and here I'm going to add my name and my
name is basically I'm going to call it
Mark
tube yeah so my channel is called Mark
Cube I can upload my picture here I can
also do that at a later stage so let's
create the Channel first and then I'll
show you how to do The Branding so we'll
click on create channel
yep and then you will see that your
channel is ready so what I can do now of
course I can upload my first video I'm
not going to do that yet I'm going to go
straight into customize my channel and
then once my channel has been set up
I'll show you how to upload your first
video so here is customizing your
Channel
and there are three elements to it there
is the layout of your channel there is
The Branding of your channel and there
is the basic info of your Channel
yeah so let's look at the branding first
but before yeah remember we had the
video Spotlight which was your featured
video
so here you can specify which two videos
you want to have in the featured section
whether it is the video for people who
haven't subscribed and then the feature
video for the people who come back and
have subscribed and then here you have
your featured sections
remember you can have the videos you can
have different sections that you can add
here like popular uploads live past live
streams upcoming live stream the
playlists subscriptions feature channels
all in the menu that I showed you
earlier but we'll come back to that in a
little bit
yeah here is your menu on the left
which is also important yes so and we'll
come back to that in a minute as well so
first we're going to do is look at the
branding
yeah and here I can add my logo I can
add my banner image and I can add a
video Watermark which is standard watch
Mark that will show in all your videos
so very simple we're going to upload the
images so here you see my I've created
these in advance yeah so here you see my
YouTube logo
yep so very simple icon and I can now
select okay what section will I do I
want and make sure it fits within your
image area and you click done and you
have your icon your picture in setup
here you see the banner image you see at
least 2048 by 1152 pixels and six
megabytes or less if I click upload I
then have my banner image I click open
yeah and here remember what you see on
the desktop and what you see on the
mobile so here it is important that you
look at the text that you have on your
banner and make sure that it is viewable
on all devices I'm happy with this so I
click done
I'm not going to do the watermark and
then I'm going to click publish
yep so the changes have been published
so if I'm now going to look at my
channel
view the channel on YouTube you now see
I have my banner I have my my banner
here I have my logo but of course
there's still a lot I have to do I have
to look at work on the about I have to
add maybe some other items in the menu
and of course I have to upload a video
so let's go back to the customize the
channel and what I'm going to look now
is to the basic info so first of all I
have my description so in the
description I'm going to tell people
what my channel is all about welcome
to my YouTube channel
a place
to learn everything
there is to know
about digital marketing
yeah and I can make this as big as
possible very I have a thousand
characters available and very important
think keywords here yeah if you follow
digital marketing courses keywords are
the Cornerstone of your digital
marketing strategy I can add a language
and here I have my channel URL and I can
change this if I want to yeah so it's a
standard web address for your channel it
includes your unique Channel ID yeah but
you can change this as well
yeah so I can say here mark
no actually I cannot change this I will
be able I think to change this let's
have a look
customize a customize URL is a shorter
easy to remember URL that you can share
with your audience and where you have
100 or more subscribers you have at
least 30 days old of your channel you
have uploaded your branding as well yeah
so to have
your number to have your customized URL
you need to have these 100 subscribers
and they have a channel that's at least
30 days old so I can't change this right
now and then here you can add the links
remember the links that you see on your
banner you can add a link
yeah so here I can say the link is Mark
kempman or let's say
simply learn
dot com and I can say https
simply
learn.com yeah and I can add a link I
can say Facebook
and I can say https
Facebook
.com forward slash simply learn and I'm
going to add Instagram
and I'm going to say https
instagram.com
forward slash simply learn
okay yep and then here I can say which
links do I want to show on the banner
yeah I can add a whole load of links
here but then I can say just show me the
first three links on the banner here's
the contact info that is marked at
simplylearn.com yep so here is my about
section ready and then here I can click
publish
and now I can go back to my channel
and what you see now my channel is ready
we have the banner we have the home uh
the logo and now here you see
simplylearn.com the website the Facebook
and the Instagram it will automatically
pick up the logos from the Facebook and
the Instagram and the other social
networks that you want to add here
all right so the next thing is that we
need to look here at the the topics that
we want here yeah we have Home Videos
playlists channels and about so I can
add multiple channels if I want but
let's go back to customizing
yeah so we've done the layout we've done
we're going to look at the layout now
we've done The Branding we've done the
basic info so here is the channel
trailer we're going to do in a minute
when we've uploaded our first videos so
let's add a section and that would be
the created playlists
yep and we want to add a section let's
say a popular uploads okay and then I
can say give me the created playlist I
want to the top
yeah I want the uploaded videos and then
I have the shorts and I have the popular
uploads okay and again I'm going to
click publish I'm going back to my
channel
yep so and now you won't see the order
yet because I haven't put in any any
videos of course but you will see as
soon as we start adding videos then you
will can you can see that we um that you
get the order that we've specified
Okay so
finally before we're going to upload the
video when we go into customizing your
channel you need to be aware here of the
features as well yeah the menu items
that you have so here is your channel
dashboard
so in your channel dashboard you see the
videos that you uploaded and it gives
you basic Channel Analytics
yeah and here you have some news from
YouTube about new features new training
Etc
here you see the content so here you see
a list of the videos that you've
uploaded
their feasibility status is there a
restriction on the video what is the
date that you uploaded and you get some
basic analytics fuse comments and likes
okay here are your playlists that you've
created
here you get your basic YouTube channel
Analytics
yeah you're looking at your comments
that you get so here you can sort of
um review the comments you can set some
moderation guidelines here you can also
add subtitles to your videos now we'll
go into that in more detail when we go
into YouTube and uploading videos and
how to optimize your YouTube videos
but Google will automatically subtitle
your videos and you can edit the um the
Subscribe the subtitles that Google will
uh will do yeah and very important to
remember if you use the Google
subtitles for your video it will not be
indexed for search for the simple reason
that there may be words that Google
misinterpreted in your video so you
always need to edit the video take the
typos the um the words that are
misunderstood by Google change those and
then as soon as you then change the
revised version of the subtitles Google
will then index the um the transcribed
file yeah for search
here is copyright information here is
monetization of your videos it's
important we talked about this earlier
yes so remember where you can have
advertising showing before or during
your videos and that is you will have to
become part of the YouTube Partner
program and once you're a member of the
partner program you'll be eligible to
earn money from your videos but you need
to have a minimum of 1 000 subscribers
and a minimum of four thousand watch
hours on your videos
you need to set up two-step verification
and you need to agree to the community
guidelines
okay here is customization of your
channel yeah we sort of went through
this earlier and then here is a little
nugget in YouTube that not many people
are aware of and that is the audio
library YouTube holds a huge audio
library of tracks and sound files yeah
and sound effects that you can actually
download and add to your videos you can
search the library so it is a huge
library that you can add for free to add
to all your videos
and then finally there is the settings
of your channel so you can specify the
conversion or the currency for your
channel that you'll be using you can
specify the basic info of your channel
yeah you can have the country of
residence in my case we can set that on
the United Kingdom
yep and it can add keywords which is
digital marketing
yeah and I can say social
media and I can say YouTube
Etc
yep there is upload defaults so for
every video that you upload you can
specify a standard element in the title
standard element in the description the
visibility you can specify and public
private or unlisted so prior unlisted
means it will not show in the Google in
the YouTube search results
there is advanced settings that you can
say you can also in your video specify
chapters
and you can spend those chapters will
then be sort of summarized in the
description of your video and that will
be noted in the timeline of your video
as well so it's really good to structure
your videos
there's permissions yeah and this is
where you can invite other people to
make changes or to edit your channel
there is your community that's where you
can set moderation guidelines and then
there are agreements yeah there's the
subject to the the terms of service
okay so those are your settings so very
important that you understand this menu
right so our channel is ready however we
haven't got any video in our Channel yet
so let's go and add a video so here to
add a video we click Plus
okay and we're going to upload the video
or we can also go live
yeah so that's where we're going to do a
live broadcast or a live stream so
upload a video and here I'm going to
draw drag and drop a video or I can
select a file and here is my about us
short infographic
yep so here is the about us infographic
that is the title of course I can make
it as exciting as possible here I can
tell the uh short introduction
to our company
I can select a thumbnail of course I
have it hasn't selected the thumbnail
yet because it is still uploading and
optimizing the video yeah you can then
say what playlist do you want it to be
part of what audience yeah there is an
automatic
catch filter is it made for kids or is
it not made for kids so it's like a
business type of theme yeah here is paid
promotion it's the paper Motion in the
video do you want automatic chapters
allow automatic places you can add text
this is all about optimizing your video
and that is for a different video that
we will be talking about how to optimize
your YouTube videos
okay and then it is going okay so that
is all done we're then clicking next
yeah I can say do I want subtitles do I
want to add an end screen do I want to
add cards remember you see that on
videos where at the end of the video you
see two cards where you can click on uh
to go to another video again I'm not
going to do that for this video and I'm
going to click next
yeah there is some copyright checks on
music and then we click next and here is
the video I can then save and publish I
want it to be public I can schedule the
publication yes so but this is all there
is to it and I'm gonna click publish
so I have now published my video I can
share it straight away on social media
again we're not going to do that I'm
just going to click close And now I see
my video in my content list
yeah I see a thumbnail I see the title I
can see the different details and if I
now go back to my channel
I can see my video in my channel but you
see here I have just put it as an upload
because I haven't added any playlists
yet
yeah so I need to go here to my
customize my channel
and I'm going to click first I'm going
to add the channel trailer and the video
I want to add to this is my about us
infographic and people that subscribed
I'm gonna give them the same video
I am now going to add a playlist
so here are my playlists oh I first need
to
publish this
yeah there we go I'm now going to go to
my playlists and I'm going to create a
new playlist and that is sort of info
Graphics or let's say video graphics
all right and I'm gonna create my
playlists
okay so now I'm going back to my uh
content
and I'm now gonna say go to edit this
video
yeah let's see if the playlists are here
go to the details thumbnail so here I
now in the video details I'm going to my
playlists and I'm going to select the
video graphics playlist done and I'm
going to click save
so now you see if I go back to my
channel
yeah so back to my channel that my
channel now looks slightly different
I have my presentation my featured
videos
okay and I have my playlists
and I have my uploads
yep so this is how you can build your
channel how you can optimize your
channel add videos to your channel add
playlist to your channel
so I hope that was a um was a simple uh
yet effective overview for you how to
set up your channel so so
that is it on the channel so let's
finish today's video with giving you
some tips on how to promote your YouTube
channel
it is very important that you promote
your channel for the simple reason you
want to get
subscribers
yep remember your YouTube channel is
your show your YouTube social media
Network it is where you can develop your
brand it is where you can get people
excited it is where you can build
relationships with people who watch your
videos so it's very important that you
do everything that's possible to promote
your uh your YouTube channel so how do
you go about promoting it first of all
very important in video marketing is the
title of your video
yeah you see here the about us
infographics you see that is the title
of this video is pretty boring if you
look at most titles of videos on YouTube
yeah let's see let's see if I search on
YouTube for let's say social media you
immediately see the titles that are
powerful how social media rewires your
brain is social media hurting your
mental health
yeah like selfies and self-promotion the
hidden dangers of social media
five crazy ways social media is changing
your brain right away
yeah you're a bit more neutral but still
powerful how to develop a social media
strategy step by step these are the type
of things that people like to uh to
watch because those titles are very
engaging
you know hand in hand with the title is
also the thumbnail that you're using for
your videos
yeah so here you see a good example 365
days of journaling that's the thumbnail
that they they use yeah if you go to
social media examiner you see good
examples of thumbnails
yeah and they are all they have the same
color style they have the same bold text
bold titles they still show people yeah
so these are very powerful
thumbnails for your video and look at
yourself if you're doing a search on
YouTube yeah what videos will you most
likely watch videos where you like the
title and videos where you like the
thumbnail when they spring out when they
scream out of the search results
okay so very important that you um that
you look at that
okay next thing how do you optimize your
channel is by making sure that your
videos are optimized
yeah so if I go to my videos your videos
and then here you have your video and I
go to edit the details
I can edit the title the description
remember keywords I can edit the
thumbnail I can edit tags yeah I can
edit
um language lots of stuff that you can
optimize about your videos another
important
factor is make videos that your audience
wants to see
understand your audience yeah in digital
marketing terms we advise our clients to
make customer personas
and customer personas you specify their
pains their needs and everything that
is important for them when they buy your
your product yes so by understanding
what your audience wants
you then can tailor the content of your
videos
to their requirements
the next important aspect of your
YouTube channel is engaging with the
community
it has very important that when people
start adding comments in your videos
that you engage with them
yeah that is one place where you sort of
build your your community you engage
with people but you also engage with
YouTubers in your Market
associated with your Market yeah comment
on other people's videos so start
engaging with other content creators in
building your online YouTube reputation
as it were and start sharing your videos
yeah with them so that is an important
one another important aspect of your
channel is that you need to cross
promote your own videos within your
videos yeah so it's very common if I go
to Simply learn yeah and go to their
Channel and I'm sure they have it on one
of their videos if I go to let's say
here
data analytics
yeah so it's a long course but if I go
to the end of the video
I'm sure you see that here at the end
yeah so you see here at the end the next
video that they promote so you cross
promote your other videos within your
video that you're showing it's a very
powerful aspect of
um the growing your YouTube channel
cross-promoting your video
yeah another one is very powerful it's
what we call video series
yeah they are
very good in driving traffic to your
channel yeah why because people want to
if they like it they will come back for
the second episode
or if they jump in for instance for the
first time in the fourth episode if they
see the episode if they like the
episodes then they say hey I want to
watch episode one two and three as well
so very important is to create series of
videos a good example is social media
Examiner
yeah when you go to the social media
examiner YouTube page and you go to the
playlists here you see the journey
and the journey is a uh basically a
series of videos of the history of the
company yeah so you see episode one
episode two episode three yeah they even
have multiple Seasons yeah of this and
this was very successful in their their
marketing promotion yeah so create
YouTube series
okay so back to my channel another way
of promoting your channel and promoting
your videos is to make sure that your
videos are outside YouTube as well so if
I click on the video yeah and I click
share instead of just sharing the code
here yeah the the URL I'm actually going
to take the embed code so the embed code
gives you an iframe which will actually
show the video on your website if you
add this uh iframe code to your web page
yeah and people will watch can watch the
video on your um your website but it
will count as a few on the on YouTube
yep and then when people click on
Youtube it'll take them to your channel
where they can
um where they can subscribe to your
Channel
yeah we talked about playlists very
important to promote your Channel
yeah the playlists are important and
make sure you add calls to action to
your video at the end of the video get
people to do something to buy something
or to sign up or to register for an
event going live always works in
promoting your Channel
yeah doing live broadcast live behind
the scenes when you're at an event new
live broadcasts really good way to
promote your channel you can promote the
event you can announce the event it will
lead to bus before the broadcast during
the broadcast and after the broadcast
yeah we talked about collaboration with
other creators with other brands and
then of course Very powerful you can
actually promote your own ads by
advertising yeah so I can go to Google
ads I can create a video ad and add a
video ad is my short video and then that
video will show before and during
um videos that people watch
yep and that will drive views on your
videos and Views obviously will turn
into subscriptions to your channel as
well
and then last but not least of course is
publishing your videos and your YouTube
content on social media channels as well
yeah Twitter of course is a very obvious
place to promote your videos but use it
on on other social channels as well now
Facebook doesn't necessarily like it
when you link to the YouTube video
because Facebook wants you to upload the
whole video yes so then people will stay
within YouTube within Facebook to watch
the video but there are other social
media channels where you can promote
your videos as well
okay well that concludes the session
on your YouTube channels
I hope you liked this yeah so remember a
YouTube channel is your social media
Network for your videos on Google and on
YouTube
yep and it gives you a fantastic tool to
widen your reach to reach a global
audience and to start building
relationships with your subscribers yep
and help them in the process of
familiarizing themselves with your
products or your services ultimately
leading to them in buying your product
of your service YouTube ideas for 2021
YouTube is the social media platform
that needs no introduction launched back
in the Year 2005 YouTube was a fresh
breath of air for the people who were
slowly becoming aware of the hype that
surrounded the internet several other
platforms like Dailymotion redmi and VMO
which admittedly have their own fans
have tried to stand up against the
wehemoth that is the YouTube and failed
slowly but surely marketers began to
realize the enormous potential that
YouTube offered they could add small
advertisements like they do in the cable
TV they could show banner ads and do
much more and all of the thanks to the
robust advertisement features that
Google already offered if you're not
already sold on why it's important to
advertise on YouTube here are some facts
that might change your mind YouTube has
more than 2 billion users across the
world a good fraction of that audience
could be shown your product and could
turn from users to customers next
important fact is that 8 out of 10
marketers consider YouTube to be one of
the best platforms to advertise their
products and services followed by that
people watch one billionaires of YouTube
per day as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
YouTube to post content this could be
just videos on their products tutorials
event announcements and much more
seventy percent of the YouTube watch
time comes from mobile this means that
when you create an advertisement for
YouTube you keep the mobile users in
your mind and finally 90 percent of the
people say that they've discovered new
products or brands on YouTube which
means that by posting on YouTube your
brand awareness is highly likely to
increase now let's talk about the video
ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience how your business
or brand operates a creatively made
video on the inner workings of your
business will show off a more human side
of your brand and make you more
relatable to your audience it is also
guaranteed to get you loads of views and
engagement here's an example how Amazon
showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects of its products it
takes the viewers into the factories and
involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like Amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall process
next we have the company culture a video
that highlights your company culture
will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure the
company works in the way it does this
can help better connect with your
audience here's an example a company
culture video created by GoDaddy the
popular domain register
the video talks about how GoDaddy
creates a fun inclusive and energetic
environment for its employees it
includes interviews of employees talking
about why they enjoy working in GoDaddy
so much and this helps the audience
relate with the company and could also
catch up the interest with some
potential job Seekers next we have the
third idea that is the marketing team a
brand is nothing without the people
working behind it and that's where these
videos come in these videos will help
shine a light on the people who create
the products that the audience knows and
loves this helps create a personal
connection with the audience these
individuals can end up becoming mascots
for your brand here's an example of Meet
the team focusing on Olympus group the
video goes into the history of masket
makers brand and the people that make it
a grand success the light-hearted tone
of the video also greatly helps with
making it more relatable now we have
number four product showcase or
announcement
a product Showcase Video aims to show
the features and benefits of the Brand's
latest offering to its audience these
short concise videos can inform the
audience about everything they need to
know about the new product or service a
product announcement video on the other
hand can be used to give the audience a
more detailed look into the product or
service than the product showcase it can
include comparisons to older versions or
competitors the aim of such video is to
show customers how the new product works
and why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
Apple's iPhone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations of what the product
would be like
next at number 5 we have event
announcements these videos can build a
hype regarding an upcoming event it will
also give you the opportunity to engage
with your audience and build their
interest
this promo video for the data Innovation
Summit 2020 Hypes up the event posting
the greatest Minds in the tech the most
Innovative companies and much more
the next video idea we have at number
six is the explainer videos these videos
are aimed to tell users how a particular
product or a service works these tend to
be much more useful than wall of text
explaining how something works they also
have an added advantage of simplifying
complex Concepts and features to your
audience for example we have our own
video on digital marketing we cover a
number of different concepts like SEO
social media marketing search engine
marketing and more on a visual manner
making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer
next at number seven we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights and knowledge that
your users can learn from these videos
aim to be guides to information complex
Concepts hints tips and tricks relating
to your industry here we have our own
digital marketing course video as an
example unlike the previous example I
mentioned this video goes into much more
detail regarding each of the concepts of
digital marketing on that note if you
guys are interested in learning about
digital marketing I suggest you start
from this video it's a great one to get
started with now on the next video idea
at number eight we have the product
tutorial a product tutorial video will
take your audience through the various
features of your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail some additional insights about
your product you can also explain the
best way the product can be used
here is a video of how the meditation
app headspace explains the app's usage
with an interesting and creative
animated video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine we have the webinar a
webinar thanks to its nature provides
your brand with loads of opportunities
to interact with your audience they are
usually very accessible and easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused as video content after the
session is complete here's an example of
Simply learns webinar where we talk to
the industry experts regarding wide
variety of topics while involving the
Audience by having the guest answer the
audience questions whenever possible
next at number 10 we have the live
streams live streams for an event will
help build excitement and hype for the
event it can be advertised on other
social media platforms to generate some
hype as well these videos can also help
you bring up your product to a larger
audience and at a reduced cost
here's an example of a live stream that
constantly keeps a track of subscribers
increasing for some of the most popular
YouTube channels next at number 11 we
have Ama or ask me anything sessions
the AMA or ask me anything sessions are
usually live streams or pre-recorded
sessions that feature questions
collected from the audience although it
originated from Reddit these videos are
finding a success on YouTube thanks to
the interactivity that it offers these
sessions can also give your audience the
opportunity to interact with you provide
suggestions feedback and much more
here's an example of AMA session with
the actor Matt Damon where questions
covering a wide variety of topics
collected from Reddit were answered by
him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your Niche can go a
long way to grow your audience these
sessions are doubly advantageous too
firstly you and by extension your
audience get to interact with an
industry style world and since this
video can be shared on your channel as
well as theirs you can expose your
channel to a brand new audience here's
an example of an interview between
Marcus Brownlee a popular Tech YouTuber
with Bill Gates the interview covers a
wide variety of topics and maintains a
pleasant theme throughout let's now go
to number 13 testimonials a testimonial
video help highlight the positive
feedback from a client or a customer
they provide social proof and provide a
unique perspective on your products and
services these videos can greatly help
improve people's trust on your brand
shareability and credibility here's an
example of Simply lunch testimonial
video that covers a learner's Journey as
he crew in his career video thanks to
Simply learn certification a video like
this can be greatly relatable to the
audience and even encourage some of them
to take up a certification let's go to
our next video idea that is the number
14 whiteboard videos a whiteboard video
offers your visually attractive way of
explaining complex Concepts usually this
involves a trained experts breaking
through a complex topic on a whiteboard
nowadays there has also been the trend
of digital whiteboard videos that work
thanks to the visual style and Charisma
of the narrator here's an example of the
Whiteboard video Simply learn created
covering various concepts of social
media marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have number 15
competitions competitions or contest
videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel these videos enable you to
generate fresh and original content with
little from your end
in an interesting example for foldable
flight Channel users submitted their
ideas for paper airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions and saw considerable growth
next we have 16 the lists list videos
are some of the most commonly found
content on YouTube most users enjoy this
type of content thanks to it being small
easily digestible and bite-sized
these videos can cover a wide range of
topics like options to choose from the
best products techniques and much more
the main advantage of these videos are
they provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst in the year 2021
if you are interested don't forget to
check it out at number 17 we have case
studies case studies talk about how your
product or service have benefited
clients and users
videos like this can greatly improve
relatability and making your brand seem
more likeable
here's a video that analyzes Coca-Cola's
marketing campaign and what it made one
of the most popular brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily for a brand but for
individual creators at number 18 we have
Tech unboxing these videos usually
involve packages being open for the
first time while these are fairly common
for technology these videos have also
found success in fashion apparel these
videos enable the users to experience
the products for the first time
sometimes even helping them decide
between rival products here's an example
of PS5 being inbox by Marcus Brownlee
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers and
other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews where tech reviews you
can talk about the various features of a
particular product what you liked about
it what you didn't its price and other
practical information and much more
here we have an example of OnePlus 8 Pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features advantages disadvantages
and much more and finally we have number
20 reaction videos reaction videos are
exactly what the name says you giving an
emotional reaction to something like a
movie trailer music video or TV episode
these videos encourage a large amount of
Engagement from the audience and make
your brand seem more relatable here's an
example of a reaction video involving
teenagers reacting to the latest tech
talk videos these videos usually enable
a large amount of likes comments and
shares keyword research so basically
what we want to do is Center our
keywords just like our website we want
to set our keywords around or our
content around good keywords so the
videos on YouTube are no different than
the web pages on our website so if we
have somebody who states YouTube is the
world's second most well well-known
engine well it is because it's right
behind Google it's not a search engine
per se it's a video platform but if it
was a search engine it'd probably be
second right behind Google so YouTube is
pretty popular majority people use
YouTube search every day to watch videos
on a number of different topics so they
can find these videos in Google but
because YouTube's so powerful and so
popular people go directly right into
YouTube for their searches and so the
whole idea behind YouTube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on YouTube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on YouTube just like for those of
you who watched any of the SEO videos we
produced it simply learn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on Google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
Google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
the first thing is search suggest so
YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns rank
number one from a machine learning
tutorial but there are other videos that
show up in my search result so we want
to be able to use the search suggestion
box in the search box field so when
we're typing in something you know
YouTube just like on Google is going to
give us those suggestions so if we're
focusing a video on machine learning
then you know we have some ideas of some
other keywords that we could center
around because these are are popular
keywords these are key words that people
are using to search on YouTube so that's
one suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title description and then once you do
that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all of them ever wonder if
there's an easier way to go back so here
I can see all the videos sort by most
popular once you do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn I click
on that video it's automatically going
to start playing but what I could do is
simply just look at you know the content
description so just by clicking show
more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right click in view page Source do a
control F for keywords and and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you could see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine learn
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I can see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tag tags for that video further
down I can also see some Channel tags
but really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with key words that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords that are disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume in the
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
key keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from there
is well aligned because it's in the
title it's in the copy and it's aligned
as a keyword tagged with the video so we
know that that keyword has good volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction and machine learning
primary keyword is machine learning
Basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords what is
machine learning because somebody who
doesn't know machine learning is
probably going to type in that keyword
and then introduction to machine
learning is a good secondary keyword
because it's explaining the basics of
what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning and introduction to machine
learning so that's the whole idea behind
choosing keywords you want that keyword
that really is going to define the
content and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video results page
so what I mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on Google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you can see we're ranked
number one so you even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's education additional to include
that keyword tutorial or how to so for
every video title YouTube has a limit of
a hundred characters so we really have
to pick and choose really wisely so if
we look at the video that we were
focusing on a couple of minutes ago so
machine learning Basics here we could
see under 100 characters we have machine
learning Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
the those catchy words and numbers to
gain High click-through rates just like
you would on the title tag of your web
page we want to do the same with our
video title because the video titles
what's going to show up in search so if
I go back to you know search here we
could see you know data science tutorial
data science for beginners so we want to
make sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember clicked array is clicks divided
by Impressions and an impression is how
many times your video shows up and the
search results on YouTube or Google so
we want to keep our click-through rate
high and in order to do that we want to
be able to write some really good title
tags for our video so use catchy words
like a number or how to or what is
because that's going to resonate with
people when they're searching now for
the description what we want to do is we
want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if I go back to
my video here machine learning Basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube now let me tell you
about simply lens postgraduate program
in digital marketing that is created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide we will explore SEO
SCM content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you'll have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start in today's video we are going
to talk about YouTube SEO we'll be
covering what it is what you need to
know how you can optimize your videos to
get found on YouTube and how you can use
it to maximize your views but before we
go into this let me introduce myself I
am Mark kempman I am your digital
navigator for this video and as usual if
you liked it video click the like button
and if you want to join our YouTube
channel click the Subscribe button below
so you become part of our wonderful
Youtube Learning Community on on simply
learned YouTube channel so are you ready
to start let's get into some numbers
here yeah let's give you some
interesting stats about YouTube Before
We Begin and I'm gonna show you that
YouTube has to be part of your digital
marketing strategy Did You Know YouTube
is the second biggest search engine only
after Google there are 98 different
language versions on YouTube making it a
global social network now it would take
a lifetime to watch all the YouTube
content that's uploaded in the last hour
only so it's amazing amount of content
that is being uploaded we as the world's
population we watch about five billion
videos every day on YouTube
did you also know that YouTube
advertising is very important to YouTube
and to Google here they generate more
than 30 billion dollar per year in
advertising revenue and on top of that
YouTube has around 2.5 billion monthly
active users making it the second
biggest social media Network in the
world so do I need to convince you any
further that YouTube has to be part of
your digital marketing strategy
so let's talk about what you can do to
increase your chances that your videos
are going to feature in the YouTube
search results and in the
recommendations by YouTube
let's check about what we're going to
talk about in this video we will be
giving you an overview of what is
YouTube SEO
yeah how do you optimize your videos for
YouTube
um how does YouTube search work and how
does your YouTube search engine
optimization work I'm going to share
with you about 10 tips for optimizing
your video for search on YouTube and
then at the end I'm going to share with
you my favorite YouTube SEO tools I will
also show you in a demo where to find
all the tools that you can use within
YouTube and within some of those tools
to optimize your videos for SEO
so let's start with explaining what is
YouTube SEO as mentioned earlier YouTube
is the second most popular search engine
right after Google in fact YouTube
searches are actually more in numbers
than Microsoft Bing AOL and ask.com
combined so we're talking about a very
important part of your search strategy
YouTube as I mentioned earlier has about
2.6 billion active monthly users as of
2022 making it the second biggest social
media Network
only
um proceeded by by Facebook yeah so now
SEC 62 percent of global consumers say
they use YouTube and since the creation
of YouTube its Mission has been to
provide fast and easy video access to
users and the ability to share videos
frequently and since then it has grown
Beyond expectations now with so many
people uploading videos on the one hand
and watching videos on the other hand
how you do you make sure that your video
features in the top of the YouTube
search results
and that's where YouTube SEO plays a
vital role
so before I explain YouTube seo let me
give you a little bit of a history about
YouTube late 2004 an idea for a website
for users to upload video dating
profiles was born and in February 2005
the website launched to a small subset
of users as I said earlier I say video
dating platform now based on feedback
from their subscribers in April 25 or
April 2005 YouTube turned into a free
video hosting platform where each clip
had a unique Link in April 2005 the
first video ever was uploaded on the
website by one of the the YouTube
Founders and in May 2005 YouTube
launches its better version to the
public for the first time and it became
a massive hit in a year later October
2000 and six Google acquired YouTube for
the not too small amount of 1.6 billion
US dollars in 2007 YouTube allowed
YouTube creators people who upload
videos to earn money from their content
based on ad Revenue yet turning their
hobby into a career and that of course
gave a tremendous push of people getting
into YouTube creating content for
YouTube where they could link it to
advertising where they could make a
substantial income now in no November
2008 YouTube expands it ad offering to
sponsored videos and free pre-roll ads
and in 2009 they launched a new music
video service called Vivo in
collaboration with fevendi so it moved
on in 2010 one of the most famous
YouTubers Felix kelberg joins YouTube to
create content under the Channel's name
pewdp and that is now one of the biggest
channels that you can find on YouTube in
April 2011 YouTube entered the broadcast
business launching YouTube live and in
August 2012 2012 it became the go-to
place for presidential elections by
launching the YouTube elections Hub it
grew exponentially and by 2013
YouTube had reached over a billion
monthly users
some other interesting facts in January
2016 the music video for Adele's hello
was the fastest video on YouTube ever to
hit 1 billion views
and a very strategic move for YouTubers
in November 2018 when they rolled out a
stories-like feature YouTube shorts yep
where they would sort of relate to
Snapchat and Instagram stories where
videos are automatically deleted after a
day
in November 2019 YouTube announced that
the service would phase out the classic
version of YouTube Studio yep and to all
YouTube creators by Spring 2020 and I'll
show you later what the latest version
of YouTube studio is all about in July
2021 YouTube did a massive cleanup of
all unlisted videos prior to 2017 were
set to be private making them unplayable
and in 2022 YouTube becomes the second
biggest social media Network after
Facebook so a whirlwind of a development
of a growth of an adoption in the market
it's being played and being used all
over the world and it is the channel of
choice for the younger generation to
watch TV and to watch video so a
spectacular development for a fantastic
channel so what is YouTube SEO now
YouTube SEO is a set of activities that
you need to do to enhance the search
rankings of your YouTube videos and or
your YouTube channel in other in other
words when a user does a query on the
YouTube search bar yeah which is related
to your videos what you do what do you
need to do to make sure that your video
features higher in the YouTube search
rankings or in the recommended videos
based on that search
now many businesses of today they see
the power of search for a YouTube it has
showing up and the importance of showing
up higher in the search results it helps
them to reach more people because more
people will click on the the video links
it helps in building and promoting their
brand it helps them in creating customer
engagements more people will like the
videos more people will engage with the
videos and it is a great opportunity for
Brands to Showcase their expertise so it
is a no-brainer for businesses to be on
YouTube these days and to put all the
effort in place to show up high in the
search rankings
so as you know the engine of a search
engine is what we call the algorithm so
before we dive a bit deeper into YouTube
SEO let's have a look at this YouTube
algorithm YouTube says in their own
documentation that the algorithm is a
feedback loop in real time that
recommends videos to individual viewers
according to their different interests
now quality of the user experience
wasn't
that important at the initial start of
YouTube for the first seven years
YouTube rewarded videos that got the
highest number of clicks or views
yes so all based on number of clicks and
number of views but soon content
creators started to abuse the algorithm
approach and tricked people into getting
more views because of clickbait video
titles or catchy thumbnails so Google
had to do something about this and to
tackle this misuse of clicks and Views
and improve the user experience
today announced an update to the
algorithm in 2012. they prioritized
considering videos that had higher
attention time a higher watch time a
longer watch time
but still YouTube wasn't able to provide
what an individual user was looking for
so in 2016 they announced another update
to their algorithm and that's where they
announced to do to use machine learning
and deep neural networks for its
recommendation system completely
changing the user experience of a
YouTube user in other words YouTube is
focused on hooking users into valuable
addictive content based on their
interests
yes so how does YouTube SEO work
let's dig a bit deeper into the YouTube
algorithm overall the YouTube algorithm
affects the search results and the
recommendation streams so what do I mean
with that
in response to a user's query the
YouTube's algorithm analyzes videos
across thousands and thousands of
channels to return a list of the most
relevant videos
and the YouTube search results are
highly affected by YouTube's algorithm
yeah and the factors that will make your
video pop up in a user search query are
your videos comments the likes the watch
time you can call this engagement
your videos titled the description the
keywords the tags we call this the
metadata that matches the user's query
yeah so a lot of reasons yeah why the
YouTube algorithm picks your video to
show up higher in the search results
now the algorithm goes through a
two-fold process for recommending videos
to a user
yeah there is the search results but the
second part of this the SEO is the
recommending video to a user which you
see on the left side after your search
results first it ranks video Based on
data of their performance Analytics
so for instance videos that are trending
they have a higher priority
second it matches videos based on the
user's history and the similar content
they may have watched earlier so
ultimately they would end up spending
more time on the platform going through
as many videos as possible automatically
watching as many ads as possible
so now you got an idea about the end
goal of YouTube's algorithm in 2022 and
how it works to create a better user
experience
right now that you understand the
YouTube algorithm
how can you make this algorithm work
with you
what I'm going to do here I'm going to
share 10 tips with you on how to
optimize your videos for search so let's
start with tip number one tip number one
is to make sure that you conduct your
keyword research before you optimize
your videos
make sure your keywords are relevant to
your video
because they allow YouTube to determine
the video topic and index the content
and relate it to the user queries
so here are five simple steps for you to
do to do your video keyword research
first start with topics that you want to
be an authority for
identify those topics and then for each
of these topics you generate keyword
ideas you find those keyword ideas by
going on YouTube for the YouTube
suggests and you can go to Google as
well you go to other video platforms you
go to keyword recommendation tools
yes so you generate keyword ideas then
for those keyword ideas you're going to
look for monthly search volumes and the
difficulty for those keywords how
difficult is it to get a higher search
ranking for those keywords
and there are tools that you can use to
find out about these keyword metrics
you're then going to conduct a YouTube
serp analysis so you're going to analyze
the search engine result page for your
keywords and find out what you can see
yeah it's a serp analysis is very
important because it helps you to
determine the types of keywords that are
currently ranking for that keywords or
the type of videos that are currently
ranking for that video
it helps you in determining the quality
of those videos and it also helps you in
determining the search intent for those
keywords why are people searching for
those words is it with a buying intent
is it with a learning intent or is it
with an informational intent
and the fifth tip on your keyword
research is to select those Target
keywords that are the most that have the
I search volume of the the the the the
best competitive difficulty yeah so it's
finding the right balance and come up
with a list of keywords that you can
start using for your videos
and then you're going to assign those
keywords to your video
yeah and make sure that those keywords
are relevant to the content
and that you use them in the title that
you use them in the thumbnail that you
used them in the subsid the the
transcription of the video and I'll tell
you more a bit about that in a little
bit yes so it is all about capturing the
content of the video make it unique and
encouraging viewers to watch your
content so keyword research is a very
important topic
second is to make sure that you use the
right title for your videos
titles is critical there are two
elements of your video that will decide
whether people watch a video or not it
is the title of the video and it is the
thumbnail of the video and more about
the thumbnail later so get a good catchy
title
make sure your keywords are in your
title as well yes so it's not only about
explaining the content of the video in a
very strong title but also
encouraging people to click on the video
link
yeah so your keywords and your title
play a very important role in this
right let's look at the third tip that
is the description of your video
yeah and for the algorithm the
description is very important the
algorithm uses the description to check
the topic of the video so make sure that
your description includes the keywords
as well
so the video description is the text
below each of your videos and viewers
can read the YouTube video description
by clicking on the see more button below
the video
yeah so these descriptions usually
include a short explanation of what the
video is about including the relevant
keywords links to any resources
mentioned in the video maybe affiliate
links website links maybe social media
handles
definitely asked if you were to
subscribe and chapters and timestamps
and Google now has the feature to sort
of split up the content of your video in
timestamps and people can jump from
timestamp to time stamp
so YouTube descriptions including all
the right elements like the informative
text the links the buttons they can help
the viewer to discover your video can
help you to increase your subscribers to
increase your views and to increase your
watch time
so tip four is about tags
very important to add tags to your video
YouTube uses tags to effectively index
and search for videos but also to
suggest other videos you might be
interested in
they help again the YouTube algorithm to
understand what your content is all
about and to serve it to the right users
so here are some best practice tips on
using tags don't overdo them don't use
too many tags
use trending text yeah so find trending
topics with YouTube Auto suggests
yeah so and use those trending text be
specific with your tags for example a
road trip is a tag that is less Broad
and has a higher chance of ranking well
in search engine than for instance the
word vacation because that is too
generic
also includes synonyms think about the
words your audience is likely to use
when describing a topic of your video
and use those synonyms to broaden the
reach of your tax
and if you're you out of ideas user tag
generator to identify related and
potentially trending tags a really good
tool for this is tune pocket
right let's move on let's go to the next
tip tip number five YouTube creates
transcriptions and captions for your
videos
and you can create your own
transcription
because the algorithm can't interpret
visual content only text and code so if
you can transform your video in text
through a transcription that can really
help in your search Effectiveness so a
transcription is the translation of what
is spoken in the video
and you can use this transcription for
subtitles in your video as well
they will also help you to generate
captions for your timestamps in your
video now very important YouTube will
automatically generate a transcription
file
but be aware this transcription file
will not be indexed for search the
because the raw file may have typos or
wrong translations wrong interpretations
from the Google automatic transcriber
so what you need to do is that you edit
the transcription file and take out a
typo and the mistakes and once you've
done that you've then uploaded that
transcription file up to your video and
once you've uploaded It Again YouTube
will then index the file and use it for
the search
so very important and I'll show you
later where you can find the
transcription file
tip number six think about the length of
your videos
focus on both the watch time and the
video length
and let's be realistic about it if it
takes 20 minutes to explain how to do
something yeah on your video then make a
20 minute video if you can say it in one
minute then make a one minute video
Don't Waste people's time by stretching
out a Content just to hit a certain
number of minutes it's not about how
long your video is it is about when
people stop watching your video
if you can keep watching if you can keep
people watching longer than average then
you'll get more views and eventually you
will get more subscribers
now YouTube wants to recommend videos
that people stay engaged with or in
other words watch longer so if you can
increase your watch time for your videos
then YouTube will reward you with better
rankings in search results and
recommendations across their site which
ultimately leads to more viewers
so a good way to keep people engaged is
to use screens and YouTube cards
and that is tip six
yeah so an end screen is the YouTube
feature that appears in the last 5 to 20
seconds of your video
and you can use it to promote videos
playlists merchandise and external
websites your end screen can help you to
get more views more traffic and
subscribers from every video
YouTube cards are a bit more flexible
they are interactive cards that you see
throughout a video
that let you share clickable links to
relevant content throughout your video
you can use those cards to promote a
related video or playlists to promote
your YouTube channel to encourage
viewers to take a call or to take a poll
to direct responses to a verified
off-site location like a specific
landing page or to ask viewers to donate
to a charity this will only work for the
US by the way so non-us
viewers cannot do those donations to
charity
right next tip
mixtape is making sure that you increase
audience engagement by increasing the
watch time of your video
yes so this is all about the content of
your video
and be clever with the content in your
video try to use elements of surprise in
your video or changing the pace of the
music or ask for audio participation for
instance by adding a quiz in your video
very important to maintain people's
interests
yeah and some other tips that you can do
to keep people's interest is to make
sure you have a strong video opening
yeah where you captures people's initial
interest to make sure that you use
chapters in your videos yeah because
that will give people a guideline of
what to look out for use pattern
interrupts as we call them like music
paste different Graphics different
camera angles or you storytelling
techniques why are people so interested
in stories because stories use
techniques like good and bad yeah or one
extreme to The Other Extreme yeah to
actually keep people engaged in the um
in the story maybe create longer videos
for a more targeted audience where you
know they have a better interest in
watching your videos maybe look at
developing a series of videos
yeah because then you build up loyalty
and you build up kind of a viewer
membership for your video series and
then obviously use the YouTube insights
YouTube analytics to learn about how
effective your um your interrupts in
your video are
final there then there is tip number
eight
tip number eight is an obvious one make
sure that in every video you upload on
YouTube that you promote your channel
and promote the likes the people to like
your video yeah at the beginning and at
the end of your video just like I did on
this video and I'm doing it now if you
like this video click the like button if
you want to subscribe to our video click
the Subscribe button or subscribe to our
Channel yeah very important that you do
that
now a tip that is often overlooked is
the power of the thumbnail
yeah people make a decision as I
mentioned earlier to watch your video
based on the title of your video and the
thumbnail and the more exciting your
thumbnail the more likely people will
click
yeah so now YouTube will create
thumbnails for you but if you don't like
them you can also upload your own
uh your own thumbnails so you can design
those on any tool um any creative tool
make sure that if you upload your own
videos that they accurately represent
your videos
include a shortened version of the title
of your video
yeah make sure that the text is large
enough to read Because particularly on
mobile and remember about 60 percent of
people watch YouTubes on their mobile
yes so make sure that the text is large
enough to read use contrasting colors to
capture the attention make sure that you
pay attention to White space between the
images and create add your brand logo to
your thumbnail as well and the final tip
it goes out it goes without saying tip
number 10 make sure your video keeps
your viewers attention
yeah your videos have to be unique they
have to be different they have to be
engaging
the best videos are controversial
educational funny or shocking
check your analytics your YouTube
analytics to see and to analyze your
viewing behaviors learn from that and
tailor your content to what you learn in
your Analytics
okay so those are the 10 YouTube SEO
tips and now let me show you where to
find all this in YouTube
so if you go to YouTube
yeah I'll show you here this is of a
company
um and this is their YouTube kind of
Channel yeah if I go to the channel of
the company then here you see the
channel it is a shoe store and here you
see their videos now I'm not going to
explain the channels to you but here you
see if you go at the top right okay you
see this little photo here you're gonna
click I'm gonna switch the account I'm
going to my
solution and I'm gonna here have the
dashboard I'm going to look at the
content this one
how we made two and a half thousand
African kids happy with a pair of shoes
so here you see the metadata of this
video
okay so let me show share with you the
elements that we discussed first of all
there is your video title that you can
add here
right how we made two and a half
thousand everything gets happy with a
pair of shoes then here you have your
description
remember keywords actually what I did
here I took the script off the video and
put it here in the description yeah you
have a lot of characters available here
I always start a description with the HD
with the website
because that is another free opportunity
to get a link to your website
yes so there is your title your
description then if I scroll down
then here you see your thumbnail
I've picked a thumbnail yeah the one
that YouTube created for me I can also
upload my own thumbnail
okay I'm not going to go into the
details I'm just focusing on the
elements that we discussed so here you
see show more and this is where I can go
2D automatic chapters
yeah so those are the chapters that
YouTube will create for you and here you
see the tags
so this is where you can add all the
tags for your video
okay
and then you have the language recording
date
Etc
and then finally here you have the
visibility here you have the section for
subtitles or transcriptions and your end
screen and your cards remember what we
talked about
so let's look at these subtitles
here you see the file
that YouTube created and that we have
updated as it were took out the pilots
YouTube does this automatic you can
download it and then you can edit it
so very useful very powerful tool and
this is by the way if you need to
transcribe any text for any particular
reason yeah just upload to text as a
video on YouTube and YouTube will
transcribe it for you
yep and then when you play the video
there you see here how the text
this is how
she belongs to 40 of the African
population yes so extremely powerful
feature of YouTube the the
transcriptions so close that and then
here you see your end screen that you
can pick so you could a video and a
subscribe you can put it at the bottom
you can put it at the top you can put it
in the middle or you can relate to two
videos and here you see the end of the
video where you can place those uh end
screens
okay and the same with the cards
so here you see the type of car to you
want a video card and then you can say
which video do you want to relate it to
do you want the playlist do you want to
promote another Channel
or do you want to add a link but you
need to be part of the YouTube Partner
program in order to add links to your
cards
right
so that is all there is to uploading
your metadata to your videos a very
important part
to your YouTube SEO
cool let's go on and let's look close
today's session
yeah with sharing my favorite YouTube
SEO tools with you there are five tools
here and I want to actually highlight
two of them number one is canva number
two is social blade tubebuddy a refs
keyword Explorer and sci-fi
so socialblade is a good tool to examine
any popular YouTube video
yeah and then a reps keyword Explorer is
a tool where you can study keywords and
not necessarily only for YouTube but
also for your Google SEO
one of my favorite tools on YouTube is a
tool called tube buddy it is
specifically dedicated for SEO with a
lot of helpful functions yes so it
actually helps you with performance
tracking analyzing keywords yeah and it
is a very simple Google Chrome plugin
let's go to tube
buddy
Chrome extension
yeah here is Chrome tubebuddy
yeah so here you see the tubebuddy
extension and here I click add to Chrome
ADD extension
and you will now see up here that we're
going to add an extension
yeah it has been added to Chrome and now
you see here the um the extension okay
okay so if I now go to a video let's say
simply learn
social media
yep and I pick a video social media
marketing course you can now see that we
installed tubebuddy as a plugin and we
create an account and we logged in and
look at what I see now of the video that
I have on my YouTube screen
yeah I have what we call videolytics
I can see the number of views for the
video the number of comments number of
likes yeah I can see their social
channels I can see their channels uh the
Youtube channels I can see the best
practices does it have a high res
thumbnail have info cards been added and
Screen being added has comments been
pinned Etc so some work to do here and
here I get the tags that are being used
for this video I can also show search
rankings yep and I can have additional
tools as well where I can look at
various elements like search ranking
share tracker Etc so a very powerful
tool on YouTube through tubebuddy that
gives you a whole load of
metadata of each video so if you are
doing a social media video and you want
to upload it on YouTube look on
videos that are similar to the one that
you want to upload and look at their
tags look at their best practices learn
from that and you can use that for your
own video
okay so that is tubebuddy and then the
next tool I want to share with you is a
simple editing Graphics editing tool it
is a tool called canva
canva is what I call photoshop on
steroids it is a very easy site to
create Graphics to create thumbnails to
create Graphics that you can use on your
videos and there's even video Tools in
here as well that you can use yeah you
can create a design you can just say
let's see what you can create
specifically for YouTube you can do a
YouTube Banner a YouTube channel logo
YouTube display ad a profile picture you
can make YouTube Shorts YouTube
thumbnails YouTube video chapters so
lots of stuff that you can create for
YouTube where it has a set of templates
for you that you can use in your in your
design for your YouTube video or your
YouTube channel
so very powerful tool I love can Farm
yes Sophie is a good tool for
um for analytics so you can bring your
YouTube analytics into sci-fi create a
dashboard and it allows you to monitor
success of your videos and your top
ranking keywords so lots of great tools
that you can use for optimizing your
videos and my favorite are tubebuddy
canva and SciFi in today's video we are
going to be talking about YouTube ads
we'll share with you what they are what
type of YouTube ads are available how do
you create them what are the benefits
you can get with them so there's a lot
to cover in this topic of YouTube ads
but before that I am Mark campman I am
your digital navigator for this video
and as usual if you like the video click
the like button and if you want to join
our Channel click the Subscribe button
that you you can find under this video
but before we go into the topic of
YouTube ads let me share with you a new
program that simply learn has put
together together with Purdue University
marketing land search engine journal and
yes meta as well and the good thing
about this course is that you will get
all the skills in digital marketing to
easily complete the meta blueprint
courses as well which are very high
standard courses on everything you want
to know about Facebook and Facebook
advertising so I can highly recommend
this course
and just follow the link and the link
will be in the um in the notes below the
video as well so don't hesitate but join
this video right enough about this let's
go straight into
um YouTube advertising now let me give
you some history to begin with in 2007
YouTube introduced the ability for
creators to monetize their videos with
ads yes so welcome back to that later
there are three players in YouTube
advertising there is the YouTube
creators there are the brands and there
is Google itself of course well the good
thing about YouTube ads that is brands
are able to reach an audience and video
creators in YouTube they are able to
monetize their their videos by enabling
Brands to place ads before or during
these videos initially these ads were
displayed as overlays on top of videos
or as a pre-roll ad before the video
played now in 2010 YouTube introduced
trueview ads they allowed viewers to
skip ads after five seconds and only
charged advertisers if viewers watched
at least 30 seconds of the ad so that
was a benefit for
um for the viewer they could skip the ad
but also a Ben benefit for the brands
because the people that watch the whole
ads were more likely to engage with the
brand now in 2015 there was a new
introduction from YouTube which was the
six second bumper ads very short fleshy
ads that you can run
um during uh during videos in 2016
YouTube faced controversy yeah when ads
um appeared on extremist and
controversial videos yeah so that led to
many videos pulling their ads and
YouTube really had to get their act
together so YouTube implemented stricter
ad policies and introduced new ad
formats such as sponsored cards and
mid-roll ads in 2018 YouTube introduced
the non-skippable ads for viewers on
desktop devices so you could not skip
the ad in 2019 YouTube introduced at
pods so you could do two back-to-back
ads before a video starts and they can
be skipped after five seconds as well
now today YouTube offers a variety of AD
formats for advertisers including
display ads overlay ads sponsored cards
skippable non-skippable video ads bumper
ads and mid-roll ads and we're gonna
cover these later in this video
all right so let's move on let's talk
about what we're going to discuss in
this video we're going to start with
giving you a short introduction to
YouTube ads yeah what is it where how
can you use it but then look at the
benefits of using YouTube ads and then
of course you want to know what are the
different types of YouTube ads that I
can use and I'm going to share with you
the library of ads that Google has and
which ads you would want to use in what
particular circumstance circumstance now
a very big benefit of YouTube ads is the
targeting that you can do with the ads
so we'll cover the YouTube ads targeting
and then I'm just going to go into
Google ads with you and show you how to
create a YouTube ads and you will see
that it's a very simple thing to do and
then finally we'll close the session
with some tips and tricks on YouTube ads
and that should be it for Google and the
YouTube ads so let's dive straight into
this let me give you a short
introduction to YouTube ads to begin
with so let's talk about video
and advertising with videos video
advertising refers to the use of videos
to promote a product a service or a
brand it's very straightforward video
ads can be displayed on various
platforms like desktop on TV on social
media on websites and it can take
different forms yes so it can be a
pre-roll ad it can be a mid-roll ad and
it can be sponsored content that you can
see on the website video ads are very
very powerful because they are more
engaging and more memorable than any
other type of ads people prefer to watch
things and what they see they will
remember they can convey emotion they
can convey storytelling and visual
appeal making them more compelling than
traditional ads you can also reach a
much wider audience and it can be easily
shared across social media so it
increases your reach and it increases
your brand awareness
now one of the issues with advertising
on desktops is that a lot of people have
ad banners of ad blockers installed on
their desktop and that is a and that
Limits The Reach of General advertising
on desktop and also limits to reach of
your advertising on YouTube
because if I have an ad blocker
installed I won't see any ads on YouTube
now there's different ways of getting
um getting about that yes so try to work
with your um your audience that they
um that they don't use an ad blocker to
have access to your your content but the
reality is that the best platform for
advertising
um is on for video is on mobile yeah
mobile devices they have really they
have fewer ad blockers and you will
reach more people bear in mind that
probably 70 80 percent of people watch
videos on YouTube on their mobile anyway
yeah so mobile devices they're becoming
increasingly popular for video
consumptions video consumption more
people watching videos on their
smartphone therefore a much better area
much better channel for you to advertise
yeah so they can be much more in
effective on mobile to capture users
attention and to generate engagement
because mobiles are more personal and
they're more intimate than other devices
so mobile video ads are more cost
effective you can Target specific
audiences and you can optimize them for
the different mobile devices so
all in all
mobile ads very powerful desktop ads
still a very good medium to use for your
video advertising now let's go to then
to the next level and let's talk about
YouTube ads
so YouTube ads are a form of video
advertising displayed on Google's
YouTube platform
yes so advertisers they can create and
upload videos yeah to be displayed but
then they can turn them into ads that
they can be displayed before during
after YouTube videos or a standalone ads
and they can take different forms as I
mentioned earlier they can be pre-roll
mid-roll display ads sponsored cards
bumper ads and what helps you and the
big advantage of YouTube advertising you
can Target very specific audiences based
on demographics interests behaviors and
a lot more and we'll cover that in a
later section of this presentation so it
can be a very powerful tool for brand
awareness for generating leads and for
driving sales so let's dive a little bit
deeper into this targeting is one of the
most effective
features in YouTube ads yeah so there's
lots of ways that you can Target people
in in YouTube advertising you can do
demographic targeting so targeting based
on age gender parental status household
income you can do interest targeting
targeting based on your users interests
and habits on and off YouTube you could
do behavioral targeting based on a
user's past behavior and interactions
with ads and content you can also do the
remarketing where you can Target people
who have interacted with your website or
with previous ads
you can do custom intent targeting like
targeting users based on keywords and
phrases that they have used when they
searched on Google and YouTube
you can do placement targeting where you
can very sort of specify which channels
videos or types of content you want to
use you can do topic targeting yep so
you can Target videos and channels
related to the specific topics or
categories of your business you can
Target by location
and you can also Target by device so
this again is one of the biggest
benefits that you can get in using
YouTube advertising
another feature is that YouTube ads are
part of Google ads yeah and that is
Google's advertising platform that
allows you to create and display ads on
various Google properties including
YouTube including Google search Google
Maps Google Display Network you can do
shopping ads so it is a fully blown
advertising platform and YouTube ads is
just part of that so it's the same
interface so if you're used to using
Google ads for creating search ads or
display ads and I'll show you later
YouTube ads is just another feature of
that functionality you can even use the
same Google ads account to create and
manage your YouTube ads and you can set
the same targeting options you can use
the same audiences that you created and
you can use the same reporting tools so
very easy very simple to set up and it
makes it very easy for advertisers to
run and to track their campaigns across
multiple platforms
YouTube analytics is another tool that
provides data and insights on the
performance of your YouTube videos and
your YouTube channel and those insights
are very very powerful you can track
metrics like views watch time engagement
audience demographics and it provides
information on traffic sources Revenue
generation if you've activated that and
even audience retention how long will
people watch the video and when do they
drop off and you can learn a lot about
it on fine-tuning your your content so
YouTube analytics YouTube insights can
be used to analyze the effectiveness of
your YouTube ads you can check use it to
monitor your growth of your channel and
to optimize your videos and it can be
accessed through the same analytics
dashboard and the first time YouTube
Studio dashboard and you can customize
and filter the data to get more specific
insights
right so then also you need to
understand
the kind of the ecosystem for YouTube
advertising there are three players as I
mentioned at the beginning of the video
there are three players that are
involved in the YouTube advertising
there is the content creators or the
video creators there are the brands and
there is YouTube or Google
and all three would like to make money
and the beauty is that Google and
YouTube they put together an
infrastructure that allows Brands to
make money and that allows YouTube video
creators to make money
so video creators they have their videos
on YouTube and they have their Channel
and when you
qualify and meet certain
conditions like number of followers or
subscribers to your channel a number of
hours that people have watched your
videos you can qualify
for the advertising sort of partnership
yep and then when you qualified for that
you or Google will add you to the video
Network that Brands can use to place
their ads yes so there is a money making
opportunity for video creators
brands have another objective they want
to reach as big an audience as possible
yeah and that's the beauty of YouTube
there are so many people using YouTube
so many people watching videos on
YouTube it is a fantastic platform to
show their ads on the content before or
during the videos from the YouTube video
creators
yes so the YouTube video creators can't
live without a branch to make money the
brands can't live without the YouTube
video creators to actually reach their
advertising objectives and then Google
YouTube is the third party managing this
ecosystem as it were and Google YouTube
is always sort of doing the The
Balancing Act of keeping both video
creators and the brands happy
yeah so keep that in mind
advertisers video creators and YouTube
the three key players in um in YouTube
so what are the benefits then of using
YouTube ads well let's look at some
numbers the main benefit of YouTube
advertising lies in the size of YouTube
has over 2 billion monthly active users
and it's the second most visited website
in the world
over 1 billion hours of videos are
watched on YouTube every day which is
equivalent to over 114
000 years of video
now the most viewed video on YouTube by
the way is baby shark Dance by pinkfong
with over 9.5 billion views as of
February 2023 and the highest paid
YouTube earner
yeah so in 2021 was a nine year old kid
named Ryan Kaji who earned almost 30
million dollars from his YouTube channel
Ryan's worlds
so not only of course there's part the
advertising partly sponsorships yeah so
there's lots of other ways to monetize
your channel as well so YouTube is a
channel that is out there and it is a
and a fantastic channel to get a huge
reach for your campaign now let's take a
bit dig a bit deeper there are several
benefits for advertisers of YouTube
Because of its sheer sites it gives you
as I said the largest audience reach yes
so with over 2 billion active users each
month it is a tremendous Network where
you can reach everywhere in the world
yeah so you have access to a huge
audience and you can reach a large
number of potential customers that
audience is also very diverse and it
spans all age groups genders and
Geographic locations everybody uses
YouTube yeah so not like Tick Tock where
maybe a younger gen generation YouTube
spends all age groups
so you can tailor your ads to specific
demographics and Target very specific
groups YouTube gives you a variety of AD
formats as we talked about earlier and I
will share that with you so that is a
big menu of sort of options that the
advertiser has
because of YouTube's size and it
Advanced targeting capabilities it is
also a very cost effective way of
advertising with a relative low cost per
impression or cost per click yes so
making it very cost effective and
another big benefit of using YouTube for
your targeted advertising is the high
engagement in user on the on YouTube
yeah YouTube users spent an average of
11 minutes per day on the platform that
indicates quite High engagement and they
have an incline to comment to like to
share the content yes so it's a big
opportunity for Brands to build a
relationship with their key audiences
so here are some more facts about
YouTube's targeting capabilities yes so
in YouTube you can reach 90 of online
audiences in the United States
yeah so YouTube is available in over 100
countries and it supports about 80
different languages now what does that
mean for your targeting yeah so it
allows you to reach users in basically
every geographical location from entire
countries to individual cities or even
zip codes
yeah so they allow you to reach users
based on their language preference so
you for instance you can Target people
who speak a specific language or who
have set their preferred language on the
on their YouTube account
so another interesting statistic that
over 70 percent of in-stream ads on the
YouTube platform are now delivered
programmatically
yeah which basically means there is a
growing Trend towards automated buying
and targeting of your YouTube ads
so all in all the targeting on YouTube
is a big benefit of using YouTube ads
so let's look at some more Benefits
YouTube advertising is very cost
effective but it is important to
carefully plan and execute your
campaigns to maximize your Effectiveness
it can be cost effective based on
various factors like your target
audience your advertising goals and your
budget yeah you're getting different
advertising formats so that can relate
to the cost and the benefits that you're
getting and the YouTube
advertising is typically based on a cost
per view which means you only pay when
someone interacts with your ads and the
average cost per view on YouTube ranges
from let's say ten dollar cents to
thirty dollar cents but again this can
be slightly different based on targeting
ad format and competition
so also use the analytics that you get
here to measure the effectiveness of
your campaign and to measure to to get
the ROI of the campaign that you're
using
now for me one of the big benefits of
using YouTube ads is the increased
engagement YouTube's High engagement and
targeting options makes it a very good
platform for marketeer to reach a large
audience and to build relationships with
the customers
yeah customers spend an average of 40
minutes per session to watch videos so
with over 2 billion monthly active users
yeah you have a huge audience available
that you can build their relationship
with and the good thing is YouTube
videos are very highly shareable so
users they share their videos they share
the ads and they want to share it with
their family and their friends through
social media and messaging messaging
apps
so there's lots of features on YouTube
like comments likes and subscriptions
which helps with this engagement and
helps building the um the the
relationship with your audience
YouTube's recommendation algorithm also
helps to promote videos to users who are
likely to be interested in them and that
increases the reach and that increases
the engagement with your marketing
campaign
so by leveraging YouTube's High
engagement High best targeting
capabilities you can build brand
awareness Drive traffic to your website
increase conversions at a lower cost
compared to traditional advertising
methods
yep and then finally and we talked about
that yeah it is all about the measurable
results that you get and through the
YouTube analytics you get powerful data
powerful insights to optimize your
advertising campaign and improve the
return on your investment on the
platform so you can get very detailed
data in like clicks impress Impressions
conversions so you can really make
decisions on improving your campaign
based on the data that you get out of
the um out of the Google the YouTube
YouTube analytics yeah so you can also
track the performance of your
competitors and Benchmark their
performance against industry standards
and that can help you improve your
campaigns as well
so lots of benefits that you can get out
of YouTube ads and
um that's why it is such a popular
advertising platform because Brands they
really believe that YouTube is probably
one of the best channels for advertising
okay now let's look at the different
types of YouTube ads there's quite a few
of them first of all it is important to
understand the term trueview ads so
trueview is a type of video ad formats
over by YouTube that allows users to
choose whether or not to watch an ad
and with trueview advertisers only pay
when a user chooses to watch the ads
so that can help that you only get
interested users engaging with your
content
trueview ads can be targeted like we
talked about earlier again yeah based on
demographics interest search history
Etc yeah so they can also be optimized
for specific marketing objectives like
Grant awareness consideration or action
yeah so that can help you achieve your
campaign goals so overall trueview ads
they are flexible effective yeah and
allows you to reach a large audience
while ensuring that you only pay for
engaged views
so the first type of ads are trueview
in-stream ads
trueview in stream ads are very popular
and effective for reaching a large
audience on YouTube and for driving
engagement and conversion
so they are a type of Truth you add that
appear before
during or after other videos on the
platform
yes so true few in-stream ads are
skippable video ads so you can skip them
after five seconds so they can be up to
three minutes long and again the user
has the option to skip them after five
seconds and advertisers only pay when a
user watches more than 30 seconds of the
ads or the entire ad if it's shorter
than 30 seconds
or engages with the ad by clicking on a
call to action or companion Banner
okay so those are these true few
skippable in-stream ads
we then have to True view Discovery ads
trueview Discovery ads are a type of
trueview ads yeah that appear in search
results on the YouTube home page and a
long related videos on the platform
yeah whether it's the desktop or whether
it's the mobile they are thumbnail
images with a headline and a description
that appears in the search results and
on the YouTube homepage
so when a user clicks on the add
thumbnail they are taken to the
advertisers video on YouTube
so they can also appear alongside
related videos on the platform and you
only pay when a user clicks on the ad
thumbnail to watch the video
so they are very common you see them a
lot on on YouTube yes so those are the
trueview discovery ads
next the bumper ads I love the bumper
ads they are very creative and a very
effective way for advertisers to make an
impact in just six seconds and reach a
large audience they are a type of video
ad format that are six seconds long
they're short snackable and memorable
they're non-skippable and play before
the video content that users have
selected to watch so they are really
good for advertisers to reach a large
audience quickly and effectively and
they're often used in conjunction with
other AD formats like trueview in stream
ads
they can be targeted to specific
audiences based on their demographics
their interest search history
Etc and advertisers only pay for
Impressions so they pay for instance for
every 1 000 times the bumper ad is shown
right the next one are the non-skippable
in-stream ads a very effective way for
advertisers to reach a captive audience
on YouTube and again to drive conversion
and drive engagement it's a type of
video ad that appear before during or
after videos on YouTube
yeah so they are non-skippable which
means that viewers are required to watch
the entire ad before they can continue
watching the video they selected they
can be up to 15 second long and they can
include a call to action which is very
important yes so to encourage viewers to
engage with the advertisers brand or
products
and you pay uh only when the user
watches the ad to completion or the
first SEC for 30 seconds if the ad is
longer than 30 seconds
right and then you have the outstream
ads outstream ads are an ad type that
appears on Partner websites and mobile
apps but not on the YouTube platform
itself
yeah so they Those ads they often play
on the page rather than in a video
player which means they don't require
users to watch them to continue viewing
the content they have selected they can
just browse on on the page they're
designed to be mobile first and are only
available on mobile devices makes them a
great option for advertisers looking to
reach an increase in Mobile audience on
YouTube
yes so they can be up to 15 seconds long
and can be optimized for specific
marketing objectives like brand
awareness consideration or action so you
only pay when a user views the ad for at
least two seconds or interacts with it
in some way like tapping the ads to
expand it or clicking through the
advertiser's website
right and then there is the must-head
ads must had ads are a premium ad format
offered by YouTube and they appear at
the top of the YouTube homepage
yeah on desktop and mobile devices
they're typically reserved for large
Brands and designed to provide maximum
visibility on the platform
so they can be up to 30 second long and
can include a call to action doing to
encourage viewers to engage with the
brands so it's great for promoting new
products or Services great for building
brand awareness or driving traffic to
your website
so you can run a must-hat ad for a
single day or for a longer period of
time
depending on the goals of your campaign
and costs can vary depending on factors
like the time of the year targeting
options selected and the duration of the
campaign
and then finally there is the overlay
ads so overlay ads is very effective if
you want to drive traffic to a landing
page and to generate leads yeah for a
product or a service but sometimes they
can be seen as intrusive
so it's important to create ads that are
engaging and relevant yeah so they are
display ads that appear on top of a
YouTube video while that video is
playing Those ads are transparent and
can be text or image based and they
usually appear as you see here at the
lower 20 percent of the video player
to promote a product or a service or a
brand they can include a call to action
targeting specific audience so you can
run the overlay ad for a specific video
or for a group of videos in a particular
category or Channel
so cost for defend for the brand depends
on factors like targetings option
selected duration of the campaign and
the competition for ad inventory so as
you can see a whole library of ads
available yes so
um that YouTube has and that you can use
yep so good let's move on let's look at
the YouTube targeting we'll talk a lot
about the YouTube targeting so let's
summarize this targeting on the next
slide
yes so first of all there is the
demographic targeting so you can Target
people by age by gender by income and by
children
yeah so there's the behavioral targeting
so you can Target viewers based on their
search history the watched videos or the
website append activities
you can also remarket people so you can
advertise you know you can show ads to
people who have visited your website so
if you have a website and somebody
visited a particular product page and
then left your website then you can
Target him on YouTube with an ad for
that particular product maybe doing a
promotion
you can look at Affinity audiences so
you can Target certain interests and
trades with specialized audiences and
you can look at similar audiences so you
have a particular audience selected and
then you can ask Google can you sort of
select a similar audience with similar
interests or behaviors so very extensive
targeting options and it is one of the
key benefits that you get out of YouTube
advertising
good
now now how then do I create a YouTube
ad to create a YouTube video ads you
have to go into Google ads yes so you
must have an account on Google ads you
just click sign in
and that will take you to your standard
dashboard for your all your activities
in Google ads
and you will find out you'll see that
Google you or just YouTube ads is just a
particular section of the Google ads so
what we're gonna do we're going to look
at the create so we're going to click on
the create button and we're going to
create a campaign
and as you will probably know with
um Google ads there is goal guidance yes
so you Google will advise you on the
type of goals that you can set for your
campaign and based on the goal that you
specify Google will automatically select
the type of channels it has available
for the advertising
you can also decide to do campaign
creation without goals guidance yes so
what I'm going to do I'm going to click
brand awareness and reach and here is
immediately you can select what type of
AD what type of campaign type you want
to run do you want to do a display ad or
do you want to do a video ads and
obviously since we're talking about
video ads on YouTube then you click here
on video
so you're going to do a video Rich
campaign
yeah you can do an ad sequence by
showing ads in a particular sequence to
individual shoe viewers yes so that can
be really good to show viewers a series
of ads following the customer buying
cycle for instance or you can look at
people or rich people in audience in
audio while they're listening on YouTube
with audio based ads so we're going to
go for a video Reach campaign and then
here you see the type of ads that you
want to do do you want to do the bumper
ads or skippable in stream yeah or a mix
yes so or do you want to do
non-skippable share your entire message
with up to 15 seconds and remember these
are the ads that we talked about in the
ad overview
so we're going for Bumper skippable in
stream or a mix
yep and then we click continue
so here is the campaign name will do
your budget let's say we're going to
spend 100 pounds a day you'll then have
your start date I'll put that a bit
further out
let's say the first of August we're
going to end in two weeks or selected
date
required let's say we're going to end in
two weeks
yeah so there is a 6.67 daily budget so
let's bump that up
I can also say yeah the daily budget
yeah so I'm going to do a daily budget
of 100 pounds
yeah and then here I have the locations
yeah so no and I can be very specific
with my location I can even do a let's
say rg4 I can just Target by
zip code as well
yes so and I can make that as advanced
as possible yeah so here you can see a
map even so if I want RG yeah so I want
rg7 you see how the map expands yeah RG
I can do rg40
or rg9 yes so here I see how that kind
of develops and how you can be very
specific with the targeting for your ads
and here you see an estimate estimated
number of Impressions that you would get
you can pick a language you can do
content exclusions remember we talked
about it where advertisers were not
happy with the um the videos where their
ads were shown so here you can say
content exclusion
and then here in the ads group you're
going to specify your segmentation
that's where you're going to specify
your targeting now I'm not going to go
into the details here but again these
are all the topics that we've sort of
discussed in the presentation
yep and then here of course what you
need is your video ads so here you're
going to specify the link or you're
going to basically add the link of the
video on that you have uploaded on
YouTube of your ads because of course
your video needs to be on YouTube
yep so that is one so you create your
ads on every video creation platform
yep and then you upload that video ad on
YouTube and then you have the YouTube
link and that's where you paste the link
of the YouTube ads
if you don't have an ad then you can
just create one in a few steps yeah and
YouTube actually has a video ad Builder
that you can use now where you can just
use templates how cool is this
yes so now of course you need to be
aware that if you use any of these
templates you're not the only one who
will be using those templates so it'll
make your
um campaign slightly more generic yeah
and maybe not as unique as you would
like but the fact that it's in there is
a big benefit yeah if you need to create
an ad from from scratch but there's lots
of other tools that you can use to
create your video ads yeah so let's just
go to YouTube
.com yeah and I will take a video let's
say from one of my clients so do
that this one how we made 2500 gets
happy yeah so I'm just gonna I guess I'm
just gonna take this link in my ad I'm
gonna paste the URL here
yep and then here you see how your ad is
going to be like yes so here is the
skippable you have your display URL and
your final URL when people click on it
remember that it's the same as with
Google advertising so you can use the
display advertise the display URL as
part of your promotion yeah so that
could be a solution
dot Co dot euk forward slash summer
campaign or something
yeah and then you can have your final
URL as well yeah and then you can add a
call to action in your ad yeah that can
be a headline and here you see how all
of that is going to sort of show on the
on the ad
yeah so lots of ways of adding your ad
here and then you set a bit for your ads
and then you basically create the
campaign and you're advertising your
YouTube ads is ready to be executed when
um based on the timings that you've set
and that is honestly that's how simple
it is to advertise on YouTube just go
into Google ads pick an objective that
has video ads as their one of their
channels then go through the campaign
setting go through the ad group settings
select your targeting and then link it
to the ad that you've uploaded on
YouTube as the ad that you want to use
for this campaign or use the YouTube
Tool to create your video ads in YouTube
good so that summarizes how you create a
YouTube ads and now let's close today's
session with giving you a few tips and
tricks on using YouTube ads so first of
all
keep it short and engaging short simple
and engaging because YouTubers have a
short attention span
and make sure you bring your message
across in the first few seconds of your
ads
try to summarize your ads right to use
storytelling tell a story that moves
your audience that builds an emotional
connection
yeah so think about storytelling
Concepts like there's a hero and there
is an uh there's an enemy so there is a
victory there is
um yeah there are lots of ways that you
can build storytelling elements into
your your YouTube ads don't forget to
add a call to action to your ads because
it encourages viewers to either go for
instance to your website or to buy a
product or to sign up for an event or to
register for something yes so make sure
that you use a call to action in your
your videos and even mention that call
to action in your videos as well use the
right target
um yeah so Target a Right audience so
you add reach the Right audience because
that will give you the best return on
investment on your ads
optimize your ads for mobile that is a
very important tip yes of course because
many people and we're talking probably
about 70 plus view YouTube on their
mobile phones so the ads will be seen on
their mobile phones and very simple yeah
so if you use for instance text on your
ads
yeah on desktop it will be easily
readable but on mobile it may be
unreadable so when you make an ad always
test it on your mobile device as well
and test and check the user experience
that people will get
and then of course continuously test and
optimize your ads to improve their
effectiveness maybe the description of
your YouTube ad or the description or
the title of your YouTube ad or the
thumbnail of your YouTube ads or the
opening of your ads so there may be
different ways test and optimize to make
sure you get the best return on
investment of on your ads now let me
tell you about simply lens postgraduate
program in digital marketing that is
created in collaboration with Purdue
University and meta blueprint with this
program you will learn everything from
the fundamentals of digital marketing to
the latest trends and techniques used by
top marketers worldwide we will explore
SEO SCM content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher and see
what exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing is one of the
most commonly used and lucrative forms
of digital marketing it's a methodology
that has Brands creating and sharing
content on social media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it LinkedIn Facebook or
Instagram you've promptly been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that Burger King video
advertising their new whopper or about a
marketing tool that can help you
visualize your team's workload better
than any other in the market right now
one of these are just some of the many
ways that you've been marketed to and
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
Brand's marketing and branding goals now
this could be increased engagement more
clicks conversions and so on so how do
they do it with text and image updates
videos or any other form of content they
can attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them now alongside
publishing quality content it also
involves analyzing your data and running
social media advertisements
now some of the more popular social
media platforms right now are Facebook
Instagram Twitter LinkedIn and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
first off social media marketing
provides great brand awareness now with
the help of interactions with people on
social media brands are able to build up
their reputation as businesses and with
each interaction each post each share
the brand is exposed to a larger network
of potential customers who might be
interested in the products or services
offered
next it gives you more traffic to your
website marketing your products or
services on social media will also
attract customers to your website
outside of your usual customer base
next it improves your Brand's search
engine rankings now although this isn't
the direct correlation social media
marketing does have a part to play and
it comes in helping your page rank
higher up in the search engine rankings
now if you start posting high quality
content people will start liking and
sharing it and this will in turn bring
it to the attention of influencers
within the industry who would be willing
to write about your business and then
this gives you backlinks which as you
know will help you improve your search
engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates and with your brand
being much more visible and interactive
on social media every text image video
or comment could potentially Drive users
to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting a brand and being more
interested in your products and services
and then we have improved customer
satisfaction when your customers
interact with your brand on social media
it provides you with an opportunity to
show compassion for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective
compared to other forms of digital
marketing social media marketing offers
some of the most flexible and relatively
low-cost options available
now this opens up your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures and
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on your investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders with your high quality
posts communicating with your audience
sharing content and promoting your
Authority you can have your followers
look up to you and this will allow you
to become a figure of expertise in your
industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind the goal
of your marketing strategy may be the
driving force behind every decision that
you make and this is exactly why setting
up goals is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
here are some things that you need to
keep in mind while setting up your goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative for example you need to
have a thousand conversions by the end
of the quarter or 5 000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options number three
make sure your goals are smart now smart
refers to specific measurable attainable
relevant and time-based
now let's go to number four like I
mentioned earlier your goals need to be
aligned with the marketing strategy
and alongside these goals there also
needs to be the North Star metric now
what is the North Star metric well this
represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this North Star
metric will also give your team Clarity
and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
North Stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your audience
social media allows you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
Audience by understanding what they need
want and desire you can deliver content
in a way that makes your product or
service the answer that they're looking
for
there are also other ways that you can
understand them better
this could be surveys to determine the
issues that bother them the age
demographics of Their audience
by conversing with them in forums
responding to their comments and blogs
and social media taking up their
feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learns audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
baijuab has high school students as
users
now let's go to number three determining
the right social media platform
now when performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
When selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform who you will reach
with this platform what content could
work best on the platform and is there
any content that was unique to that
platform like for example YouTube and
then there's the video
answering these questions will help you
zero in on a platform for you
and while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest
now let's talk about the purpose of each
of these platforms LinkedIn is a
professional Network that's best suited
for B2B audiences
for Facebook well just about everyone
has an account on it
content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook and then we have Instagram well
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form video It Doesn't
Really drive a lot of traffic to your
website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four setting up a
social media calendar
a social media calendar demands the
message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
let's have a look at some of the most
popular types of posts on social media
first off we have competitions now I'm
sure all of you have seen posts like tag
a friend who does this or comment or
like to win something and stuff like
that competitions like these provide
great opportunities for engagement with
the audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag in competitions help
grow your presence on social media
then we have polls and surveys
polls can help you if you need a
collection that also encourages
followers to take action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and has so
much more to offer live stream with its
live nature and having a human face
alongside your business humanizes your
brand and by extension helps increase
customer loyalty and trust and then
there is infographics articles and
images
so social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization with it
you can create high quality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule posts on your social
calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer HootSuite
buzzsumo if Triple T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of posts
now for number six visual storytelling
visual storytelling involves passing out
a lot of information in the simplest of
forms visually using pictures and videos
your followers are able to grasp the
message quickly and remember it for a
long time afterwards visual storytelling
is also not limited by language barriers
and this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much more
but it also has some other advantages it
helps you build a bond with your
audience a visual storytelling connects
with your audience methods like live
streaming help humanize your brand and
help grow customer loyalty and trust it
has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
so have a look at some of our videos so
here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and AI in five
minutes now these are some of our most
viewed videos on our Channel and now you
know why visual storytelling if you guys
are interested in watching these videos
you can check them out on our Channel
homepage and we also have similar videos
on blockchain devops and Six Sigma but
now back to the list
let's go to number seven paying for
advertising
this is a method that helps you find a
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goal
and this can help you improve your reach
and improve your Brand's visibility it's
pay per click model and shows cost
Effectiveness by providing great results
and return on investment it also helps
improve targeting by letting you control
who sees your ad you get to choose from
a number of different factors like
interests Hobbies personality types
alongside the basic user demographics
like age location gender and so on
now since most social media platforms
have native analytics you also get to
assess and Define the performance of
your ad campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
peer advertising first of all your
audience could get exposed to your posts
too many times and tune out your content
disregarding it in the process
second it could get really expensive for
small businesses or startups to manage a
campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant or unimportant you also
have to deal with a lot of competition
smaller companies with lesser budgets
have more of an uphill battle to deal
with than better funded organizations
next we have number eight news jacking
newsjacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services now it's a
popular method that's used to improve
brand awareness
newsjacking uses the popularity of
current events and drives it to your
brand it helps shine a spotlight on your
products and it also helps you show off
that you are up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant and by extension it
also improves engagement and website
traffic
now for number nine a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content a b testing helps determine
which of the variants your audience
engaged with the most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
and next up number 10 community and
influences
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry
actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up with
and on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience
it helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in YouTube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influencers we have Marcus Brownlee
unbox therapy Mr who's the boss and
Linus Tech tips each of them with more
than 4 million subscribers
and finally we're at number 11 measuring
and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process it ensures that you're
making the most out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand and these metrics can be tracked
weekly monthly or on a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
so on Facebook you could look out for
reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for impressions
clicks and Impressions and interactions
on LinkedIn and likes comments and
mentions on Instagram and engagements
and Impressions on Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
HootSuite Google analytics and so on
and there you go that's our list here's
your reminder to subscribe to our
Channel and click on that Bell icon to
stay updated on tutorials lab sessions
and the latest Technologies and this was
all for this social media marketing full
course hope you guys found it
informative and helpful if you like this
session then like share and subscribe if
you have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here